come
on le programme de Community streamer de
Chess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre Compte àess.com et profiter de la
visibilité offerte par notre plateforme
de jeu il vous suffit de relier votre
compte à
jess.com/settings/cnectting MRE échec
comm catégorie sur twitch et commencer à
streamer une s expérience sans publicité
sur chess. et apparaîtz dans notre list
de streamer en directre prof.om
affichera vre stream twitch qui sera
aussi mis en avant durant vos
partiesam dans le chat
[Musique]
votre
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe qu'à l'événement et chiikien
sur plus à du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess
oou les titles
chess.com/eventsc quel est le meilleur
moyen de suivre n'importe quel événement
échikien sur plus du monde au tournoi
des candidats en passant par le speed
chess ou les title toesday
chess.com/events C tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec qui se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète a les
commentaires en français de nos experts
moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base
des un essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des roues les prix les
résultats les courprend du quotidien les
PI des joueurs les règle départage et
plus encore participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats TZ de
gagner des abonnements prémium alors
rendez-vous dé maintenant sur jet.com
Flash events sur le site internet sur
vos applications iOS Android pour votre
passion comme nulle par
ailleur quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échipen
sur tour les plus bizarr passant par le
speed chess ou les title Tuesday
chess.com/events tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec qui se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties du meilleurs
joueurs de la planète et des
commentaires francés de nos experts V
moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases des
infos essentielles comme le programme
lesir des r les prix les résultats
lesend du quotidien les T des joueurs
like despartag et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats t de per
des abonnements très bien alors
rendez-vous.com T N sur le site internet
sur application iOS Android etation.com
par quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement é sur
Prat passons par le chess et le title
chest/ vousou les p mocheèque se déroule
en présentiel ou en
L Prz en direct par les meilleures heurs
de la
planèteos experts vre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
base retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les contte rend du quotidien
les Dios des joueurs les règles des
partage et plus encore pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour ê
gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous d maintenant sur
chess.com/events sur le site internet
sur nos applications iOS et Android pour
V votre passion comme d par
[Musique]
ailleurs quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement et sur
plus pr candidat passant par le SPE
chesstle
chess.com/even tous les plus grand com
d'échec qui se déroulent en présentiel
ou
en en direct parti des meilleurs de la
planète
les experts Meur d'analy l'explorat et
les tablees
bas essentiel les programes lesir les
prix les résultats les contends du
quotidien les VIOS des joueurs les
règles des partag et plus encore pou
même participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/ events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
VI par ailleurs
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement éen sur du
monde au tournois des cidat en passant
par
le
ch/ tous les plus grand tournois d'éche
se déroul en présentiel ou en
ligz par meilleurs joueurs de la planète
[Musique]
commentaireur d'analy l'explorateur
d'ouverure et les tables bas des essenti
Programm les hororaire des rondes les
prix les résultats les cont rend du
quotidien les Dios des joueurs les
règles départag et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats TZ de gag
des abonnements pré alors rendez-vous de
Matten
ch.comash sur le site internet sur
Application votre passion
parilleur quel est le meilleur moyen de
bien por un événement
écié id passant par
chess/ T les pour
moéchec en
présentielenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
moteur d'analy l'explorateur d'ouverture
et les tableau bases imp essentiels comm
le programme les horair de r les les
résultats les conf du quotidien les tous
des joueurs les règles partag et plus
encore PZ même participer à la
compétition pronostiquant les résultats
TZ gagner des abonnements prémium en
rendez-vous
dém sur le site internet sur les
applications iOS andro votre comm
parur quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échen
chop du L de de candidat passant par
leess les
ch/ent tous les plus grand tournois
d'échec se déroul
cher
en direct on parti des meilleur do de la
planète en cher moteur
d'alexlorateur et
lestable essentiel
pour résultat les du quotidien les S des
joueurs même participer à la compétition
des résultats gagner des abonnements
alorsz d
maintenant
sur le site internet
appationouv pass comme par
aurs qu est le meilleur moyen de suivre
9 ans g
é passant
par/ t
[Musique]
les en direct meilleur de la planète
comm à expert vre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
base retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les cont rendsus quotidien les
des joueurs les règles des partag et
plus encore vous pouvez même participer
à la compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats t de gagner des abonnements
prémium alors rendez-vous dès maintenant
suress.com/ event auss bien sur le site
internet sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour V votre passion comme nul
par
ailleurs
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échen sur
d'humour tourno des candidat passant par
le SPE chess
[Musique]
tit.com/ tous les plus d'éche se déroule
en présentiel ou en
ligne en direct par meilleurs joueur de
la
planète expert moteur d'analateur
d'ouverture et
Lesable l'essentiel
prog pr résultat les du quotidien tous
les joueurs direct partage pe même
participer à la compétition le sttiant
les résultats gagner des abonnements
prév alors rendez-vous dès
mtenant.ash sur le site internet
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échiken
CHP à du monde au tournois des candidats
en passant par le speedchess les title
Tuesday
chess.com/events cour tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec qui se déroulent
en présentiel etou en lignez comprenez
en direct et parti des meilleurs joueurs
de la planète avec des commentaires en
français de nos experts moteurs
d'analyste et d'explorateur d'ouverture
et les tables
bas essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des roues le prix les résultats
les confant du quotidien les P des
joueurs les règles des partag et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition pronostiquant les résultats
tentez de gagner des abonnements
prémieur alors rendez-vous dès
maintenant sur chat.com/s aussi bien sur
le site internet sur no applications iOS
andro et votre passion comme
[Musique]
du quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement é chiken Surp à
du monde on trouris des candidats en
passant par le speed chess les title
Tuesday
chess.c/events tous les Prs pour Mo
d'échec qui se déroulent en présentiel
ou en ligne
é en direct parti des meilleurs joueurs
de la planète des commentaires en
français salut à tous et bienvenue pour
pour ce live salut le Fab salut k salut
à tous alors attends attends Fab hop
voilà ça y est j'ai la bonne vue et on
est parti Fab pour donc 6e 7e ronde même
du Grand Suisse et tu as pas trop suivi
à vrai dire tu me disait le grand
Suisse jusqu'à maintenant non bon alors
je suis les résultats euh je regarde ce
qui se passe un peu voilà après coup
mais suivre le live en entier non pas
trop donc tu as pas tu as pas encore eu
les les les sensations de jeu entre
guillemets c'est un tournoi F tu vas
voir avec la cadence qui est qui est un
peu un peu long le micro pas ouf ouais
je sais pas lequel le mien attends
normalement on a le même réglage que
d'habitude les
deux
attends
alors peut-être là ça va être mieux il y
a peut-être eu un petit bug on a
tellement fait de régi ça a pu un peu
buoger vous nous direz
ah c'est
bon euh ouais donc je disais ouais je
suivais pas trop les parties en entier
tout le long avec le live euh bon déjà
les parties sont longues avec la cadence
comme ça mais je regardais un peu ce qui
se passait j'ai vu des belles parties
ici ou là moi une que j'ai bien aé aimé
d'ailleurs j'avais tweeté dessus c'était
celle de Douda ouais très jolie partie
ouais qu'on fera peut-être un de C4 sur
la chaîne mais que je recommande à tout
le monde euh cétait la victoire de Douda
contre le petit murzine et voilà donc
j'ai un peu suivi comme ça mais oui j'ai
pas pas pas à fond même si le tournoi en
soit est intéressant et que bah
évidemment il offre le sésam enfin deux
sésam pour aller se qualifier pour les
candidats on va voir Fab en tout cas
aujourd'hui partie de firouja contre
contre Sarana les Français qui sont
assez mal partis en réalité dans ce
grande Suisse puisque maxime est déjà
quasiment éliminé ouais alors Maxime la
seule chance ce serait de faire 100 %
donc ce qui est infime comme chance mais
tant que ça existe on peut pas
complètement l'exclure euh Marc Andria
bon bah de toute façon lui jouit pas
aviment pour se qualifier mais lui c'est
mathématiquement fait que c'est pas
possible on va dire euh cela dit fait
plutôt un bon tournoi au demeurant être
juste à mo-1 à mi-parcours vu la moyenne
affronter c'est c'est quand même plutôt
bien euh alira on aurait bien aimé qu'il
a un pe point de plus euh alors c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est une partie
très très importante et d'ailleurs qu'on
va suivre en grand format euh il est
opposé à Sarana donc joueur russe mais
qui s'est naturalisé maintenant serbe et
euh il joue une Sicilienne 6 il joue le
petit coup fou de ah il veut peut-être
jouer la le fameux truc là cavalier C6
petit rock cavalier F6 euh D5 fou B5
ouais enfin il fait comme il veut mais
oui en fait au pire là-dessus tu peux
aussi prendre en D5 faire D4
euh non mais en fait en gros enfin le
truc c'est que je sais pas ce que Sarana
joue d'habitude mais c'est très
possible ENF oui bon de toute façon F de
c'est un coup qui existe he déjà les Kin
avait joué tu te gardes des4 en en
réserve mais ok un des rares intérêts on
va dire de fou de par rapport à alur de
coup 3 D4 si on est là c'est que sur D4
CD qui D4 cavalier F6
k C3 k C6 c'est une des grandes ventes à
la mode en gros les noir utilisent
souvent cette ordre de coup et sur k B5
qui est le grand coup faire D6 fou F45
fou G5 c'est une chez sniakof mais o on
a pas la vente moderne a D5 rapide le
carwana qui est jou match contre Carlsen
et donc F2 en fait c'est pour les mecs
qui ont fait 6 mais qui veulent jouer
des chez sneakof et ben en fait on va
attendre que tu joues un coup comme D6
pour faire D4 et on aura une ccilienne
genre classique quoi h voilà donc c'est
ça le l'intérêt principal de fou 2
surtout que bah des4 on pourra le faire
plus tard éventuellement alors on
s'enlève des plans où on jouera avec F 3
grand rock et cetera mais on a ça en en
contrepartie mais sur des5 Direct donc
tu peux jouer le truc avec F C4 ouais
que toi tu aimes bien faire voilà ou
alors peut-être ed Ed et D4 hein pour
jouer contre le pion
éolé en après je sais pas ce qu'il
compte faire lui mais euh et et tu peux
le faire là aussi he je crois sur
cavalier F6 tu peux faire cavalier C3 et
sur D5 tu peux refaire des fou B5 si tu
as envie je pense peut-être bah tu do
ouais je pense je pense toi tu tu déjà
en jouer ouais je me rappelle plus ça
fait longtemps que je blit plus donc
j'oublie en fait mais je crois que tu
peux aussi le faire je pense que c'est
tout le temps intéressant en fait cette
idée
là damage 5 ou quelque chose non tuavais
pas une ligne tu laissé le pion je bien
de enfin moi je jamais jouét ça ça et ça
je sais plus comment ça
marche mais ça peut vraiment être
ça et un truc mais c'est vraiment pas
clair ce truuc bon après je me rappelle
pas si vous voulez vous rappeler c'est
la partie V forest pragananda vaanz 2022
je pense ouais fait AC Mathieu sur la
chaîne ouais ouais ça après les coups
quand tu les as pas revu récemment c'est
pas facile et B qui on n pas trop mal
bah pour moi là les Français c'est
décevant même si fait le truc c'est que
ceux qui font plutôt un bon tournoi
c'est maoridi et Baki qui ont quasiment
pas de chance de se qualifier ou en tout
cas aucune chance de gagner les
candidats derrière en soit qui ont zéro
chance réellement pour être champion du
monde et les deux qui font un enin on va
dire un soit très mauvais tourin pour
Maxime soit T moyen c'est alier Reza et
Maxim et c'est les deux joueurs qui
peuvent être champions du monde c'est un
petit peu comme si à à Roland Garos C
AVC Quentin Alice et j'en sais rien moi
un Hugo Gaston qui qui sont pas mal mais
euh mais donc en fait c'est bien d' fait
vraiment un bon tourno tournoi mais mais
mais tes joueurs qui peuvent gagner
Roland bah en fait ils sont déjà
éliminés quoi voilà ou qu'il y en a un
qui a galéré en 57 machin donc à vrai
dire tu préfères avoir ton meilleur
joueur qui est devant et qui joue pour
la gagne que d'avoir tes petites équipes
qui bah qui March mais qui peuvent pas
aller au bout quoi on va dire ça comme
ça donc c'est pour ça que c'est plutôt
décevant dans le sens où
ouais ça tu as lesestienne ouais c'est
ça c'est exactement çaas lesestien et
Quentin Alice qui joue bien quoi
Tam éim au premier tour de ver quoi donc
bon tu su
ouis tu as plus fils tu as plus non mais
les França pouv gagner Roland bah tu as
eu tu as eu ga et tuas son gars qui
aurait pu enfin FA et ils sont tombés au
mauvais moment aussi en face c'était
très très très fort mais en soi il y
avait un petit
espoir est-ce que enwin aujourd'hui
alors si on parle de la Calif pour le
grand Suisse pour moi il est en must
wiwin ouais ouais après faut pas oublier
tuas déjà expliqué plein de fois mais il
a la cartouche classement ho donc en
tout cas faut pas perdre
et si on joue le ho il faut que que nak
qualifie donc on ira voir un peu ce
qu'il fait de temp en temps Naka alors
soit que Naka se qualifie soit qu'il
fasse N et qu' se mette à enchaîner les
bulles mais je pense que alors j'ai lu
l'interview d'un gars aujourd'hui je me
reviens plus qui parce que j'ai lu pas
mal de choses mais qui disait que pour
lui N était le gros favori là pour la
Calif dans le tournoi dans le tournoi
ouais ah si euh mais j'ai vu aussi parce
qu'il il s'est garder C ner je sais pas
quoi n ouais ouais bah oui oui on a eu
la même chose alors c'était qui c'est
quelqu'un qui était très heureux c'est
quelqu'un ouais non mais c'est quelqu'un
don la vie est correct je veux dire
enfin c'est pas ouais bon c'est
quelqu'un avec qui j'étais d'accord oui
donc c'est là sur D5 ok c'est douf
exactement et que je voulais dire et on
nous demande quoi combien d' en tout il
y en a 11 donc là on a mis parcours en 6
de jouer là c'est la 7e donc donc on a
un peu plus de 50 % du tournoi mais il
encore tout à
faire et euh ouais donc du coup ici il
attend il attend un coup comme D6 pour
faire des4 alors après c'est une ché
vingue hein ça veut pas dire que tu as
fait un truc grand grandiose avec les
blancs mais tu as un peu forcé
l'adversaire à rentrer dans un Jard de
position voilà euh sur D5 je pense qu'il
va vraiment faire fou B5 hein bah c'est
possible c'est vraiment pénible faut
très bien connaître avec les
Noirs après si tu veux pas voir des qu
tu as dame B6 qui
existe mais il y a un sacrifice de pion
qui est pas con c'est à 4 à 5 pour
dégager le cavalier faire quand même D4
et après jouer avec fou3 et la dame en
B6 elle est mal placé et tu gagnes des
temps
et pourquoi doubb joue pas peut-être
qu'il a juste pas envie quoi enfin je
sais pas pourquoi tu joues
quoi c'est parfois plus logique de pas
jouer que de jouer en
fait bah après j'en sais rien si ça se
trouve il a pu de visa comme ouais
possible aussi ouais comme
Grisha mais c'est beau d'êre tout le
temps heureux de pas jouer tellement
heureux et dinglyen ben il stream
il stream c'est un grand mot mais il a
commenté un il a commenté quoi
d'ailleurs un tournoi en Chine en tout
cas ça c'est sûr alors quel était le
tournoi j'en sais rien mais ça avait
l'air d'être assez relevé en terme de de
niveau de jeu Fab h ils disent au Parin
aussi j'imagine je crois qu'il joue pas
au Parin au Parin il vit dans le coin
enfin en France mais il je pense qu'il
vit en Europe il est pas américain au
Parin bah ou alors voilà c'est ça enfin
j'ai pour la fédération américaine c'est
ça il m'a semblé de ne plus le voir sous
drapeau
russe serg au Parin
ouais on fait le la fin sur chesscom
alors on fera les petits résumés
évidemment chaque soirée hein sur la
chaîne Youtube de stream mais les
commentaires live ça sera ici ouis
jusqu'à
dimanche V comme comme vous êtes déjà
habitués pour ceux qui suivent le tourin
depuis le début on est en en attente du
coup
non mais bah en gros on a déjà
expliqué on a expliqué là c'est un choix
là on a tout expliqué on a plus qu'à
plus qu'à attendre Fab euh après je sais
pas est-ce que c'est déjà tôt pour aller
voir les autres qui jouent dans les
ouvertures je pense c'est un peu tôt
ouais un peu tôt je penseil faut
vraiment là il peut y avoir un coup et
qui peut être quand même déterminant
pour la suite du tournoi c'est notre
comme je disais pour moi l resa à moins
d'un retour en fanfare de de mvel c'est
notre dernier joueur français qui joue
pour le titre de champion du monde sur
ce cycle
oui peut être éliminé pas complètement
éliminé mais il peut être semiéliminé
aujourd'hui donc pour moi c'est quand
même là les les parties en jeu c'est ce
qu'on a envie de voir en tant que que
supporter
h c'est pe-être c'est peut-être grigoryi
au Paris noouais c'est peut-être
grigoryi au parisouis au Parin plutôt
ant quand même et pourquoi pas Baky Baky
on ira voir mais après vous pouvez aller
sur la chaîne de son fils il a joué D6
et euh et comme je disais bah même s'il
fait un très beau résultat ou quoi et il
a une infime chance de se qualifier au
grand Suisse qui serait génial mais gag
les candidats et B Ding Len ça paraît
quand même
ouais bon c'est pas fait d'avance ou
c'estal Rea il a un vrai shot pour être
champion du monde donc c'est normal en
tant que supporter de
se de se focaliser sur sur Alire Reza
qui qui est quand même en en piste
pour pour éventuellement éventuellement
devenir champion du monde mais bon alors
déjà faudra se qualifier au candidats
après faudra gagner les candidats et bon
voilà la route est longue c'est toujours
très dur de toute façon d'y aller alors
il a pris en C6 ok bon il aurait pu
jouer fou E3 ou d'autres coups euh il va
B prend est-ce que tu peux jouer E5 là
il a fait Dame des TR tempo tu peux
repartir vers G3 après bon de toute
façon il sait ce qu'il fait hein alors
moi j'ai joué souvent ce genre de
position mais souvent il y avait A6 en
plus chez les Noirs mais le plan que je
faisais avec les blanc c'était B3 fou B2
je me plaçais par là la dame je
l'envoyais ouais verg3 H3 par là-bas
F4 fou D3 souvent puis je j'envoyais
quoi enfin E5 F5 ça paraî assez assez
cohérent c'est harmonieux dans le
placement des pièces quoi et alors pour
le coup en fait les Noirs ont beaucoup
de plans bon en gros ils vont faire
petit rooc hein ça c'est pas le problème
mais leur structure de pion centrale
c'est eux qui vont décider quoi en faire
est-ce qu'il joueent avec E5 est-ce
qu'il joue avec D5 est-ce qu'il joue
avec C5 euh en général ils font D5 c'est
le le plus probable mais on m'avait déjà
joué un peu les autres structures ici ou
là alors on dit après on peut dire ce
que tu veux tu qualifies tu es meilleur
que ceux qui se qualifie pas donc si Bak
qui se qualifie il serait plus fort
qu'aliera ben non en fait ça marche pas
trop comme ça d'ailleurs ça a été dit
par beaucoup de joueurs dans ce tournoi
en fait c'est un peu des loteries c'est
tournois de Calif alors pas complètement
mais mais c'est quasiment jamais les
meilleurs qui gagne en tout cas un
tournoi comme celui-là c'est ah lui ça
peut quand même enin gen la dernière
fois cétait carwana ouais mais la fois
d'avant c'était wangao et Alexe Yenko
non al 3e non ouais mais c'est lui qui
s'est qualifié oui il s'est qualifi par
parce queil y avait déjà un mec wangao
quand même mais euh c'est dur de gagner
mais en fait bon c'est mais en gros
enfin je sais pas de toute façon ta
phrase elle veut rien dire enfin c'est
comme si tuestimes que dans un match de
Coupe de France de foot l'équipe de 8e
division qui fait un exploit en fait
elle est plus forte que l'équipe de
Ligue
1 tu considères jamais comme ça dans le
sport et c'est pas parce que
je sais pas comment te dire on va dire
que moi je bat alira Kevin il me bat ça
veut pas dire Kevin il va battre al
enfin il y a pas de truc comme ça ça
existe pas dans le sport et là tu peux
regarder Bercy les résultats ou quoi
alcas VI perdre contre moins fort que
voilà donc je sais pas enfin juste
réfléchis avant d'écrire un truc quoi
pas tu as 11 GAM pour prouver non mais
c'est tu prouv enfin non mais tu pr en
faitf là Carlsen il a pas battu le il a
pas gagné le catar open du coup
carlen 28 mecs devant lui bah oui tu as
9 secondes pour t'exprimer je dire c'est
enfin c'est grottesque de penser comme
ça je sais pas faites ce que vous voulez
hein mais donc non en fait tu as tu as
toute ta carrière qui parle pour toi tu
as ton classement ho tu as plein de
choses sur le long courer après que tu
es été plus en forme sur une compétition
précise ça il y a rien à dire tu as été
plus fort sur ce tournoi là mais tu es
pas plus fort dans l'absolu ou enfin
c'est quand même deux trucs très
différents puis tu joues pas les mêmes
adversaires aussi là c'est un tournoi
ouvert donc les appariments ça joue et
par exemple al resa qui a joué le joueur
kazak là 2440 genre ça c'est vraiment
pas de bol parce que le mec enfin nous
on a regardé toutes ces parties hier
avec Fab h il est vraiment hyper fort et
il te pourrit ton il te pourrit ton
départage alors queil joue à 2650 enfin
en tout cas sur le tournoi ouais et et
tu as quand même énormément de facteurs
comme ça qui qui qui
jouent après je serais d'accord avec toi
si on fait six grands Suisse
ouais qu'on attribue des points à chaque
fois là je te dirais ouais c'est tu
commences déjà être plus proche de la
vérité genre si la qualification c'était
sur C même CIN tournois tu fais un
classement général ou à la fin ouais tu
tu commence être sur quelque chose où le
niveau de réussite existe encore mais il
devient quand même relativement
marginal l'exemple réscent c'est abasov
qui a réussi sa coupe du monde et là il
est un peu moins en forme bah abasov je
sais pas combien il est là mais il est
enfin il menacerait même pas de se
qualifier
non mais il a aucune chance de gagner
les candidats et sil gagnait les
candidats il a 0 % de chance mais enfin
c'est ouais c'est même pas donc non ça
marche pas ça marche pas comme ça en
fait mais
euh mais bon après on espère qu'alireza
va réussir à battre Sarana et qui va qui
va réussir à se qualifier
hein mais après bon c'est quand même
faut quand même être méritant pour
gagner un tel tournoi he c'est ah c'est
très
difficile mais ça veut pas dire que tu
es le meilleur pourut enfin tu as été le
meilleur cette fois-là
quoi
mais exemple c'est surtout surtout c'est
gocage 2/ 6
ouais non mais tu peux passer à côté
c'est pas absurde de faire un départage
au ho tu juges par rapport à quelque
chose d' retour moi je trouve que le
départage au Ho est absolument absurde
quit à vouloir faire ça autant faire le
départage où tu te donnes des points de
départage après chacrond suivant ton
score quit à voulir faire un truc comme
ça et récompenser un peu ce qui commence
bien autant tu fais départage le
cumulatif ouais mais là le départage en
c'est absolument absurde je crois que
Lilou l' dit il voulait dire autre chose
en fait enfin il voulait faire un truc
qui existe pas c'est dire que le
meilleur classement ho ah je crois que
c'est ça qu'il veut dire ce serait
absurde aussi enil dit que c'est par
rapport à quelque chose d'extérieur au
tournoi mais en fait le truc c'est que
là tu fais un tournoi pour que tu sois
méritant sur ce tournoi bah c'est ça le
but de ce tourno en
fait mais bon après pourquoi pas après
pourquoi pas attention he ah il est
d'accord avec moi bon bah tant mieux
hein mais surtout que leso en plus il y
a pas mal de débat en ce moment il y a
quand même encore du rattrapage par
rapport au covid il y a des pays comme
le Kazakhstan ou quoi où les mecs
beaucoup moins ils sont très sousclassés
donc il y a ouais c'est ça prend trop de
facteurs en compte mais bon peu importe
on n'est pas à
une absurdité prê j'ai envie de dire non
ouais mais moi je trouve que le cumul
person le cumulatif qui absolument
jamais utilisé je le trouve très bien
moi parce que ça favorise quand même
ceux qui ont bien commencé et finalement
tu as fait le T à part devant ben tu es
récompensé enfin je trouve ça tellement
en fait tous les départages ont leur
points fort leur points faiblees je dire
mais je trouve que celui de la moyenne
Ho est vraiment
bah pourquoi pas en fait enfin parce que
alors oui bah là tu as le kazak qui est
bizarre mais normalement en fait c'est
plus dur de jouer des mecs à bien
classer que des mecs moins bien classé
c'est quand même subjectif
hein bah si on part du principe que le
ho veut dire quelque chose bien sûr
ouais mais il y a tellement de formes de
machin puis bon si tu as joué des mecs
la joue Naka par exemple il a 5 points
de départage plus caliera ou 10 points
de plus enfin oui mais bah il y a C
rondes ça peut changer tout
ça je sais pas B moi je préfère le bols
ou le
cumulatif parce que le brô ça représente
quand même la forme de tes adversaires
sur ce tournoi là peu importe hein on
peut aller jeter un rapide à ce qui se
passe sur la partie de Baky ah bien sûr
si on y arrive alors att comme ça je
vais ouvrir en
faitetvrires les par
ok je vois alorsende les
repass
ilose et il va jouer
donc
désolé on nous entend tout parce que ça
a réouvert le truc c'est pas pas très
très bien
foutu euh
ok donc ça ça c'est encore la théorie
alirza on va y venir on y était ouais
et B qui donc c'est une une
calache donc c'est que yyangi joue le
gain ouais il a pas joué sa P il a pas
joué sa P et euh ok bon là pour le coup
je connais peu ce qui se passe euh c'est
intéressant
euh donc la position qu'on voit qu'on
vous a laissé en bas à droite juste pour
dire c'est la position de la partie de
d'alirea qu'on va qu'on va laisser comme
c'est notre grand format oui oui et puis
bah sur l'écran c'est la position de
Baki euh
ok enfin cette ligne elle est vraiment
intéressante B qui va pas jouer C3 il va
attendre parceen fait sur cavalier un C3
tu peux le jouer c'est le feu vert pour
les noir pour jouer A6 et balancer le C
B5 vers A3 est moins bien placé peu
importe après bon ça joue quand même le
CAL A3 il peutevenir en C2 et mettre le
C3 vers D5 bon c'est une autre histoire
mais en fait l'ordre de coup qu' a
choisi Baky de faire fou D3 c'est pas
con c'est de jouer bah petit
rock et dès que le fou va aller en G7 je
pense qu'il va jouer fou
C2 mais toute façon tu vas devoir le
faire tt ou tard ce ce fou 7 euh et il
va faire fou C2 ou fou 2 d'ailleurs pour
aller taper D6 alors il peut yoir des
ventes où les Noirs donnent D6
pour
pour pour
s'activer du coup faut savoir et sinon
c'est les noir glandouille genre disons
petit rock et fou E6 tu peux aussi jouer
C les 5 C3 m ça plus trop de coup utile
donc il peuvent faire fou G7 mais tu
sautes en en D5 maintenant et euh et tu
aller très vite ici voilà bon bon c'est
jouable après les n pourront toujours te
faire fou prend des5 et cetera mais mais
voilà je pense ça les prochains coup
donc il eu petit joué par Etienne et
donc c'est Yang
jouer je m'attends un coup comme fou6 de
sa part voilà et en fait c'est Mar j'ai
tourné un DVD récemment moi là-dessus et
l'ordre de coup que j'ai suggéré moi
avec les noirs sur C4 c'était de faire
fou E6 au 6e euh pas G6 en fait ouais et
sur fou D3 si les blancs décident de
faire ce truc j'avais dit ok on fait pas
G6 on va retomber sur le truc normal F
7 donc euh donc j'évitaé plutôt donc je
pensais que c'était plutôt un truc malin
pour les blancs euh ce qui veut pas dire
que c'est injouable si tu connais bien
avec les Noirs je sais que ça va avec
l'ordi mais ça peut inclure des
sacrifices de pion des ves compliqué euh
donc donc on va voir après yangi il a
une bonne mémoire généralement Yi a une
bonne mémoire et tien euh bah il devait
pas s'attendre à ce choix d'ouverture
quoi qu'il en soit euh mais il a choisi
une ligne plutôt plutôt intéressant mais
c'est c'est pour ça ça ça revient aussi
à la discussion dont on avait tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en réalité tu dois
marquer comme il y a que deux places
qualificatives et que c'est pas un truc
où tu marque des points au fur et à
mesure des tournois ou quoi ça demande
vraiment au joueurs plus fort de prendre
des risques et donc mécaniquement avec
les machins de moyenne et lo de machin
ça va peut permettre à un mec moins fort
B un peu là tuas tu as des mecs moins
forts qui sont devant en en tête de
ouais après il faut en profiter mais
prof mais c'est pour ça que je dis tu
vois ce serait pas ce serait pas harant
euh là on voit un peu les les
les premières fois mais tu vois même
d'avoir un carov qui se qualifie ce
serait pas harant dans dans dans dans ce
format quoi non non bien sûr ou parce
que comme tu as la moyenne ho à la fin
qui va te donner un boost d'un
demi-point par rapport au fort ben
c'est par un genre de mécanique de
chaise musicale ça ça peut ça peut bien
se
passer on verra en tout cas qui qui va
au bout mais tu vois là parlea il a un
gros retard par rapport à un mec comme
sindarof il a un demi point de retard et
il a un MOS bon
départage ça peut il ils peuvent être
très très dur à cooiffer au poteau donc
lui il doit prendre plus de ris donc un
mec comme Sarana plus enfin plus de
chance de gagner peut-être qu'à ce petit
jeu au final sur les 4 C favoris qui
doivent prendre des rises bah ils font
trois victoires une défaite et c'est
celui des moins forts qui gagnent qui
les coiffe tous au poteau quoi de par la
dynamique du tournoi bon j'espère que
vous m'avez compris ceux qui m'ont
compris tant mieux ceux qui m'ont pas
compris ben tant mieux aussi euh alors
moi je vis jeter un œil sur la partie de
Maxime quand même juste l'ouvrir alors
je suis très bas c'est une française et
Maxime il a obligation de gagner pour
avoir une chance pas du tout une
française mais ça ressemble à une
française c'est une Rossolimo c'est une
Rossolimo donc Maxime qui connaît il
joue tout tempo donc Maxime sa
problématique elle est simple il doit
faire 5 sur
5 au moins c'est facile enfin au moins
tu sais ce que tu fais quoi ouais ouais
alors qui sait ça peut commencer par une
victoire aujourd'hui avec les Noirs bon
admettons tu gagnes demain au blanc tu
redoubles les blancs tu gagnes encore et
puis suffit de faire de/ de sur les deux
dernières contre un autre mec contre
d'autres mecs qui font de sur deux qui
suicid un peu aussi et et par un trou de
stor tu passe bon c'est hautement
improbable mais j'en discutais avec
Maxime pas plus loin qu'hier et il disit
bon B de toute façon tant que j'ai une
chance on va la jouer à fond quoi ça
passe ça passe bon c'est 99,9 % de
chance que ça passe pas mais tant qu'il
reste un 0,1 bah on va on va tenter quoi
pourquoi
pas
pourquoi pas bah faut de toute façon
voilà au moins
euh donc on
verra là bon pour l'instant sa partie
bah voilà c'est une position qui bah qui
ressemble beaucoup à une Française
euh avec les caractéristiques de ce
genre de position donc j'imagine qu'il
va avoir envie de faire F6 très
prochainement pour casser un peu ce
centre blanc reprendre un peu d'espace
et et s'activer alors on peut peut-être
faire fou D7 avant à voir mais euh ça
devrait arriver
on va retourner sur notre partie
principale Fab où il y a quand même eu
un coup D5 dont dont tu parlais qui
vient instantanément contester le le
centre ouais ouais c'est logique alors
je m'attendais peut-être à petit rock
mais pourquoi pas des 5 direct et et bon
ben du coup j'imagine que que dame G3
doit être complètement normal
ouais il réfléchit est ce que D5 était
une surprise ça semble pas quand même he
c'est un coup logique après dame D3
c'est pas coup plus jouer ah non mais
enfin alors sur dame G3 il veut quoi il
veut rock et sur F H6 cavalier8 je
suppose ah ouais ouais je pense pas que
mais bon tu peux le faire juste pour ça
gagne pas de qualité c'est tout ce que
je voulais dire donc à voir ouais j'ai
TR petit rock tu peux aussi peut-être
faire
E5 tu peux voir souvent on aime bien
maintenir si on peut un peu la pression
centrale
mais après peut-être on peut réfléchir à
B3 ici
aussi B3 j'aime bien parce que si les
Noirs font des pr bon certes ils vont
échanger les dames mais c'est quand même
une moins bonne structure quelque part
donc tu peux aussi vouloir jouer une
partie sur la finale comme ça et puis
bah s'ils prennent pas E4 enfin qu'on
fait B3 qui Roque et ben on fait fou B2
et puis on maintient un peu le le
suspense et on verra ce qui se passe euh
donc bref çairis de voir euh dame G3
semble logique mais il a sûrement
d'autres options
voilà
F4
aussi bien sûr non non mais bien sûr tu
sors
quoi tout est possible c'est au joueur
après de de faire la partie aussi Fab
exactement là ce sont juste des options
après suivant celle qu'il choisira la
partie prendra une direction x ouou y
j'ai envie de te dire si tu me me
permets l'expression je te permets je te
permets mais là je pense qu'il sait ce
qu'il fait en gros peut-être que D5 il
était pas complètement au courant de ce
qui se passe mais en gros c'est
clairement le genre de position qu'il
allait obtenir en choisissant cette
variante bah c'est lui qui a pris en C6
on lui a pas demandé de le faire donc
c'est qu' voulait obtenir ce genre de
truc donc il doit avoir un placement de
pièce en tête et cetera Sarana bel
adversaire mais c'est c'est on voit là
c'est ces résultats alors on les voyait
pas tout à fait on va vousler dire il a
battu michra quand même avec les Noirs
pas facile après il avait enchaîné
contre le le joueur qui s'appelle royal
un joueur local donc cl c'est que 2400
alors lui il a réussi à gagner le joueur
est pas forcément super sous-classé mais
ça lui pourrit un peu le le départage
surtout qu'après nul contre il s'est
pris aussi le J donc lui en fait il a
son tournoi un peu détruit par ses
départages malheureusement oui faut
qu'il finisse clairement en premier ou
deème ouais après il a perdu contre
Nakamura il a battu l'adversaire de
maximean et il joue maintenant contre
alza donc pour lui aussi une défaite
aujourd'hui serait éliminatoire au vu de
de ses apparims oui oui oui il faut qu'
bon enfin là je pense avec les Noirs il
va pas jouer le gain en soi il se dit
que nul c'est pas mal et euh et il verra
mais euh une défaite serait rébitoire
ouais après ou plutôt un bon joueur ce
Sarana il a dit d'ailleurs je crois
champion d'Europe
donc ça sera sûrement le dernier
champion duurap russe avant un belle
lurette parce qu'ils ont changé de
continent aux échees
mais maintenant il est serbe mais
maintenant il est serbe mais du coup il
est plus russe ENF ouais mais dis donc
c'est sûrement le dernier joueur sous
drapeau russe gag championn d'Europe
avant belle lurette on va dire oui oui
parce que maintenant les Russes jouent
avec les asiatiques les Asiatiques et ça
va donner des beaux jeux olympiques
asiatiques d'ailleurs
ouais très réputé en Asie les Jeux
Olympiques asiatiques et les échecs on
la part belle et ça va faire un tournoi
de très très très haut niveau
j'ai parlé avec quelques amis russes qui
étaient plutôt
contents mais pour une raison très
simple déjà beaucoup voyager en Europe
ça le permettra d'aller voir permettra
d'aller voir la Chine ou d'Aou d'aller
faire des voyages en
Asie azerbaïjan c'est aussiant
l'Azerbaïjan ça joue avec
l'Europe
mais du coup je sais pas si ça affaibli
ou rendu plus fort le championnat
d'Europe en cette histoire alors
évidemment il y a plus la Russie qui
joue qui était à chaque fois la nation
numéro 1 on va dire les favorite mais vu
qu' énormément de joueurs jouent sous
d'autres drapeaux maintenant ça
renforcit tellement d'autres fédérations
ouais bah oui oui que au final c'est
peut-être devenu plus fort qu'avant même
s'il y a plus la nation la plus forte
dans S comme V qui joue maintenant pour
l'Angleterre tu as Sarana et prè que qui
joue pour la Serbie tu as d'autres
joueurs qui sont partis en Espagne
notamment chez les fille avec Sarah
Sadat ouais al elle était pas russe mais
oui mais c'est juste que j'ai pensé à
elle aussi qui renforc une équipe quoi
mais tuas genre oui Alex C qui joue pour
la Suisse ou enfin Alex pour l'Autriche
et et donc
bon
ça a enlevé l'équipe la plus forte mais
ça a renforcé des équipes plus faibles
quoi voilà c'est comme C tuit pas les
Black au rugby on va dire mais ouais
mais et que tous le joueurs et puis même
des joueurs qui étaient pas asse dans
l'équipe qui seraient quand même pas mal
du coup dispatch un peu de partout toute
façon ser l'Afrique du Sud qui gagnera
la fin mon Fab ça changerait pas
grandchose tu mets les mains tu fais un
grattage avec les les qu appuis oui bon
puis bon tuas la pénalité ouis tuas la
pénalité c'est pas
grave Maxime qui joue vite B qui le fou
G7 qui est parti donc toi spécialiste tu
dis fou C2 ou fou E2 tu es pas obligé
mais normalement c'est l'idée de cet
ordre de coup là
ouais il joue vite juste pour savoir
duongi ouais ouais il joue très vite
ouais donc en fait il doit connaître les
nous tu donne des S et compagnie tu peux
donner des S mais ça me semblait pas
ouais en ça mais bon après si tu enfin
c'est toujours pareil quoi des fois
c'est des trucs qui sont durs à
apprendre tu as pas envie de les jouer
mais si tu as fait tourner le truc à
fond que tuas tu sais tu sais ouais
ouais ouais j'avais enregistré tout ça
il y a pas si longtemps C au mois de
septembre donc c'est encore un petit peu
frais dans mon
cerveau alors évidemment les Blancs ont
le droit de de se développer
naturellement avec kc3 mais comme je
vous disais en fait quand on joue ce ce
genre de
position globalement en fait les Noirs
ça va ils vont jouer tour C8 il y a la
case D4 éventuellement pour le cavalier
des fois lui il peut partir ils peuvent
jouer F5 donc bon ça c'est censé
aller après il peut y avoir des des
ventes comme ça ou même nul peut arriver
enfin pas obligé de faire c 5 C j'ai
envie de dire d'ailleurs mais disons une
varante une varante comme
ça
je sa
pas F3 ti voilà pour pour renforcer la
position peut y avoir ça pour attaquer
le pion et sur B3 essayer de faire des
coup comme
B5 donc c'est un peu ça les idées des
Noirs donc ça en fait je pense pas que
les Blancs soi juste mieux en général
mais de délayer ce C C3 ça ça son
utilité donc là je
m'attends
pour appuyer sur SP pion du coup et on
voit l'absence du du f
F donc en général ouais les noirs
peuvent roquer pour filer le pion et
jouer pour les compensations et donc le
fou peut aussi partir de l'autre côté
voilà après on verra3 sachant que ce
coup a rien de mal si jamais tien venait
à le jouer mais peut-être moins
[Musique]
moins critique pour la ligne
quoi
on va voir Fab on a plus qu'à plus qu'à
attendre je dirais là puisque on est un
peu bloqué dans les parties donc c'est
souvent pour pour ceux qui suivent pour
la première fois ces cadences longues
bon normalement il y a que des habitués
mais je le dis quand même il y a souvent
un moment où ça joue assez vite je
dirais la première demi-heure heure de
jeu donc on est encore là dans dans le
moment où ça va jouer un peu vite à
partir de de je dirais 16h45 17h ça va
ralentir et ça réaccélérera vers 19h
donc il va y avoir là entre alle les
16h40 et 19h un temps un peu mou avant
de repartir en accélération jusqu'à
19h45 pour Z not pour le Z not et après
il y aura de nouveau un temps mou
pendant de 19h45 jusqu'à 21h 22h où ça
ira assez lentement ça c'est c'est
généralement ce qui ce qui se passe dans
dans les parties donc le plus
intéressant pour les spectateurs c'est
de suivre maintenant he jusqu'à aller on
va dire 17h après faites une petite
pause si vous voulez faire et revenez
vers 19h généralement c'est un peu là
que que les que les choses se repassent
se décant un petit peu ouais mais là il
y a encore des choses intéressantes qui
nous attendent pendant les les 30 40
prochaines minutes on va dire puis il y
aura un temps vraiment où il va se jouer
deux coups toutes les demi-heur quoi
ouais mais là on aujourd'hui étonnamment
on attaque on va dire le moment mou un
peu
plutôt mais ça après c'est on peut on
peut pas y faire grand-chose c'est fou
fa subit ouais ouais on le ouais mais
c'était tous les jours comme ça on le
subit
Fab mais à partir de 19h ça va 19h 19h15
20 ça va vraiment se se réaccélérer et
ce sera intéressant là pendant pendant
les 20 25 minutes là ça va vraiment être
le le moment passionnant de la journée
donc il joue dame
G3 donc on s'attend à petit rock bahjà
mettre le roi à l'abri et défendre
G7 est-ce qu'il y a plus long comme
cadence sur l' Stre non pour ce tournoi
c'est la cadence la plus longue qui
existe euh déjà il y a 1h40 + 30
secondes maintenant il y a beaucoup de
tournois qui sont 1h30 plus 30 secondes
donc ça fait quand même 20 minutes de
moins c'est pas si peu en terme de de
dynamisme même si ça peut paraître
anecdotique après généralement au 40e
coup maintenant il y a plus que 30
minutes de rajout ce qui laisse le
dynamisme alors que là il y en aura 50
donc ça fait quand même une grosse
différence et en plus ici encore 15
minutes de rajout au au 60e ce qu'on
trouve plus trop non plus sur le circuit
donc c'est vraiment la cadence de très
loin la plus longue et la moins
dynamique mais c'est probablement celle
qui offre le meilleur niveau de jeu donc
c'est c'est pour ça qu'elle est aussi
plébicité pour les tournois les plus
importants que sont bah le grand Suisse
les candidats et le le match de champion
a du monde pour être sûr que le niveau
de jeu atteint son son paroxisme Fabien
donc c'est pour ça que les joueurs ont
besoin de de ces temps de de réflexion
euh long euh d'ailleurs au champion du
monde il faisait pas un truc avec 40
coup de heur sans r jou de
temps alors ouais mais ils avaient les
mêmes enfin ça faisait autant de temps
ça faisait la même ratio de temps à la
fin ouais mais euh oui il te change
toujours un peu quand même les cadences
quoi on s'habitue pas vraiment quand
même ça serait dommage cohérence entre
les cadences si pour pour faire simple
les cadences sont pas exactement les
mêmes sur le sur le cycle de de
championnat du monde c'est un petit peu
comme si au tennis ont changé un peu les
les quand même les les tailles des cours
ou genre de truc pendant pendant des
tournois non pas diamètre allemand mais
bon tu rajoutes 10 cm quoi
ou
pas à quoi réfléchir à part petit rock
ici
peut-être 3 F8 mais je crois pas
il réfléchit pas vraiment ouais
peut-être qu'il peut-être qu'il est
juste pas sur sa chaise he c'est c'est
tout à fait possible qu'il soit en
partie en vadrouille un petit peu
marcher se détendre comme on l'a dit la
cadence est longue donc on a le temps de
bien se
reposer est que D4 c'est un
[Musique]
coup j'aime pas D4 pour les
no en fait on va juste bouger le
cavalier tu auras fait pas mal de trous
au centre sur les cases blanches et où
les blancs pourront s' installer dessus
et surtout que des4 qui va les prendre
tu as pas forcément envie de prendre 4
vu que tu as toujours G7 à attaquer donc
euh non ça doit être le C c'est certain
en
fait
ouais est-ce que c'est utile ouis sur P
de faire F H6 F
F4 peut-être pourquoi pas en fait c'est
pas idiot c'est pas idiot parce qu'on
essaie de mal mettre le C E8 alors après
il va sûrement revenir en jeu peut-être
via via D6 d'ailleurs et donc faudra
regarder ce qu'il en est parce que quand
on fera5 il pourra peut-être venir F5
bon ok à voir
euh mais mais en tout cas
euh ça se réfléchit c'est c'est pas du
tout grotesque et c'est peut-être la
meilleure manière de jouer en plus
quoi après donc sur petit rock ouais
donc il y a donc ce fou H6 d'abord pour
emmener le cavalier en E8 euh il y a
aussi on peut faire tour peut-être tour
D1 on peut peut-être faire E5 on peut
peut-être faire fou F4 on peut peut-être
faire B3 enfin bon il y a du coup
beaucoup de choix en
fait position intéressante bien pour
alira position qui joue he c'est tout ce
qu'il souhaitait obtenir à mon avis de
l'ouverture est-ce que chez Baky on a
des coups on vous laisse la position
d'aliza notre grand format chez Baky ça
réfléchit encore c'est pas forcément une
super nouvelle dans le sens où comme on
le disait yuangi semble très préparé et
il a changé son fusil d'épaule pour
cette partie et B fout de ouais c'est la
ligne ouais l'idé prend4 F F3 ouais mais
je crois pas qu' fallit prendre4 en fait
je crois que sur c'est
a c'est mieux les blanc D4 qui C3 mieux
blanc mieux blanc ouais tu le sais h
faut deux en fait il faut faut fa roquer
et laisser donc D6 fais fou6 et mais
c'est compli enfin en fait je pensais
justement ne pas recommander ça parce
que je me dit que ça faisait beaucoup de
trucs à à réfléchir et je trouvais pas
d'égalité éro0 net à la fin non plus
quoi je veux dire mais ok c'est mais en
surprise à haut niveau c'est plutôt bien
pour les
et je dois dire que j'ai juste analysé
sur mon ordi j'avais pas accès à la
grosse turbine ou quoi donc peut-être
qu'en fait ça va très bien ça je peux
pas te dire à 1000 % mais je suis à peu
près sûr que le meilleur c'estck là ok
on va on va on va laisser la partie se
se dérouler et Maxime il a une position
intéressante ce qui est surtout
intéressant c'est qu'on voit qu'il joue
tout tempo et qui connait et que son
adversaire même si la position peut pas
être moins bien au blanc actuellement
bah il reste déjà plus qu'unh 100 et
issu quoi ouais il wou enfin je sais pas
trop ce qu'il fait mais euh ouais il
réfléchit en tout cas bon mais les
blanchs je sais pas trop hein sil va
faire fou 3 tours C1 ou jouer avec G3
histoire de pouvoir jouer avec H4 on
voit souvent quand même que c'est c'est
une idée hein euh donc euh on va voir
allez on retourne sur la partie d'ikarou
un petit coup pour voir ce que nous
prépare le favori actuellement du du
tournoi etaruna camura donc comme on le
disait on sait pas trop si on veut qu'il
gagne ou qu'il perde ce qu'on veut pas
c'est qui finissent 45e du tournoi sans
se qualifier donc gagne ou perd ikarou
mais ne fait pas de nul
ouais euh
ok je m'attendais plus à voir le F2 mais
c'est vrai que récemment il y a eu une
petite mode de remettre le F en C4 de
jouer un peu des sortes de susin à la
Bobby Fisher j'ai envie de te dire euh
et le coup A3 inclus dans la position
bah pourquoi pas ça fait une cas à 2
pour le fou ça peut préparer un B4 un
jour ça ralenti aussi un A6 B5 B4 d noir
donc que bon il est pas inutile comme
coup et j'imagine que voilà ici il peut
penser à Al soit FO de pour couper court
à tout D5 et ce fou qui peut de toute
façon être un peu attaquable par
cavalier E5 cavalier A5 tour C8 bref
enfin il est pas forcément au top il sur
une bonne diagonale mais souvent faudra
le rebouger euh et ensuite songer à
faire F4 F5 peut-être pour le faire
taper sur la sur cette diagonale là
après il peut aussi juste faire un coup
comme dame 2 pour D1 et ça doit être pas
mal aussi quoi en tout cas position là
encore qui se travaille et qui joue côté
Alireza on le savait mais Sarana ne
répond pas pour le moment il y a de la
friture sur la ligne Fabien ouais
ouais ouais ouais euh mais je sais pas
pourquoi il joue pas mais bon ben
peutêtre il a de la friture sur la ligne
ça vibre pas pas comme il faut pas comme
il veut non bon mais au pire il peut
trouver tout seul quoi
tout cas il réfléchit côté Baky il
réfléchit gu il réfléchit vou a fait
petit oui je sais mais on était on en
était là déjà ah je savais pas qu'il l'
déjà fait ok ikarou qui envoie F4 ok
très bien et maintenant c'est prê que
qui réfléchit exactement non bon F4 très
logique he souvent dans la saine on
envie de faire F4 F5 et puis de toute
façon ce coup prendre l'espace au centre
ça permet aussi peut-être de glisser la
dame F3 bah sans se prendre un cavalier
au 5 qui arriverait donc
multifonction et puis bah ça pe aussi
permettre à passer la tour via F3
et là-bas donc donc donc logique
F4 allez ça a jouer chez chez alza le
petit rock et donc là question qu'on se
posait c'est est-ce qu'on fait fou H6
cavalier8 et fou F4 ou fou F4
directementah ou5 ou B3 enfin ou on sait
pas en fait mais là ouais ça y est là il
peut réfléchir
et et voir ce qu'il compte
faire là il peut bien réfléchir même
j'ai envie de te dire Fab on est enfin
rentré dans dans la partie j'ai envie te
dire après ce dame G3 petit rock tous
les coups logiques et évidents ont été
joués de part et d'autre à la suite de
la préparation théorique et maintenant
on rentre dans le vif du sujet dans le
milieu de jeu où les choix peuvent
coûter cher Fabien ils sont plus
importants ouais euh donc ouais donc ce
qu'on disait bah on peut bouger les
pièces si vous voulez hein c'est fou H6
on menace mat donc on s'attend à caval8
hein évidemment et on pensa peut-être
replacer le fou ensuite ici euh la
question que je me posais est-ce que c
D6 c'est une amélioration ou pas pour
les Noirs l'idée hein c'est que si on
fait E5 le cavalier va pouvoir venir en
F5 il va être gênant parce que bah il
est bien placé ici il fait il attaque la
dame et il contrôle bien le centre donc
on doit pas faire E5 on peut faire F3
préparer EU5 donc en fait ouais bon
c'est hasard de réfléchir et voir à quel
point ça lui plaît ou pas ce truc mais
franchement pourquoi pas ça me paraît
pas absurde ou avoir plus ou moins la
même position mais avec le cavalier côté
F6 donc faire F F4 direct il a fait F H6
et cavalier 8 point d'exclamation ah et
oui il par le mat en un joli coup ce
cavalier E8 et on nous dit l'ordi
recommande cavalier E8 sur fu F4 direct
donc fau H6 c'est une pure perte de
temps on nous dit àovic ouais tu vois
donc du coup on est aussi nul qu'za
parce que moi aussi j'aurais fait F H6
non mais F4 c'est pas k le coup enfin et
et que si je sais pas ce que c'est ton
ordi mais B alors nous l'ordi c'est tour
8 hein le coup mais
que si mais jou 8 c'est c'est absurde
quoi et oui
je sais pas peut-être mais c'est oui
mais Caval 8 k D6 et
oui il faudrait que je prenne un autre
expert Fabien beaucoup plus fin que toi
pour
pour faud qu'il soit plus fin qu'a aussi
quoi ouais il est pas assez
fin manque de finesse chez alirea qui ne
comprend pas que cavalier 8 était le
coup main de l'ordi
mais après non mais je pense qu'il va
jouer k D6 et du coup on va voir mais
çafin moi je suis pas convaincu que
c'est le C en d6ou en F6 je peux pas te
dire moi j'aurais quand Mme plutôt fait
FO H6 F4 comme comme le joue ici àa ça
ça me paraît parce que oui je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit mis en D6 par rapport à
F6 par contre je suis sûr que j'ai enfin
ouais moi j'aurais l'impression qu' D6
je te fais F D3 c'est ça et d'ailleurs
bon F pas quand il éta en F6 parce qu'
H5 mais là je suis plutôt content tu me
fais tour 8 j'ai envie de te faire tour
à1 tour8 je sais pas si j'ai envie de le
faire je sais pas ce qu'elle fait là
mais moi j'ai envie de te mater en fait
je me dis que j'éis un peu affaibli H7
que je commencé à pouvoir penser à des
pions pr pr H7 même peut-être certains
jours en fait je jouais que sent pour
mater comme ça
moi tu t'en fous complètement puis des
fois je RAM Leon D13 G4 il partait
là-bas non mais
complètement
on demande si on peut enlever la barre
mais je crois pas non on ne peut pas on
a la barre
l'évaluation ce qui est beau quand
même alors après ne vous inquiétez pas
trop parce qu'elle est pas forcément
précise non plus parce que là c'est
l'ordinateur de la barre il est
profondeur 24 autant te dire
que
bah bah c'est pas terrible quoi non mais
bon si tu fais tourner en profondeur 40
tu auras peut-être pas du tout la même
ouais non mais bon ok on
a vo c'est ça on a un petit c'est à peu
près ce qui se trame dans la
position et s'il a une grosse tactique
ou
quoi B qui ça réfléchi s'est rien passé
Maxime ça réfléch s'est rien passé Naka
ça réfléchi il s'est rien passé
ok donc on est on est à jour sur sur nos
parties
Fabien donc on pourra faire une petite
pause dans 5 minutes Fab histoire de de
respirer de
récupérer c'est vra que j'ai l'IM qu'il
se passe souvent rien
quoi non comme je dis jusqu'à 19h ça va
être un peu mou et après ça va
s'emballer
encore que on a on a des parties
aujourd'hui quand même relativement
intéressantes j'ai envie de te dire là
c'est des parties qu'on a envie de voir
se se développer là surtout cette partie
d'alierza la partie de Baky aussi mais
Baky comme il est il est contre une
prépa ça fait ça ça inquiète un petit
peu
plus bon le truc c'est que je crois
qu'il c'est à peu près Bak qui mais ça
vait faire un petit moment qu'il a pas
vu ouais mais ce qui est embêtant c'est
que l'autre a l'air de savoir et de
d'avoir vu récemment quoi on verra on
verra Fab on va pas tracer de plan sur
la la comète
com et come on dit dans le chat il reste
que 2h30 là avant l'emballement du du Z
not ça va passer très très vite surtout
qu'il peut se passer des choses
avant bon moi je fais un petit tour des
stades je vois qui est en train de de
voir ce qui se passe à droite à gauche
reg est-ce que le A4 dans la partie 4
marquance nous a fait kiffer bah tu sais
c'est juste ordi en fait enin je sais
pas comment dire c'est pas comme avant
où quand tu avait des coups c'était
pensé par l'être humain maintenant c'est
juste je fais tourner ton module chez
toi et il le fait alors c'est un joli
coup mais mais j'ai déjà vu des gur
jouer en fait c'est pas nouveau ou
quoi mais euh ouais normalement c'est
pas le genre de coup que j'aime bien
mais il y a il y a quelques idées
derrière quoi bon l'idée principale
c'est d'éviter des c
quoi ça réfléchi côté Sarana moi je
trouve que cEIT H6 ou F4 est plutôt
intéressant allez moi je MRAI quand même
une une pièce sur une victoire d'alireza
c'est une position qui lui convient h il
y a beaucoup d'attaqu c'est dangereux il
est en il joue quand même plutôt bien
ala dans ce tournoi la partie contre
artemf était peut-être la moins bonne de
cette QV mais faut dire qu'artemief joue
aussi très bien le type de position
qu'il a obtenu et aliresa a quand même
réussi à tenir
donc non mais là ça va ça joue il a pas
pris trop de temps à la pendule ou quoi
et
ou je te propose qu'avant notre première
pause on fasse un dernier tour des
stades pour ne rien manquer St dans la
partie de Baky il y a eu cavalier C3
donc Baki qui ne s'est pas emparé du du
pion c'est peut-être très bien joué
parce qu'il continue à le menacer il se
le garde en stock en fait je pense faut
faire F 6 avec les Noirs ici euh à mon
avis euh mais parce qu'en fait lon les
noirs pour le défendre c'est qu'il vait
E8 le
coup 6 mais c'est passif en fait on veut
pas faire ça trop au côté noir
normalement donc donc donc pas bête et
euh et voilà et donc là les blancs
peuvent prendre aussi sou je crois que
c'est c des4 le coup et c'est des vente
à la con comme ça ouais mais il y a du
là tuattaques le cavalier hein euh en D6
et si tu prends B7 en fait tu fais dame
C7 et je crois qu'il on fermé si je dis
pas n'importe
quoi donc tu peux pas en fait c'est pour
ça qu' D4 est pas est pas débile et
c'est un peu sur ce genre d'idée que les
Noirs joue donc peut-être commencer par
fou3 tu peux voilà et 6 qui prend des 6
qui des4 peut-être quand même et là il y
a peut-être des coup comme C5 je crois
et après tu vas attaquer le pion il y
aura des B6 je sais plus exactement le
truc mais c'est je c'est combi c'est une
position quire bordellque
mais bon et puis au pire des cas tuas
pas prendre des si tu as rien fait si
mal avec les blancs mais à partir du
momentù tuas fait fou des TR fou de bon
c'est clair que tu dois faire enfin tu
dois justifier ta perdre de temps mais
c'est plutôt pour taper des 6 que tu
l'as fait hein donc ça on va attendre la
réponse de de yangi après la pause la
partie de de Maxime il a eu H6 le fou
qui est revenu en D3 et fou D7 Maxime
c'est ce qu'il fait il laisse prendre ça
rappelle un plan paqu avit montré
peut-être dans sa partie contre Val gros
de reprendre de F parfois pour repartir
sur G5 allit jouer les casses blanches
mais c'est sûr que c'est bien ça c'est
sûr que c'est bien donc je pense pas que
les blanc vont prendre il ils vont pas
prendre en G6 donc Maxime l'ouverture se
passe plutôt bien en tout cas il a
quasiment une heure d'avance à la à la
pendule et Nakamura on a toujours pas
pas de réponse sur ce F4 on va jeter un
dernier œil Baky ça n'a pas bougé et Ali
Reza non plus donc voilà un petit peu le
bilan après quasiment une heure de jeu
on va vous laisser euh le Multiboard
comme ça vous allez pouvoir tout voir
bien comme il faut et on se retrouve
après la pause à tout de
[Musique]
suite
he he
he he he he
[Musique]
ho
bon les amis on a profité de la pause la
FA qui est en train de de revenir en
fait on a un peu regardé sur l'ordi bon
c'est plus ou moins théoriqueon a pas
énormément de choses à vous raconter
là-dessus mais c'est juste qu'on a un
petit peu regardé de toute façon vu
qu'il se passe rien on on a voulu un peu
analyser de notre côté mais oui c'est
théorique un peu de partout ça ça a été
déjà joué avec les Blancs par kramnick
en title Tuesday mais voilà il y a pas
d'info particulière à à lâcher donc on
est on est revenu pour pour attendre les
coups en votre
compagnie pour attendre les coups en
votre compagnie mesdames et messieurs
oui donc là il y a eu fou H4 on va voir
est-ce qu'il va jouer à avec la dame en
F3 en D3 retour en E3 E3 je pense pas il
y a D4 qui paraît pénible non mais d il
y a peut-être5 donc D 3 ça paraît par
élimination très vite le seul coup
ouais mais
bon autant bien réfléchir Fab
oui voà il s'est plus ou moins rien
passé dans la partie de
Baky bon c'est encore théorique la bonne
nouvelle c'est que si si yangi connaî
pas bien ça pourrait bien se passer pour
pour Baky après là ça dépend vraiment
est- ce qu' connaitt ce qu' connaît pas
donc on peut pas vous en dire beaucoup
plus on verra au fur et à mesure de de
la partie ouais bon le meilleur c'est
fou 6 hein comme je vous disais F 6 F 3
à 6 il faut gambiter le pion à ce
moment-là qui prendre des 6 qui des qu
on en a déjà parlé un peu plusôt dans
dans dans ce live mais ça on verra après
au fil de de la partie nguen mvl ça a
pas énormément joué ça développe les
pièces côté Maxime on va là aussi voir
si Maxime peut avoir des véléités ou ou
pas et euh et dans la partie de Naka il
y a simplement pas eu de de coups depuis
ce ce F4 qui prépare F5 donc on va aller
voir euh le yuyangi donc qui suit la
théorie he pour le moment euh depuis
depuis 1h10 là il s'est c'est pas que
c'est un pass parce que voilà on a déjà
tout expliqué donc on va attendre de
voir jusqu'où ça joue la la théorie et
dans la partie d'Ali r ça on vient
d'avoir le le dame F3 donc qui était le
le coup le coup évident donc
rassurez-vous si si vous navez pas vu
pendant euh une grosse dizaine de
minutes vous n'avez ABS absolument rien
raté mesdames et messieurs on ne rate
pas pas l'action pour le moment non bon
après c'était juste Sarana qui devait se
décider et il a choisi donc de jouer
avec F H4 pour enlever la dame de
G3 ben pourquoi pas
euh et maintenant donc la dame est ici
et ça va laisser le temps au noir bah de
faire autre chose alors pourquoi pas
peut-être fou G5 proposer un échange de
fou réduire un peu la tension
voilà
on va attendre de voir ce qui ce qui ce
qui va décider de de jouer Sarana donc
on prend les les enjeux de la position
le F H4 est intéressant maintenant ce
sont les les joueurs aussi qui ont la la
vérité de la
position voilà si je peux si je peux me
permettre quand il y a plusieurs options
qui paraissent jouaable après c'est au
joueurs de de les jouer ou de ne pas les
jouer d'ailleurs ah c'est
devir
il a joué fou G5 donc comme tu le comme
tu le le l'envisageais pour réduire la
pression matérielle sur proche de son
roi h et ça te redonne des cases après
peut-être que s'il y a plus ce fou la
dame elle pourrait all en C7 le D6 ne
plus avoir trop de pression et cetera
voilà donc les n pour le moment ont un
mauvais fou C8 mais il aura du potentiel
surtout si les noir peut faire5 bien sûr
ça fera un gros centre et le fou qui
sort mais éventuellement ce fou pourit
aussi aller en B7 et faire C5
ou il aurait aussi du jeu voir aller
vers A6 donc il est ok il est pas
terrible mais il a beaucoup de de chance
de pouvoir pointer le bout de son nez
plus tard dans la
partie on imagine un coup comme tour
faut prendre pr peut-être essayer F D3
tour 3 quand même ouais tour1 tour
AD1 tro direct je sais pas
moi pas mal de coups pas mal de coups
poss
possiblebl Baky ça joue pas Maxime il a
eu à 3 bon de toute façon parti de
Maxime on y reviendra plus tard quand B
ce qui nous intéresse c'est le résultat
ouais c'est le résultat plus qu'autre
chose ouais pour le moment et Naka Naka
qui à mon avis est bien parti alors ça
peut faire nos affaires une victoire de
Naka aujourd'hui on sait pas on est soit
pour une victoire soit pour une défaite
a pas de nul soit il prend le large soit
il s'enlise soit ils s'enlisent mais pas
de
demi-mesure mais qui prennent le large
ce serait vraiment l'idéal
hein ludwiig le
large alors pourquoi tu dis ça alors
parce que parce que dans les places
qualificatives au candidats il y en a
deux qui seront attribués au au grand
Suisse il y en a aussi une qui sera
attribuée à Lélo et pour le moment c'est
Naka le grand favori de la de la place à
Lelo derrière au cou à coude avec alirea
qui est pas si loin cependant entre
alirea et West lo et Guiri il y a déjà
un trou de 25 points et l'O qui qui est
fait donc si karunakamura allait
chercher la place qualificative via le
grand Suisse alirea passerait large
favori pour avoir la place à à l'éo en
réalité faudrait qu'il fasse ENF suivant
comment ça se finit on saura exactement
les h à la à la fin du tournoi mais il
faudrait qu'il
finisse à moins de deux points de moins
que Guiry et sa au à la signe que field
Cup ce qui est pas gagneré d'avance
attention hein il suffit qu'il rate un
peu son tournoi il fait 4 sur 9 et gui
fait 6 et demi c'est possible he il peut
aussi tomber malade avant de chance
alors non parce qu'il doit jouer quatre
tournois dans l'année ah il peut pas
tomber malade alors alors si tombe
malade il pourra il sera pas éligible a
la place à l'élo tout simplement Fabien
ok il est obligé d'aller jouer ce
tournoi pour pour être éligible et c'est
tournoi d'un certain standing oui est-ce
que il peut tomber malade il irait un
petit peu mieux après il irait jouer à
ici les moulino par exemple non il faut
avoir quatre tournois dans un certain
standing
d'accord donc il faudra qu'il fasse
qu'il fasse quand même le taf parce que
c'est déjà arrivé dans un tournoi de
voir un joueur passer à travers du
calibre d'aliza et finir à 3 ETI 4/ 9
c'est possible et de voir un joueur en
pleine B surtout qu'il aura deux
adversaires directs so et Guiry et so on
sait he qu'il est capable de finir à 5
et demi ou 6 dans un tournoi comme ça il
aa déjà fait donc si tu as Wesley 5 et
demi bah si tu fais 3 et demi sur 9
c'est terminé hein h et ça c'est pas
dans le domaine de l'impossible c'est
hautement improbable mais il faudra
encore aller chercher les points surtout
que là les les les points hloo d'avance
ils sont pas gravés dans dans dans le
marbre ou dans la roche je peux je peux
te dire avec un un rapide coup d'œil
2700 live sur 2700 en live quelle est la
différence de de points donc aliresa qui
a actuellement
2775 S qui a
2751 euh
donc 24 points
c'est que tout ouais 24 points mais mais
mais mais lesécart pourrai se réduire
avec la fin du tournoi parce qu'on voit
que dans ce grand Suisse les meilleurs
perdre plutôt des points il suffirait
qu'il en perde 6 7 là sur les dernières
rondes
il y aurait plus que 15 points d'écart
et 15 points tu finis un point et demi
derrière tu tu es sorti donc ça peut
aller très très vite fa bien non ça peut
ça peut
mais ça ça semble trop quoi mais ça peut
aller très vite oui oui non bien sûr tu
peux
déraper ça va en plus il va pas faire un
score démoniaque quoi ouais mais il est
capable de te faire 5 et dem sur
9 mais bon c'est pasmiaque mais tu fais
4 sur 9 4 sur 9 c'est pas enfin ou non
mais sûr tu peux et puis tout d'un coup
tu es pas au candidat donc il faudra et
ça c'est dans le cas où où où Ikaru
Nakamura se qualifie via le grand Suisse
Fabien oui oui et et c'est pas fait non
plus alors qu'on a okage qui arrivit
dans dans le
chat
comme dit dictal après il peut faire top
2 et puis on en parle plus B évidemment
c'est tout ce qu'on lui souhaite alors
après le truc c'est que s'il est proche
de faire top 2 genre qu'il finit à une
place derrière enfin admettons que Naka
fe 1 un mec Fe 2 carwana Fe 3 et qu'il
fasse 4 admettons le truc c'est que dans
ces caslà il gagnerait des points ho il
sera encore plus large et il serait
vraiment large pour la S field Cup donc
en réalité même si Naka le le dépasse
d'une place que Naka fait deux carz a
fait 3 il aura 26 27 points de plus que
West leso dans cette configuration là
donc il faudra qu'il fasse non il faudra
vraiment faire n'importe quoi pour que
ça se pas donc ça ira c'est dans ce sens
là que si Naka va vraiment chercher la
place en fait c'est c'est mieux quoi
comme dit thodor le pire serait Ikaru 3
et firirou 4 mais là même là tuas tuas
tu as encore dans ta manche une carte
carwana gagne le tournoi qui est déjà
qualifié le trisème SER qualifié donc il
y a beaucoup de cas favorable dans le
cas où Naka joue bien non mais s'il y a
ikaro 3 F 4 ou non mais jeux dire c'est
en fait Naka Naka joue bien et vraiment
bien pour nous c'est Naka fini 5e qui
est horrible pour nous 4e ou 5e ouais là
c'est vraiment la la catastrophe et il
faudra aller gagner la S fi C avec 6
voir même 6 et demi sur 9 ce qu' là est
difficile évidemment et donc moi j'avais
une dernière question là pour ce
califello ils le prennent à un
classement précis où il faut une sorte
celui du 1er janvier il y a que lui qui
compte je crois que c'est 1er janvier
ouais
ok seul et unique
Fab c'est pas terrible je trouve la
moyenne a plus de sens quand même bon
ils font comme ils veulent
hein après il force à jouer au moins
quatre tournois de haut niveau sur
l'année non ça au moins c'est déjà une
bonne une bonne chose de faite ils ont
raison tu peux pas rester assis sur ta
chaise à ne pas jouer et te qualifier en
pas
justement est-ce qu'on par le Baky qui
est en train de s'enver sur le top 2 B
on a pas mal parlé tout tout ça est très
théorique hein pour le moment les
joueurs qui sont encore dans la théorie
ici dans la dans la partie d'Étienne bah
là il va prendre en D6 il y aura qu' D4
et le meilleur coup c'est C5 comme on
vous l'a dit yuyangi qui prend beaucoup
de risque aujourd'hui euh mais lui il
est dans la problématique aussi de
devoir marquer des points et on en a
déjà longuement parlé au début du du
tournoi où en réalité tu es plutôt dans
la meilleure situation quand tu es le
chassé plus que le chasseur dans ce dans
ce grand Suisse c'est quasiment un par
j'irais pas dire un avantage mais le le
le peloton des mal
classés a autant de chance de se
qualifier que les 4 C gros si tu les
prends le l'armée des l'armée des pions
ouais a autant de chance de se qualifier
que les meilleur non non bien sûr ça pe
ouais parce que le nombre le nombre fait
le fait la balance comme on disait
normalement à égalité de s'il y a trois
joueurs qui finissent à 8 sur 11 le
joueur à 26 50 27 finira devant le les
top mondiaux donc on n'est pas à l'AB
d'avoir un joueur classé en dessous de
2700 se qualifier c'est très possible
c'est très possible c'est très possible
et ces joueurs là aussi ont un certain
avantage c'est que comme les autres
veulent Absolum les battre en disant bon
allez ça y est j'en a apparimment facile
alors entre guillemets hein tout est
relatif mais ils disent ah ça va
j'aiévité carwana par exemple et et ben
je dois absolument cette partie je
prends tous les risques parce que si pas
là de toute façon je me qualifie pas et
que c'est un peu un tournoi winner titol
ou cétait pas de premier de toute façon
pourquoi tu joues alors à part à part
firou et nakar on a expliqué le le truc
pour eux mais pour tous les autres et
donc tu peux avec une stratégie
peut-être un défois un peu attentiste
attendre que l'autre prenne des risques
pour aller le cueillir al c'est ce
qu'espère évidemment Baky hein ce serait
de gagner aujourd'hui avec avec les
pièces blanche en en contrant un
adversaire qui tentait de de le battre
avec les noirs et après d'essayer de
serrer la vis au maximum et attendre
peut-être la dernière ronde pour pour
venir placer un contreassassin à un
favori en en mustwin euh ben par exemple
c'est un beau scénario ça
euh mais on va suivre quand même du coin
de l'il cette partie intéressante je
disons qu'en fait ce qui se passe si
tous les joueurs bon ils connaissent et
l'un et l'autre joue toute la théorie
jusqu'au bout normalement c'est k des7
là le coup pour les euh ça rend dans une
finale où il y a tour fou cavalier de
chaque côté et quatre P contre TR pour
les blancs qui est censé être égal
d'après l'ordi mais donc du coup il y a
que les Blancs qui peuvent espérer
quelque chose mais ça ce serait ce
serait un scénario idéal mais c'est en
gros ce à quoi ça peut tomber sur un jeu
parfait de part et d'autrre d' si les de
que je vais regarder voilà s suivent mes
analyses mais pour l'instant c'est c'est
le
cas ça continue Maxime qui clique je
pense qu'il va juste gagner en cliquant
tout tempo comme l'autre jour en fait
ouais justeand si tuis enever ton G6 tu
fais g5s je P c'est ce qu'il va
faire vas quoi F4
machin
je pense qu'en fait un vraiment mauvais
appariment c'est ikarou pour tout le
monde je crois que c'est le pire
appariment parce qu'il perd jamais
quasiment contre les moins de
2007 je crois qu'il est vraiment
horrible à jouer dans ce tournoi si tu
es entre 26 et 27 20 30 je pense que le
joueur que tu as pas envie de taper
c'est
ikarou en fait il arrive ils arrivent
jamais à le finir non mais après bon il
fait monter moy si jamais quoi oui mais
je par là que un Carana enfin Carana il
peut il peut perdre des fois il pe mais
Naka tu as l'impression qu'il peut pas
quoi c'est pas dans son range bah c'est
vrai que la partie qu'il fait c'était
quoi rondin h contre un des de Van là
lamentable quoi sa partie était très
très mal avec les blancs mais bon mais
il défend tellement bien il est pas
arrivé à perdre pour autant quoi ah
ouais non je pense vraiment que c'est
l'appariment cauchemar
ikarou
après Sarana c'est pas forcément un
super appariment pour aliera moi je trve
c'est plutôt bien parce que c'est un
joueur qui peut envoyer mais c'est vrai
qu'il est vraiment un 2682 c'est vrai
qu'il est vraiment fort non c'est un bon
joueur c'est un bon joueur après bon le
truc de toute façon pour les gagner ce
pour faire top 2 de ce ce tournoi il
faut de toute façon battre des joueurs
de ce
libre tu tu dois battre des bons joueurs
quoi le TR quand même nettement plus
fort qu'il a 2 ans
ouais il y a plus de plus dense il y a 2
ans c'était quand même pas facile
évidemment mais là c'est plus
dense par un genur comme Guiry qui a que
à+ 1 alors bon Guy on sait que c'est pas
son fort de gagner des parties mais il
arrive quand même normalement un peu
quoi donc juste plus un sur six parties
c'est que ouais pas facile
quoi c'est pose une question marrante
mais du coup si on a ikarou vs firou à
la dernière onond et qu'il soit en gros
4 et 5e les deux firou auraient plutôt
intérêt à perdre qu'à faire nul en fait
il aurait intérêt à jouer le gain à
fond et si ça passe pas de faire exprès
de
perdre tu essayes de gagner quand même
pour te qualifier et si c'est nul bah tu
donnes ta dam en un et tu laisses
l'autre gagner le tournoi ouis pas de
chance pas de chance mais en fait tu as
le droit en fait tu fais ce que tu veux
quoi h regard madame mais oui clairement
it
[Musique]
[Rires]
resign pex
queenqueenclear check check check repeat
the
moves mais ouais mais du coup partie je
sais pas pas don c'est intéressant joué
mais qu'il a plutôt bien réagi éch des
fou l'absence du Fou F4 ça permet aussi
à la tour d'aller en B8 cette case pour
t'acti donc parti qui va
durer partie qui va durer côté
[Musique]
béféch
qui qui peut se retrouver bien la prpA
qui qui s'est plutôt bien passé au final
il s'est bien
souvenu Maxime qui a décidé de faire un
B5 quasiment à tempo Maxime il décide de
clique en fait
ouis il emploie la
stratégie soit il sa par cœur non mais
je crois qu'il emploie Mar je pense
qu'il clique juste non non il emploie
maat je croison parler dis moi quand je
vois rien que j'arrive pas à calculer je
clique jeque j'en ai absolument rien à
et puis un moment donné si dans
la partie faut calculer j'essaye mais à
un moment quoifin je crois que la strat
elle est pas mal en fait hein quand tu
arrives vraiment pas à jouer bah c'est
mieux que perdre du temps de t'énerver
non mais il me disait par exemple la
partie la partie contre dura Bailey il
me disait par exemple que il aurait
mieux jouer en blitz en
fait quand tu arrives pas à calculer tu
cliques hein et ça met une pression sur
l'adversaire ouais est-ce que lui il
sait pas tu c tu cliques tout
dans la gueule quoi démerde-toi calcule
connard
une strat qui a fait ses preuves
Fab est-ce que tu l'as déjà employé
cette strate c'est pas trop ton style
non non mais je suis rendu compte
c'était bien des fois je me
forçais tu cliques quoi bah ta main elle
s'est encore joué quoi c'est ça le
truc ah oui donc tu peux juste clique et
puis
tu as pas trop mal jouer non plus non
non
[Musique]
tu ça suffit largement contre un tel tu
sais après c'est dangereux mais de toute
façon si tu peux pas tu peux pas si tu
pas en condition de bien calculer toute
façon tu pourrasah tu dois faire avec
les armes que tuas c'est ça si tu as
plus
d'armes
donc bon au moins tu peux jouer
vite al qui
réfléchitangi qui
réfléchit tout le monde
réfléchit réfléchissez messieurs
donc pr qui a choisi une
ligne intéressante avec ce
5 on dit que tu vois trop de trucs qui
existent pas en réfléchissant et le pire
c'est que c'est vrai à tous les niveaux
HM
malheureusement al nous a habitué
lorsqu'il réfléchissait longtemps sur un
coup à à pas avoir de bonnes position
pas forcément à mal jouer avir des
positions qui géraent mal à un moment X
ou
Y
h
ok il se passe rien on va attendre on
peut aller voir les car ou 2 secondes
voir ce qui se passe si l'autre il prend
le pion moi j'ai 5 non pas du
tout tu vas arriver avec fou C5 en fait
sur fou
D4 C7 double attaque ok qui G4 le coup
ouais donc le 5 bah faut se
barrer peut-être encore ok G4 d'ailleurs
ouais
h peutre tu prends ou ouais pourquoi
pas
euh ça ou je sais
pas je sais pas intéressant de tuer le
pion comme ça pour jouer HM le fou qui
débarque qui prte le bout de son nez
ouais en tout cas pas mal pr que qui qui
qui a eu une réaction dans la position
de s'est pas laissé marcher dessus c'est
un beau joueur he ce pr que il a un bon
départage en plus que lui il a quoi il a
battu à 10b 2550 d'accord après il a
joué 27 26 il a gagné encore il a joué
26 80 27 12 27 17 2698 et 27 80 et prê
que on se rappelle que pour son hlo il
est ultra dangereux he il est bon c'est
un bon joueur je sais pas pourquoi il a
jamais plus de hlo en fait ouais moi non
plus je mettrai plutôt 2006 80 2007
chaque fois qu'on doit faire un truc il
est toujours pas mal placé il est là
quoi il qui a joué cavalier A4 bon mais
il ve aller vers vers C5 il vers C5
ouais cavalier D6 cavalier C5
admettons et ça joue hein c'est
compliqué mais ok
intéressant k D6 k C5 est-ce que il
faudrait prendre en de 4 tant pis avec
une moins bonne structure mais au moins
on enlève ce cavalier très puissant qui
domine le fou et compagnie tu pe jouer k
B7 peut-être
h à voir en tout cas il semble que que
Sarana est réussi à presque
égaliser
Baki ça commence à sentir bon yyangi se
rappelle pas il pourrait passer par de
sur bord le joueur chinois Fab
euh oui alors as après je sais pas si tu
vois enfin je sais que c'est le meilleur
coup je sais pas à quel point c'est
forcé et compagnie tuas peut-être
d'autres options de jeu un peu moins
bonnes sans être une position
catastrophique
mais mais oui en en tout cas rentrer
dans une venteù tu files un pion c'éit
pas absolument sûr de ce que tu fais
c'est un peu étonnant quand
même il aurait dû te consulter fa pour
la préparation dans dans la calach et
ouais mais bon
le truc le DV n pas encore sorti quoi
donc AE AE a a il est pas bien quoi il y
a le vieux livre qu'on a fait avec
Mathieu mais on ne parlait pas de cette
V ça existait pas à l'époque c'est
peut-être pour ça il est pas
bien est-ce que c'esti qui a éliminé
Baki non Baki avait battu il avait été
complètement gagnant luangi il devait
dans la française là ouais l'emporté
sans trop de problème et B qui avait
retourné il TR un truc tout coup
ouais je me souviens de la
partie avantage psychologique pour bcky
ah je suis pas sûr mais
euh bon en tout cas s'il y en a un qui
aantage psychologique c'est c'est Baki
on est d'accord mais je suis pas sûr que
y enfin je pense plutôt que c'est
l'ouverture là qui procure un avantage à
Baki qui sait ce qu'il fait alors que
yongi ne sait pas
ou il sait plus il doit vraiment se
remémorer à fond ah c'est des ventes
compliqué hein clairement il faut avoir
en
tête
ça réfléchit en tout cas à côté
Sarana est-ce que Bak a déjà joué au
candidat il a déjà joué mais c'est un
format complètement différent avec 16
joueurs il c'est en élimination ouais
ouais c'était vraiment complètement
différent mais du coup plutôt oui quoi
plutôt oui
plutôt oui que
non alors ne vous vous inquiétez pas là
si un petit temps mort c'était c'était
prévu ça
s'emballlera vers 19h vers
19h on
s'avance doucement mais sûrement vers
vers
l'emballement
pas un coup pour
Max j'ai pr
5 mais est-ce qu'il faut vraiment le
faire ou pas je sais
pas je comprends vousou regagner la
pièce avec des cas donc on peut c'est
trouvable mais est-ce qu'on est si
ravi
je sais pas moi je je suis pas sûr que
j'irai pour ça moi trouve la position
mais bon après il a fait H8
ah ben voilà un coup maximesque pour G5
G4 don le C au bord est pas assez
maximesque là il a trouvé la meilleure
case au bord quoi et ala ça a joué il y
a eu cavalier F6 et alira qui a at tempo
répondu par fou D3 c'est intéressant sa
conception il veut jouer avec le bon
cavalier contre le mauvais
fou par en fait je me questionnais mais
bon sur k C5 là sur le DPR mais déjà on
n'est pas obligé mais k C5 d k prend k
prend dame prend genre tour B8 ouais je
pensais B3 C5 et je pensais que ça
allait
pas mais je sais pas ok je vois que la
structure est un peu moins bonne
mais on va faire fou B7 on VO
donc ça ouais je suis pas sûr qu'il
veille et du coup ok donc c'est pas le
scénario voulu par Alireza il a joué F
D3 en se disant voilà si maintenant tu
veux prendre en4 je prends du Fou tu
prends je fais dame prend et on n pas
les mêmes
pièces tu veux jouer ce genre de
position où on peut travailler à long
terme alors l'ordi ça F pas du tout vous
voez la jauge mais normalement on naime
pas trop Jer ce genre de
truc donc F des trois coups intéressants
6 le coup de l'ordi il peut avoir un
tour A3 intéressant a l'idée de faire
tour F3 et cavalier C5 ou tour H3
d'ailleurs aussi c'est pe V V mal ah
mal pour ouais
complètement moi j'aime beaucoup la
conception de d'alira dans cette partie
ouais moi je ferai pas des pr en tout
cas après ben je sais pas est-ce que
tour B8 c'est un coup est-ce que
E5 t B8 c'est logique hein parce que du
coup tu pousse un peu B3 et ça évitera
de se prendre le B4 à3 cavalier C5 ouais
puis de toute façon est mieux placé en
B8 qu'en A8 he enfin juste
bêtement et peut-être un coup comme5 à
un moment voilà qui rajoute de la
tension au centre peut-être T1 t 8 on
verra
complexe il a joué k D7 donc il connaît
encore un yuyangi assez étonnant je
pense qu'ils font surtout un un travail
de réminiscence ouais les deux joueurs
ils doivent connaître mais ça doit être
des souvenirs lointains donc ils ont
besoin de temps pour refaire marcher le
fichier bon là c'est B4 le coup je le
dis ça c'est vu Maxime cavalier à chite
s vu aussi et ikarou ikarou qui tankque
hein le E5 là de prê de que est très
bien joué ouais et euh mais du coup je
me questionne si F4 éit trop tôt ou
pas possible attends attend on nous pose
une question intéressante alors on
demande si Maxim aurait pas inversé les
coups mais inverser les coups par
rapport à quoi en fait
Silas j'ai pas trop question
intéressante c'est juste que j'ai envie
d'arriver
au je pas de inverser avec quoi est qu'
fallit leord donner au coup d'avant mais
inverser avec quoi en
fait
B5 non mais k H8 c'est pas idiot tu veux
faire G5 et ou ne pas le faire mais
passer le fou le fou8 qui en H5 ou un
truc comme ça donc en soi pourquoi pas
et de deux tu te donnes aussi un chemin
pourquoi pas pour faire k F7 k G5
K4 tu as des petites idées quoi enfin
donc bon moi ça me va enfin je sais pas
leord dit là il te met point
d'interrogation bon ben ah bah al double
point d'incorreation enfin bon mais en
fait il quiie à fond son c pr 5 euh mais
il va peut-être le
faire ouais parce que il a il y a plus
parce que
ouais en tout cas qu'est je veux dire
euh time alors il demande pourquoi F4
gagne pas mais c'est à cause de H7 ou
force F7 et là du
[Musique]
coup mais gaffe vite fait parce que
c'est pas mieux au noir c'est pas clair
prend on prend 5 des
4 ça donne pas une pièce quoi pour les
blancs
non mais du coup
ouais tuas prend d à priori prend
cavalier peut-être F3 du coup pour
défendre 5 tuand même alletour pour rien
[Musique]
H qui va arriver cavalier F7 tu t'es
replacé VO c'est meilleure tête en plus
je l'aime bien défend ce qui est notre
se faiblesse quoi on la paire de fou la
position qui
s'ouvreour Maxim qui peut qui peut
peut-être faire le taf et il y a eu dans
la partie
d'5ok bon
logique
logique de la part de Sarana qui avait
un fou un peu enterré qui pouit plus
trop Leser ver B7 à 6 et donc il s'ouvre
de l'autre côté donc soit vers E6 soit
vers G4 soit vers nulle part mais au
moins le fois des cases et et pour
ensuite donc va jouer le T B8 dont on
parlait et pourquoi pas l'autre tour en
E ou D8 on imagine tour F1
tranquillement on va voir la partie qui
va s'amimer un peu plus tard la partie
de B qui all est animé déjà mais pour le
moment c'est encore la théorie et
Nakamura E5 il se l' pris dans le coin
de la des pieds en train de se prendre
dans le tapis carou dans cette partie ça
fait pas forcément nos
affaires on demande le score pour gagner
un tour 11 rondes euh ben je crois que
c'est plus
5 5 et demi plus de Demi 8 8 ouais ça
doit être
doit suffire pour gagner
doit suffire Fab là c'est hyper dur de
faire plus 5 hein là les leaders ont
plus 3 donc il faudrait qu'il fasse
encore deux victoires sur les CIN
parties restantes et tu joues bah les
joueurs qui son on le plus en forme et
qui joue bien dans ce tournoi donc c'est
bah c'est pas simple mais ouais il faut
plutôt ça après peut-être que ça ça sera
7 et demi mais à ce momentlà il y aura
un paquet de joueurs et ça jouera au au
départage ouais auartage donc plutôt H8
pour pour être vraiment sûr normalement
à 8 tu es
qualifié et Maxime qui entame ça remonte
à he s'il gagne aujourd'hui ah ouais bah
c'est bien faud en gagner encore quatre
bah ça reste toujours improbable mais
moins que quand c'était 6 quoi c'est ça
le
truc
et tu veux aller voir Fabiano c'est une
genre de position que tu joues toi donc
c'est juste pour tu peux nous dire un
peu ce que tu en
penses c'était ton ouverture en
fait
ah mais fait une Cambry spring quoi
enfin c'est
ouais il joue ça comme ça
ais pr un spécial quoi mais ouais mais
je sais pas je l'imession tu tu as
l'impression d'être moins bien avec les
Noirs mais en fait c'est pas très grave
grave he c'est solide ok voilà mais
j'aimerais pas trop avoir les Noirs
quand
même je prendrai les blancs
Fab je sais pas il j'aime pas avoir le
pion F6 en fait il t'énerve j'aime pas
laisser E4 F4 à l'adversaireit que les
trucs que j'aais pas mais des fois tu es
obligé non dans cette ouverture B Cambry
spring peut-être ouais mais moi en
général ce que je veux faire bah si je
peux hein là apparemment il pouvait
juste pas mais c'est essayer de prendre
en E4 et de faire C5 plutôt ou prendre
E4 et faire E5 prendre C4 prise et5
aussi tu vois des fois tu veux
mais mais là c'est quand même pén il a
beaucoup d'activité quand même avec les
blan il a eu beaucoup
d'activités donc j'ais plutôt mieux pour
les
blanc tour comme
prévutre tour 8
voilà cal C5 et on va
voir toujours toujours la
théorie est-ce que les deux ne se
rappellent pas c'est aussi
probable et Maxime qui a joué le
cavalier PR5 bien joué il va être plutôt
mieux un peu mieux mais il y la p de fou
dont on
parlait c'est un petit truc quoi et ça
peut bien tourner très vite en fait sur
qu' priori sonersaire s attendait pas tu
fais pas c des deux tu as vu en
fait complètement claqué son adversaire
en fait don déjà Maxim a joué tout tempo
que l'autre a déjà passé 1h 10 15 20 je
sais pas réfléchir tu es déjà fatigué de
ta réflexion et en fait tu as réfléchi
pour faire de la merde quoi donc ça peut
vite tourner pour Maxime en bien quoi
que qui continue à jouer la théorie bien
joué B6 et a 5 le coup c'est ce qu'on ce
qu'on imaginait ça se rappelle pas de la
théorie et donc B6
faute de yuyangi qui s'est pas rappelé
en premier finalement bon après encore
fautil le réfuter hein c'est une autre
histoire parce que pour r attends l'ORD
il fait quoi il fait F4
ouais c'est hyper dur de réfuter
cavalier prend
E2 il donne la
qualité réfléchir s' pas de
intermédiaire pr F4 cavalier pr
F4 que faut paser chercher no je sais
pas parce que parce que y a du jeu les
cas noir le qui
H6 sacrifice qu'on a des FO dans la GRF
mais bon pas évident d'avoir
F4 je pense qu'il va
l'avoir
et si tu commences par
baisser ah c'est ça qui est dur c'est
qu' faut qu'er F5 parce que BC BC qui il
prend C5 quand même bah là il sont bien
ouais donc il faut avoir BC
F5 CB
F
BC pr F7 j'imagine pr D7 plutôt ouais
bon tu as une pièce de plus qu
tu es bien là ouais h il s'en va ok
c'est trouvable quandme c'est pas facile
he mais c'est peut-être trouvé F4 puis
on prend
F5 il le fou enfermé en
fait F5 c'est pas trop dur enfin quand
il peut y avoir des découvertes des
machins des trucs cavalier F6 par
exemple tu as
baissé et si tu fais k pr de puis on
prend F4 qui2 puis qui prend2 puis on
prend C5 puis on prend
C5 F qui prend F4 un autre coup mais
tuas de plus hein et qui 6 très très
pénible he dans la position il est bien
placé donc bon c'est sûr c'est plutôt
mieux au blanc quoi mais peut-être faut
quand même pas prendre la T en pratique
quoi bah qui qui peut la gagner hein bah
écoute s'il a F4 mais je pense qu'il va
l'avoir bah en fait disons tu peux
l'avoir parce que bah c'est relativement
logique de desésarconé ce qu' D4 et de
deux si tu sais que B6 c'est pas le coup
tu dis ok il y a peut-être un problème
pour les no une autre raison en fait
c'est que sinon tu fais
quoi alors qu' est A4 tu te fais quand
même prendre de France C 5 ou
pas euh
ouais
ça tu fais rien mais tu perds
pas très bien tu passer ton fond C 4 D5
faire des trucsavoir par par
élimination parce que il
peut en fait sinon c'est est-ce que tour
c'est fort c'est ça en fait qu'il faut
se demander BC k
B7 est-ce que tu peux essayer de faire
un truc comme ça tuas pas de grosse
découverte
non non mais je voulais voir avec quoi
tu peux te tromper
quoi par que F4 c'est dur sans être si
dur en
fait non non c'est pas ba F5 et que tu
as cavalier E2 qui prend de puis on
prend cavalier
prend c'est quand même hyper thématique
de laisser la tour et d'attaquer le roi
oui maismatique non non mais c'est c'est
trouvable je dis pas que
mais en plus c'est le moment de prendre
sa chance les blanc euh tu as une partie
qui joue il tuas pas essayer de fermer
avec une petof ou je ne sais quoi et
l'adversaire te joue un coup qui est pas
le
Main donc ok ça peut mettre la puce à
l'oreille que peut-être il y a un truc à
trouver
ouais mais en plus c'est le seul coup
pour l'avantage
h moi je pense qu'il va
l'avoir
moi je pense qu'il va l'avoir
ici bon c'est pas 90 % mais je donnerai
bien 75 % qu'il tu
vois parce que plus tu réfléchis à la
position plus tu te demandes ce qui peut
non mais sinon tu sinon c'est tour C1 ou
cavalier à4 mais c'est égal et en plus
vu la situation du tournoi il doit TER
sa chance il a les blancs B4 c'est le
coup ah mais sinon tu pe peut-être
peutre jou P C4 si nul ça doit non ouais
mais le truc c'est qu'il veut pas faire
nul non mais je sais je veux dire tu tu
vois que tu as pas un grand danger mais
que
comme je dis surtout si tu tu sais que
c'est à 5 le coup tu vois que ça c'est à
côté et que ok ouais puis vu la
situation du tournoi B c'est maintenant
ou jamais c'est maintenant ou
jamais donc pour cette raison je pense
que Baky a des chances de trouver après
c'est pas fait hein non tu joues F4 et
tu vas au combat mais tu tu es bien et
puis et puis tuenvoies sur les cases
noires tout ça ou et F4 F4 il y a pas
d'autres options on est d'accord on F5
du coup et
ça F5 même j'y crois
pas complètement
con C6 on nous propose
prend il y a rien il y a pas de
suite
je sais pas ce qu'on peut avoir d'autres
commei c'est t C1 c'est cavalier A4 je
dis bon C4 pour changer puis puis puis
fait rien d'autre mais
[Musique]
voilà non il a pas non pour moi il va
l'avoir
oufin gr faut pas se mettre à suer avec
les Blancs dire merde j'ai fait le con
avant
et hisire de confiance aussi làdedans
ouais moi ce que j'aime bien c'est la
situation du tournoi tu as rien à
perdre tu as ta chance à prendre et en
plus le coup paraî quand même
relativement intéressant en fait là
donner la qualité ça fait pas non plus
super peur non non mais là tu vois que
tu as des compensations je sais
peut-être pas à quel point mais je ve
dire qui en plus de la culture il
connait les grunf des compagnies il a
déjà vu ce genre de truc donc ça va oui
parti contue comme ça
ouais avec une belle position après
c'est pas gagner mais c'est un réal
avantage allez on va espérer qu'il le
trouve le le F4 on va pas le Jinx maxime
lui qui a trouvé qui a un avantage là ça
se passe plutôt bien carwana bon on
reviendra bien plus
tardza il a joué tour ça réfléchit côté
Sarana c'est plutôt bien ikarou et
ikarou ikarou il est pas bien peut-être
al pas bien c'est un grand mot
mais prê que prê que là qui a un gros
shot parce qu'on l' dit lui il a joué
des joueurs qui avait plutôt un B des
bons élos donc une une victoire contre
ikarou ici 5 et demi sur sur 7 lui il
pourrait gagner le tournoi 7 et dememi
oui avec un très bel très beau départage
ou faire second mais qualifié ou quoi
ouais surtout si carwana s'envole un
petit peu ça pourrait lui permettre de
d'être sûr si si caroana si tu un joueur
qui finit à 8 je suppose que c ennemi
suffira pour 3e place quoi donc ça peut
être une belle opération pour prê que
après on l'a aussi dit en en préambule
ikarou c'est un joueur qui ne perd
quasiment jamais he contre des joueurs
de ce niveau-là
jeis pas perdre là va une St de paire de
fou mais il va installer un gros
cavalier en D5 et il est force cavalier
quoi oui car on a déjà qualifi en fait
quoi qu'il fasse dans ce tournoi mais
donc justement s'il finit prier ou
second il prend une clificative mais il
va pas se qualifier deux fois donc ça
libérerait la trème place pour bah pour
le jou fin 3e ici et pour se qualifier
pour pour les
candidats tour 8 côté Sarana Fab le plus
logique juste il vient surprotéger son
pion
en5 qui subisait une petite pression
après un prend qui peut arriver à tout
moment
donc donc
logique pour allier le mais je pense va
faire nul en fait ce qui est un peu
notre pire
résultat côté
Naka attend le coup d'aliza à
présent est-ce que B qui peut se
qualifier écoute sil gagne aujourd'hui
je dir il y aurait une vraie chance on
va dire ça comme ça là il a il il a un
vrai shot by pour se mêler à la bagarre
à la Calif
après s'il gagne aujourd'hui il faudra
encore faire plus 1 sur 4 parties c'est
loin d'être
fait mais il pourra il pourra avoir sa
chance départage il est loin devant B
alors attention parce que il sera pas
forcément loin devant des joueurs comme
prê que donc ça dépendra vraiment truc
de moyenneo là c'est un peu un peu
compliqué
ça doit pas être évident de savoir ce
qui est le mieux pour allier resas va
jouer dans des détails à position ah
complètement c'est pas clair hein tu
peux bah com on a dit tu as envie de
ramener ce cavalier à 4 vers C5 mais bon
tu peut-être pas obligé de faire tout de
suite tu peux songer à jouer des finales
pourquoi pas pour attaquer plus
facilement le 5 tu peux peut-être
vouloir doubler les tours à un moment
don pere tu fais H3 d'abord pour
préparer faire tour2 on dit bah qui pas
trouveré ple de coup bah qui qui a joué
cavalier à 4
ah euh
ouais mais c'estfin bah façon on l'ait
donné c'est cavalier A4 tour1 ou
F4 on avait dit B pran peut-être mais il
a peut-être qu' B regardé BC BC qui
prend C5 qui va pour les Noirs mais
peut-être sur BC il y a un autre
coup de prendre du CAH direct en C5 ok
bon pas clair euh après l'ordi il
suggère de faire quand même A5
maintenant qui reste logique pour casser
cette muraille de pion de A3 il a fou B3
je
crois fallait le montrer Fab ouais non
bien sûr et donc a 5 ça a tout son sens
pour casser ces deux pions blancs qui
défendent enfin qui défendent tout quoi
ils se défendent entre eux il défendent
le K
D6 et les n veulent juste aomber pour
enlever le soc de C
assez logique on va voir si si yangi le
trouve ça va être le moment de la poche
je propose qu'on refasse un un petit
récapitulatif de ce qui se passe donc
Baki il a pas trouvé malheureusement le
le F4 il faudra voir ce que ce que joue
yyongi et si Baki peut encore avoir une
chance de prendre l'avantage Maxime il
continue à à enchaîner les coups il
semble avoir pris l'avantage contre
enguen on va voir la suite voek contre
contre carwana carwana et proche de
l'égalité quand même un poil moins bien
on va dire avec ton feeling de ce genre
de position mais oui ça devrait passer
normalement quand même euh ikaro un poil
moins bien mais ça devrait passer aussi
et Alera c'est le gros combat annoncé de
la journée avec les parties de Baky
finalement on a peut-être les deux
parties les les plus intéressantes
messieurs on vous laisse pour une
dizaine de minutes et on revient très
vite pour la suite du tournoi à tout de
suite les amis à tout de
suite
[Musique]
he he
he
[Musique]
les amis on est de de retour il y a eu
dame G3 de la part d' et
H6 bah il défend sa dame alors la
question qui se pose à lui c'est est-ce
que il échange luiême en G3 ou il se
laisse échanger et donc Sarana il a pas
voulu prendre lui-même en G3 bon cétait
sûrement une option mais après h pr
peut-être on donne un plomb blanc de
faire F3 ou F4 et G4 G5 ou voilà
peut-être 3 F2 qui va montter plus vite
Tchin et cetera et il se dit qu'en
faisant H6 s est échange il prend de h
alors certes c'est double les pions mais
c'est pas vraiment faible parce que
personne pour attaquer même ce pion
pourra aller vers G4 fixer un peu la
structure blanche et euh et voilà donc
c'est possible qu'en fait et l'un et
l'autre ne ne prennent pas pour
l'instant et euh qu'irasa joue un autre
coup du type tour à1 ou je ne sais
quoi
probablement
probablement donc là on est de nouveau
en en réflexion mesdames et
messieurs de part et d'autrre peutre on
peut refaire une pause ah est-ce que la
partie de by donc il cavalier A4 et le
a5 qui s'est pas passé grand chose c'est
le coup qu'on attendait aussi ouais mais
bien joué donc de la part de de yangi
qui a trouvé la la parade la bonne
réponse dans la position et ça peut se
simplifier assez vite ce genre de chose
en gros les noir menace de prendre deux
fois en C5 puisque le C D6 n'aurait plus
de défense et euh et donc ça fera un
échange assez massif dans la dans la
position avec ce c des4 toujours quand
même pas mal placé donc faire un peu
attention avec les enfin vite fait
attention mais bon c'est pas tout simple
non
plus Maxime bon il est plutôt mieux ça
pas énormément évolué mais il y a C
histoire de paire de fou le fou8 il peut
aller à droite il peut aller à gauche
alors bon là il peut pas aller
en peut pas aller en C6 pour le moment
évidemment puisqu a le P E6 attaquer
mais ça serait une très belle diagonale
si on y arrivait tôt ou tard donc on
peut songer à essayer de le ramener par
là a différentes manières et sinon même
s activé de l'autre côté bon après ça
reste relativement solide hein chez le
joueur TCK check ouais
mais mais on peut y croire pour Maxime
on peut avoir espoir et
ikarouarouarou c'est chaud qu'est-ce que
il all les pouffer ce pion
là-bas
complètement complètement taré carou
mais c'est hyper chaud ouais ou non mais
en fait enfin venant de lui en fait
pourquoi pas il a bien placé son F en D5
il fait ça il veut essayer de bouffer B7
à passer
euh ok intéressant en fait comme choix
finalement ce qu' nous fait i caresque
ouais et donc alira notre partie fil
rouge de la
journée qui nous promettait un feu
d'artifice un petit peu plus tôt et qu'
a bat un petit peu de de l'ile mais euh
qui va s'emballer hein bien évidemment
fa puisquil y a que 18 coups joués il
reste 22 coups on voit les pendules qui
s'amenuisent petit à
petit donc on attend comme comme
relativement souvent dans ces journées
du Grand
Suisse qui s'intéresse he au parti qui
nous garde hein sur le téléphone je vois
nous dégotte des belles
choses mais bon pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent une nouvelle
fois non mais il y a bon il y a parti de
Vassek on regarda un peu contre carwana
qui évolue gentiment mais euh mais qui
bouge un peu ikarou c'est très compliqué
donc bon on y passé dessus mais
ça ça va évoluer il va se passer des
choses et dans les autres parties des
joueurs de tête il y a une partie entre
sindarov et vidit pas clair mais fait sa
partie cré petit
danger bon vu comme ça je sais pas trop
peutêtre intéressant
pourci concret mais c l' menç coupil
juste
pour
oigille
confirmer impression visuelle
noter que ouais il joue assez vite il il
a une demiheure d'avance à la pendule
sur son adversaire il peut peut-être
jouer un coup comme C5 là pour ouvrir le
fou B3 menacer bah k F7 K6 fou E6 des
choses comme ça ou voir des prend H7 et
la dame qui r H5 faire des réseaux de
mat
donc donc ouais intéressant pour qui lui
aussi et dem déjà ça pourrait être un
adversaire sérieux he pour la
qualification il était très bien par
après il a un peu ralenti en faisant
quelques nuls après avoir fait de sur de
démarrage mais il a battu j B à la rond
5 et
donc que jumabayef mais il a eu des
appariments quand même très
cléments très Arnaud cléments ces
apparimentss ouais ou il il fait son
bonhomme de chemin oui il a apparment
très très clément en tout cas s'il gagne
là évidment il se met
bien et puis après on passe dans le
groupe de point en dessous il y a
d'autres parties il a Ker kobov qui joue
il y a
deiokubofokubf qui c'est lui he qui a
gagné l' P du Qatar non ouais je crois
ouais donc en forme en forme qui est
dans le groupe des poursuivants il y a
un czubof
artemief des joueurs solides
technique Fed CF contre le
[Musique]
joueur
kazak la surprise du
tournoi qui s'accroche pas mal pas une
mauvaise position et et après on passe
dans le groupe encore en dessous là les
joueurs à juste plus un plus ou moins
les les battus qui doivent absolument
gagner aujourd'hui Guer qui apprre an
ciraro rapport contre Bartel voilà il
jou vraiment leur dernier
bateau un ronion avec les Noirs mais bon
je pense qu'il conteste rien enfin il
comptait pas trop se qualifier il est
juste là comme ça Douda qu' met le
coumant pareil faut faut faire le point
aujourd'hui il joue une partie
intéressante au demeurant quand je vois
la position comme ça je me dis he
position elle joue il envoie quoi il est
là il envoie donc voilà un peu ce qui se
passe à droite à
gauche intéressant tout ça F
intéressant Maxime qui je roi H8
HM cache le
roi s'enlève de cette diagonale vis-àis
avec la dame adverse quiêtre un dame pr
chaque un
jour ser intéressant si on p avoir GCH
pranda et rig candidat les trois joueurs
indiens représentant du Gange ouais
pourrait peut-être s'arranger entre eux
pour
ouais mais je crois qu'il joue plutôt
quand il s'affronte mais ouais
mais c'est beau quoi non mais l' l' de
nation nation forte des échecsin tu don
les quatre points à Prague quoi allez
débrouille-toi serait beau comme
strat gche qui a l'air dessus un petit
peu récemment un peu plus dur que
pendant une période ouais alors après on
m'a dit GH était quand même nettement
moins bon en
blitz finent pas étonnant qu'on trouve
des points faibles aussi en longue
euh après ouais Monon PRAG qui fait pas
un gros tournoi ici mais je crois il
fait que des nuls non que tu bouges pas
trop ouais toute façon pourquoi il joue
enin juste parce que en fait il y avait
une règle hein c'est que tu devais
t'inscrire à l'avance et tuavais pas de
te désinscrire à ce
tournoi donc en fait même si tu t'es
qualifier la Coupe du monde ça n'a plus
aucun sens de jouer ce tour pour carwana
pour pragou quo par que Jul je crois
qu'il a réussi à se désinscrire mais
comment il a fait je sais pas bravo quoi
mais je sais pas fa lui demander mais il
était à un moment donné et puis
finalement il joue pas donc peut-être
qu'il a réussi quoi
ouais mais bon pourquoi les autres sont
pas desincrits alors qu'il veulent jouer
enfin c'est même pas pourquoi peut-être
qu'ils savent pas eux-mêmees hein et euh
mais moi je désinscriraai de force en
fait tu déjà qualifié tu as rien à faire
là c'est juste un tournoi pour se
qualifier quoi donc ah moi aussi ouais
même si tu as envie de jouer en fait moi
je te dis non et puis c'est
tout mais j je sais pas si c inscrit
j'avais l'impression qu'il était inscrit
mais peut-être je me trompe
hein et
euh et je sais pas peut-être tu as
raison j'en sais rien enfin j'ai pas
trop porter intérêt qui était qui qui
comptait jouer ou pas
euh tu auras C1
ok c'est pas si simple de se
réorganiser le KG6 je l'aime pas mais en
même temps j'ai pas envie de voir un F4
arrivé donc il est au marquage quoi
euho qui n dit ben pour le plaisir de
jouer ce qui aim les parti long gagner
de l'élo je sais pas des raisons autres
que la calife ouais oui mais non enfin
en fait il y a plein d'Open même des trs
fermés qui pourrai faire se faire
inviter il y a pas de problème ils font
ce qu'ils veulent catar par exemple qui
vientnent de se terminer à l'instant
voilà ça c'est très bien sils ont envie
de jouer qu' jouent he je veux pas les
empêcher mais là en fait un tournoi
qualificatif pour les candidats était
déjà qualifié et en fait ta simple
présence ici va influencer le tournoi
c'està dire que tu vas gagner des
parties tu vas en perdre tu vas
peut-être finir dans les deux premiers
et du coup le troisème va être qualifié
alors que c'était pas censé le cas c'est
pas le tour est pas fait pour ça et donc
tu as pas venir influencer le tournoi
mais j'avais le même discours si vous
souvenez la Coupe du Monde Carls pour
moi rien à faire là mais ninepo qui est
déjà qualifié au candidat euh et
euh et voilà en fait donc c'est t
qualificatif il doit être fait pour les
joueurs qui veulent se qualifier et qui
qui peuvent encore se qualifier voilà
ceux qui sont déjà qualifiés bah bah
c'est bien faites autre chose
quoi donc il a joué H4
ok donc il eu le même constat ce G6
était mal placé mais donc moi j'avis un
peu peur de voir débarquer l'autre F4
par échange mais qu'est-ce qu' ah en ok
donc là pour l'instant effidemment c'est
pas le moment et on mettrait le fou on
touche la tour a pas tout de suite
H4 t C5 ou je sais pas
quoi touche encore cette tour peutêtre
H5 qui va clouer ou 5 très bien et puis
petit à petit on va se mettre en place
avec le fond C6 et taper la grande
diagonale donc ça ça serait un
beau un
beau un beau setup un beau scénario
évidemment les blancs sont peut-être pas
obligé de jouer comme ça déjà on n pas
obligé de prendre H4 on pe peut-être
déplacer ce qu' de F3 peut-être le
protéger avec l'autre en D4
aussi pour rir attz pas sur les
qualifications moi je serais pas contre
que les joueurs déjà qualifiés jouent
déjà joue quand même mais au cas où du
coup leur qualification est ah tu la
rems en jeu ah je la remets en jeu ouais
c'est que tu tu n'es plus qualifié
oui onève ta place on dit bon bah du
coup il y a là forceie il y a pragonda
et Carona qui joue bah du coup il y a
quatre places qualificatives tu je
t'interdirais pas de jouer mais enfin si
tu joues qui péril quoi
ouais comme tu veux quoi enfin il y a
pas de problème et pareil car tu joues
tu es plus champion du monde enfin là il
pas champion du monde mais d tu joues
bah tu es plus champion du monde en fait
tu perds ton titre et puis bah ce sera
les deux premiers des candidats qui qui
je t'interdirais pas de jouer enfin non
mais à ce là oui enfin c'est une sorte
d'interdiction parce que faut être
vraiment sacrément ah tu peuxre Dr pas
très stratège pour faire ça quoi tu as
le droit d'être
complète
alors est-ce que
ça on a malheureusement eu un petit un
petit problème de son est-ce que c'est
j'ai rien fait non non tu as rien
fait c'est bon ça un petit un petit
bug donc je sais pas Parel ça a bloqué
mais globalement non mais ça vit bloquer
ça blo donc on a peu près façon tout ce
qu'on voulait
tac tac tac ouis bon ça joute partout C3
pour ala pourquoi pas ça fait partie des
multiples coup ça pe préparer du B4
j'aime bien ouais tu peux reculer F
c2tir B3 un jour mettre une pression de
ce côté ou pas enfin bon tu dones des
options pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas moi c'est
B qui commence un poil à m'inquiéter là
il se met quand même relativement mal au
temps face à yongi ça ça pourrait coûter
cher il faut quand même faire attention
là et
jouer
ouais c'est dommage d'avoir t ce
F4 et peut-être qu'il est temps de bah
de viser la lune la nulle maintenant et
euh et puis c'est tout quoi
ok oui ce serait pas une mauvaise idée
peut-être il a trouvé le C5 caroana ça
continue à jouer et Naka mine de rien
leur dit s'inquiète mais je veux
bien
j'aime pas moi j'aime pas les blan
attention pour
Naka bon on n'est pas contre une défaite
ou dem Meurant tout ce qu'on a expliqué
hein ouais puis une autre oui bah déjà
une mais ouais
commencer par une défaite ouais ça
serait pas mal et là ce serait ikaro qui
deviendrait peut-être supporter d'aliza
faut qu'il gagne à fond est-ce que
ikarou rejoue quelque chose lui de son
côté et je crois pas alors peut-être il
va aller se faire un petit tournoi à
Vegas el quelque part avant le 1er
janvier pour se gagner des points s sans
menacer après le mieux serait d'aller
jouer un tourno fermé en Hongrie
est très bien ouais tu as jouer un petit
fermé en Hongrie oui tour norme de grand
M je
viens plus 10 points l'
quoifin il serait très bien tu vas ouais
tu vas tu vas tous les Hongrois à 2450
tu fais 9 sur 9 tu en fais TR d'affilé
tu joues même en double ronde tu men
fous de deux victoires par jour là
regarde tu viens de faire 36 sur 36
moyen à 2005 c'est normal 300 points
plus bon 28
15 ce serait
beau sur mvl sont adversaire à plus de
temps bah on verra après comme on le
disait mvl c'est quand même très loin
encore oui oui même en gagnant
aujour'huime gagant aujourd'hui c'est
pas trs bien on espère qu'il gagne
évidemment mais là c'est c'est plutôt
Baky Alireza aujourd'hui quand même
l'actualité
mais on espère que Maxime va gagner s'il
gagne il garde un petit shot il faut
qu'il gagne tout pour avoir une chance
gagne une qui regagne deains au blanc il
en gagne de tout d'un coup il redouble
il en gagne TR il gag 4 et pu la
dernière en gagne 5 qu voilà pu qualifié
candidat qualif et puis on est là les
Français au
candidat au nombre de
de français TR
indiens une
allianceanindien tu donnes tous les
points à
pr serait
beau juste rés un poil même pas fait sur
il y a quoi
14 pas qualifié mais bon faire sur cont
les
aut VO tu rachètes des parties contre un
gars pour vraiment être sûr comme ça tu
es à
10 pr
praging tu
payçon il ve plus jouer a 14 r tu pay
parties tu passes devant
80 il faut prendre des 4 prend des 4 il
B5 sens là
d'accord
ok donc en fait sur BC il veut faire
fprendre et BC
j'imagine même
pas alors ça faudrait comprendre que
c'est gros avantage
noir en fait je crois qu'il y a tour B4
qui arrive mais ouais ouais non mais
c'est pas c'est pas forcé de le voir de
loin
quoi mais alors du coup parce que du
coup si on veut pas ça en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on veut est-ce qu'on veut fouser si
par
que ils veulent bacer bisser CAH C5 CAH
C5 dame pr ça c'est ce qu'on voulait pas
partir enfin ça moi je pensais que ça
c'était mieux au noir
ouis non mais pas pas beaucoup mieux au
noir mais tu vas mettre une tour C3 bah
tu vas faire chier ouais c'est attention
pour bcky ça peut devenir dangereux on
va Voirin là c'est une partie importante
évidemment bcky avec une hule qui
conserve quelques petites chances
défaite par contre à mon avis ce non il
y en a plus en cas de défaite défaite de
trop Maxime son adversaire quand même
très mal au temps qui est en train de
prendre les devant les devants il va
faire F7 gagner une qualité il l' fait
il l'a fait bon c'était le la suite
logique prend et sur pr F3 prends8
ouais tu prends
tout sera de Tours contre TR pièces et
beaucoup de colonnes et je sais pas et
sur tour F8 cavalier G5 E3 peêtre pas si
clair
encore
G5 je sais pas on
verraana ça l'air d'aller mais on va pas
se perdre sur trop de
partiesir la
tenir jou assez vite en
fait un joue auquel je fais confiance
pour se sauver
c'est mais en plus ça il peut
gagner mais il peut tout faire en fait
il carou là genre tu vois F5 c'est
logique tu peux pas per F4 il va te
prendre B7 bon ben tu te fais attaquer
un peu partout il y a activité noir ou
quoi mais il va défendre et puis il va
faire à 4 à 5 sué à 6 à 7 à 8 ça va vite
quoi donc attention
quoi firou sur C3 il y a eu A5 il veut
pas du tout laisser l'installation
peut-être qu' veut FO 6 aussi h ou pas
mais je ça fait une idée quoi OK et B
qui B qui s pas jouer Maxime il reste
plus 4 minutes à guyen quand même c'est
pas beaucoup
he en
D4
catastrophique pour de multipl raisons
oui mais en fait oui j'ai compris dame
B7 tu menaces mat en un coup F 5 3 ça
Maxim il peut le voir en une micrconde
alors attention il y a peut-être une
idée de contrer en
E6 des PR3 en plus
non
ah a F
F7 bon ben ça peut juste être terminé
très vite ça peut ça peut ça peut coûter
cher bon conseil de cliquer vite c'est
conseil
mais SK mais j'is conseillé avant la
partie qu' a gagné là la dernière j'ai
déjà conseillé avant la partie contre S
mais il a quand même réfléchi de
fou c'était mon mon
conseil depuis longtemps après contre
Sarich il a pas pu le faire il a une
mauvaise position mais les deux d'après
il a clic il a clic et puis c'est
important quand même pour le ho quoi
qu'il en soit Maxime de pas sombrer
vous voyez ça faire une victoire à 2630
une victoire à 2618 mine de rien ça fait
toujours 6 5 si points de récupérer
h allez c'est toujours
ça ici ça joue pas on va rester à lireza
Baki bakierza ikarou
le trio
d'or coach Kevin de façon je un coach
facile V bien puis voilà bien on s'en
fout ou
[Musique]
bien bah le truc vraiment c'est que si
tu arrives pas vraiment à réfléchir que
tu es pas en forme en
fait je pense que Maxime en blitz genre
son niveau on va dire tu lui mets 10
minutes à la pendule ça va être au moins
26 30 ou6 6 40 ouais donc en soit il
joue contre un mec tu a son niveau qui a
son niveau en rapide sauf que le mec qui
a 26 18 si tu lui joues tout tempo et
que tu le mets sous pression et que bah
ça peut suffire quoi après c'est très
dangereux parce que tu peux gaffer mais
c'est mieux ça que de se faire des nœud
tout seul dans la
tête si les conseils de faes c'est
toujours les conseils quoi après
deuxième conseil c'est d'arrêter le
tournoi enfin oui bon mais ça aussi c en
fait tant que tu as une chance pourquoi
pas puis si tu en as plus barre-toi
quoi bah autre conseil c'est joue que
pour l'argent
quoi non mais quand j'étais coach
l'équipe de France je conseille pas trop
sur ça je faisais plus du travail de
préparation mais je vais le refaire
cette année d'ailleurs
tiens dans dans 10 jours dans 10 jours
Championnat d'Europe des nations
di est déjà millionnaire ouais mais
bon même si tu as 1 million quoi c'est
pas énorme hein bah tu es content mais
tu te dis bah pourquoi pas deux quo
pourquoi pas de
ouais c'est dansine powerers pourquoi
vouloir des milliards quand on peut
avoir des millions je sais plus très
heureux
ou puis tu dis pas non à 2 millions puis
3 puis 4 hein
ah mais n'empêche 1 million c'est beau
attention hein mais
euh enin tu vas pas vivre de 35 jusqu'à
jusqu'à 90 ans euh faud peut-être
travailler un peu à côté ouais c'est ça
donc autant jouer pour la Cillas tant
que la cillass peut tomber quoi
oui mais surtout qu'une carrière est pas
éternelle moment
bon soit
par manque de ou toute façon le
cerveau tourne moins vite à un moment et
puis puis puis puis voilà tu on dit à
partir de 5 millions tu commences à être
très très bien mais bon si tu as déjà 5
pourquoi pas
6 à un moment donné si Magnus allait
jouer le tournoi au qatarou c'est parce
que 25 ou 30 millions ça doit pas
suffire he il en
faut mais euh bah il carou pareil hein
bah disons moi je serais très d'en avoir
un mais ou mais put déjà 50 là tu dis
bon ça fera peut-être 51
enfin après tu compes pe-être par
tranche de 5 ouais tu es plus un près
entre 50 51 million à peu près 55
millions
6lion
maybeon
ou Magnus est multi ou c'est sûr 1
million c'est grosse retraite tu fais
une vie tranquille en faisant pas
n'importe quoi je pense pas pas en
France en tout cas en France 1 million
tu vas si tu fais plus rien tu vas être
short je sais pas combien tu dépense si
tu es chez toi tu payes un loyer ton
train de VI admettant million tout
compris avec ton capital immobilier et
tout je pense que tuares tu peux pas
t'arrêter de travailler à vie à 35
ans je pense pas tu vas être short
bah je sais pas ça déjà avec l'inflation
t t tous les 10 ans tu perds
300000 tu per 30ou 40 % de ton truc au
bout de 40 ans il te reste plus enfin
même sans les dépenser il te reste plus
rien en
fait non non je pense qu'il faut mieux
viser plus
hein viser la
lune ça lui fait pas peur les dam B7
c'est facile ouais c'est pas très dur en
fait enfin tu calcules d B7 tu dis tiens
je fais une menace il fait F3 bon de
toute façon tu es toujours content de
provquer une fablesse vers le roi G5 tu
attaques une tour F3 tu fais une double
attaque et puis puis tu bouffes le
cavalier donc c'est menace menace menace
quoi
is c'est
dur
là c'est bon tout le monde calcule là
dans le chat mais peut-être que tu es
assez bien non mais pas l'inflation en
fait il oubl parce qu'il dit ça te fait
2000 € par mois pendant 50 ans ce qui
est vrai mais dans 30 ans 2000 € ser
sera l'équivalent de 500 € quoi et du
coup ser s'il y avait pas d'inflation
ouais mais avec l'inflation et puis il
disent à 4 % ça fait 40000 par an ouais
mais sauf que tu as 30 % d'impôt donc ça
fait que 28000 en fait c'est vrai que si
tu enlèves les impôts et l'inflation là
tu es très bien mais si tu as l'impôt je
pense qu'avec les impôts et l'inflation
tu peux pas ça je pense que même deux tu
peux pas en fait avec impôt et inflation
non je pense que l'inflation les impôts
te font trop mal je pense que tris tu
peux et tu fais plus rien plus un
centime à côté tu veux dire juste tu vis
avec ça avec ça ouais mais je pense que
même 2 à 35 ans tu es un poil
juste
2 % de moyenne ça fait d'inflation mais
l'inflation elle est pas 2 % elle est
beaucoup plus
ha ou 10% c'est l'objectif de la BCE 2%
mais en fait l'objectif est pas du tout
tenu là il va pas être avant un bon
moment parce que investis ça compense
l'inflation et mais investis dans quoi
pour compenser l'inflation si tu as un
tuyau pour faire 8 % par an frérot nous
app tout le chat ser très heure de
savoir
ou non je pense pas puis en plus sur ce
que tu gagnes dans tes plçons tu repayes
des impôts donc plutôt faire 11 ou 12 %
quoi non ça me paraît difficile après si
tuas un tuo pour faire 11 % par an
frérot tu m'appelles on est milliardaire
dans 6 mois je pense on est
milliardaire mais qui a pris la qualité
quelle qualité on parle je pense
c'est Al il s'est passé des choses
effectivement s'est passé AB fou des7 7
k prend B6 d bouge k prend8
ok euh du coup je m'attendais pas du
tout à ce scénario
euh c'est quoi le
matériel tuas une qualité impion de plus
enfin tu as une tour impion de plus mais
bon le qu 8 va va se faire va se faire
dégommer h c'est compqué tout d'un coup
l'pposition ouais c'est le bordel
ouais c'est le bordel c'est chaud mais
en fait yangi prend tous les risques
hein donc B qui peut quand même contr
contrer il peut perdre il peut gagner h
HM parce que je pense que yangi veut
vraiment tout donner
quoi ce qui est intéressant c'est que
dame Fran C 5 c'est une gaffe alors que
c'est le coup que j'aurais fait à cause
de cavalier E8 tour E8 tour C1 ouais
mais ça tu peux rater hein le coup est
ouf quoi et tu fais C C7 et t'échang
ouais et tu es complètement gagnant donc
en réalité dame prend C5 cavalier 8
vraiment ça se rate hein bah oui CAV 8
qu'est-ce qu'il me fait comme coup dak
peut avoir une réussite de fou
furieux après est-ce que il y a un autre
coup pour les blancs genre tourc ind
direct c'est ce que tu regardes d'
prendre des 6 qui 7 F pr ouis tu es
tenté de faire ça en fait ça tu es
content tuasbas fandé tu as bouffé de
CIS tu peux vraiment avoir un un coup de
bol incroyable pour les blancs après
faut encore avir qu'elle vite mais bon
tu peux toi tu peux l'avoir ouais
et nak en
sueur non pas du tout enfin en semiueeur
enfin depuis tout à l'heure mais oui
mais ça genre ça pas il a ça a pas
évolué non non pas qu' c'est pour que tu
puisses faire k C7 en gagnant un temps
bon bon tu peux montrer comme ça il
ouais
ouaisza ça continue en fait dame prend
C5 tu as les deux cavaliers attaquer de
toute façon tu vas pas sauver les deux
donc tu vas te les faire bouffer le 8 tu
as pas de case de fite et en fait en
faisant qu' 8 donc tutires la tour
dessus de toute façon voilà tu fais t un
attaque la dame elle doit dégager et
cavalier attaque la tour et le fou donc
en fait tu vas bouffer le fou et tu
enlèves un des gros arguments des Noirs
qui était d'avoir la paire de fou et ce
fou qui bouffer à deux là tu aurais une
qualité entière d'avance alors faudrait
encore gagner les noir il veulent faire
des TR C3 te faire chier mais bon tu
quand même mieux quoi avec les Blancs je
veux dire c'est voilà il y a qu'un camp
qui joue vraiment c'est les blanc là
donc ça peut ça peut être le scénario on
nous a dit Maxime qui a trouvé on a pas
le coup alors mais ça se peut qu'il est
joué que un tout petit peu avant
nous oh c'est pas étnant je pense qu'il
va l'avoir Maxim en tout
cas mais tu vois c'est en fait c'est
loin d'être
Simpleo qui se
bat
je pas sûr qu'il jouer Maxime non moi
non plus mais ça joue bien à côté ala
aussi c'est dommage parce là il
réfléchit alors faud juste qu' joue
quo je pense que yangi peut se planter
oui il
peut cavali 8 ça te rend fou je
crois mais bon s'il le VO
g c'est hyper
compliqué et marquant c'est qu'on a pas
du tout regardé après ça qu'on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup à faire
je le haut du tableau table on peut par
qu'on dit qu'il est gagnant donc doit
être assez bas il 2 et dem ouais il doit
dans les dans les fin fond après avoir
fait un gros début de tournoi jou contre
santoa
euh bon gagance un grand mot mais il est
beaucoup mieux
ouais après la position se compliqué
hein très
compliqué il y a plein de coups
importants là je
crois sur les parties des Français ouais
parce que genre firou Monon bon firou
c'est pas ouis mais tu sens que ça va
devenir crucialit là tu B c'est ce que
je disais revenez à 19h je m'étais pas
je m'étais pas
trompé daky là c'est vraiment crucial et
Maxime c'est crucial il fait fou c'est
bien aussi tu attaques la tour et tu
veux c'est la même en
fait simplement ça enlève peut-être un
peu de cavalier prend6 il y a peut-être
plus de fou F7 et tu t'embêtes pas avec
des k prend des 8 qui te rattaque la
dame gen de
truc donc c'est très bien il est il est
dans le bon
is puis il y a plus énormément de temps
côté non mais je pense Maxime dans moins
d' demi-heure la partie est finie il est
gagné même beaucoup moins dans 10
minutes par que l'autre il a plus que 3
minutes il va se suer
il a encore 15 quouer dans 2 3 minutes
il aura plus de temps et puis
voilà il va exploser en
Voen fou 5 ça va faire suer quand
même
mais il a complètement raté dame B7 en
fait le le
nuien peut-être qu'il croyait de loin
faire F4 ou enfin de loin il av qu' voir
le coup d'avant c'est lui qui est parti
de F3 avec son cavalier quand même
maison en tout cas là on va vite avoir
un coup puisqu'il est complètement
bloqué par le in oui oui bah ou alors il
va tomber et puis voilà
mais
ouais plus 2 minutes quand tu une
demi-heure ça pourrait même durer non
non mais 10 minutes 10 minutes
ouais dit que la tempête est là euh
ouais ouais mais j'ai vu C tempête qui
arrive par l'Ouest c'est ça
ouais bah du coup si vous pouvez rester
chez vous peut-être
mieux mais les avions étaient très
heureux oui il battent des records de
vitesse traversé
transatlantique du côté USA France jou
et il a joué d'ame Fran C 5 alors K8
peut-être bon mais c'est loin d'être
enin moi je pense qu'il va l'avoir
cavalie 8 c'est un coup de marlou
c'est un gros coup de Marl all vite tu
peux l'avoir quand même ah mais tu peux
tu passes mieux tu seras beaucoup mieux
quand même bah c'est qu'on regarde en
tout cas c'est toi qui joue le gain
c'est plus du tout les
Noirs il l'a raté il a fait 5 a a a bon
pour nous c'est facile avec l'ordi mais
je veux dire c'était possible quoi C
cétait trouvable ou C
maximesque
allez on va rester sur Maxime ala il a
eu cavalier H5 et il peut tomber dans 35
secondes ça serait très vite réglé cette
histoire mais ben en fait il va
peut-être même abandonner ou tomber hein
enfin si'il dit ouais bon il y a dame B7
faut 3 je per une pièce ça fait dame
prend 6 resign hein
euh
d'accord tempo menace g de Matth
continueer d'attaquer la tour C1 F3
minimum prc1 déjà et
euh et le turbinette propose encore
mieux avec dam à 7 mais
[Musique]
euh je crois qu'il y a tout qui gagne
là est-ce qu'on peut pas même fou
ça quand même l'air pas mal oui une
pièce de plus quoi ouais donc en fait ça
fait déjà beaucoup de coup sympa quoi là
c'est une question de choix Maxime qui
va
l'emporter qui d'après la turbine prend
un petit avantage maintenant c'est vrai
que le cavalier en H5 est moins bien
placé ça peut-être Mar cette situation
vouit clarifier les choses donc il a
fait5 provoquant l'éch donc il voulait
mais en tout cas c mal placé pour
revenir en jeu mais bon je rappelle dans
livre de kotof il avait dit le grand
maître c'est celui qui r la tension le
plus
tard quel part le coup pour pour forcer
à rompre la
tension le grand matre il fait
[Musique]
pas il te laisse c'est toi qui va faire
le qui va donner le tempo en premier
aoved donc là prend 5 qui veut cavalier
le 4 il s'en va après il va perdre
l'autre en V du
coup ça joue ça reste hyper
compliqué évidemment si on pouvait
enlever cette paire de fou au noir on
aurait été content donc c'est une moins
bonne version que ce qu'on avait
vu
de
OK
c'est quoi ça marquant mais bon pas tout
voir ikarou comme tu disais leur dit il
va recommencer à ikarou parce que
position est trop compliqué pour pour
battre un
tel il peut gagner mais bon non mais a
de une partie caresque il fait ce qu'il
a de pas facile même c'est PASC
expliquer en fait ce qu'il fait fait
c'est que du calcul que du calcul donc
c'est ordinateurque et compagnie je dire
la partie que j'avais bien aimé de Douda
l'autre jour il y a tout un truc fond de
jeu domination cach le roi machin de
qualité enfin tout est explicable juste
avec des mots je trouve toujours les
parties comme ça plus belles et plus
instructives mais cas où en terme de
calcul c'est incroyable ce qu'il fait
enfin probblement le meilleur
calculateur quoi et
euh mais du coup il y a pas grand chose
à retenir quoi pour s'autoaméliorer
soi-même quand tu regardes tu as pas de
concept tu as pas tu as just
c'est c'est très efficace
mais c'est comm un ordinateur très fort
mais je peux pas en dire grand chose
quoi tu vois très faible plutôt mais
c'est plus comme ça gen genus 3
quoi Fritz
4 non en C8 ouais et peut-être juste
dame D7 propose l'échange des
dames et puis Ben qui va êre plus fin
quoi ça devrait abandonner dans côté
ouais alors il va peut-être cliquer des
coups par inertie jusqu'au contrôle de
temps puis se dire ouais en fait c'est
trop pourri
j'abandonne mais attention un ordinateur
très faible c'est déjà très fort quoi B
oui parce que les ordis forts ils sont
genre à 3600 je sais pas où ils en sont
maintenant donc un ordinateur faible
c'est genre 2008
quoi imagine un tel joue que à 2800
ho je t'annonce que la partie de firouja
va durer oui oui oui bon ça c'était
prévu
hein non c'est genre un iPhone 5
quoi bon Maxime à mon avis ça va signé
incessemment d'une minute à
l'autre et bah qui en est où bah il a
joué eu 5 là ça réfléchit en face
complexe toutes ces positions mes
amis en tout cas Maxime ça va faire le
Punto il va repasser il va passer même
pour la première fois du tournoi en
positif oui donc bah déjà c'est bien ça
fait du bien au moral et il garde sa
microochance
elle qui est un peu plus grande du coup
maintenant il reste pas
grande on va passer sur du on éit à
0,1 on va passer à
0,5 fait FO 5 quoi quand même c'est pu
si regagne devant va passer à 2 3 % 2 3
% 1 % peut-être s regagne on passera à 5
et puis puis puis la petite bête qui
monte qui monte qui
monte peut revenir de
l'arrière moi jeaurais bien rester
jusqu'à la jusqu'à la signature de la
partie de Maxime puis puis j'aurais fait
la petite pause avant les avant les
not Maxime qui peut regretter hein son
début de tournoi en j'ai même pas envie
de dire en D si hein puis que la D s
elle était vers le bas ouais il avait
pas de dents en fait il y avit pas de d
ouais cétait juste une s plate quoi
mais pentu vers le bas
quoi une C denté
exactement G6 il va remettre cavalier
en7 fou
F7 F7 ça a l'air de bien fermer quand
même reprend cavalier prend et puis
voilà bon après ça
abandonne je pas demande si jeis faire
des vacances en Turquie euh non c'est
pas prévu j'y suis jamais aller en plus
mais je veux dire non non j'ai pas j'ai
pas vraent envie d'aller là-bas en ce
moment et on nous demande on dit que
Maxime aurait joué contre d'autres
joueurs s'il avait gagné non mais ça
c'est sûr mais tu vois bien que làin au
début c'était vraiment dur là il gagne
deux parties contre contre des joueurs
plus faibles mais
ah tu sais que sil avait été au même
niveau que en championnat d'Europe ou
euh dans les tourins qu'il avait joué
avant ça aurait été toi tu autre chose
c'est pas dire que tu fin de premiers
hein c'est dur il faut une part de
réussite ou quoi mais
euh c'est un joueur qui serait censé par
son niveau de jeu être en course pour
quoi
pour les cheveux non cheveux bon j'en ai
pas et ça fait longtemps que je le sais
je compte pas changer grand-chose à ce
sujet
quoi ok Naka il faut prendre
[Musique]
B2 ça va jouer mais après l'avantage il
est quand même minime oui non il n pas
tellement mais après bah tu joues
longtemps peut-être ça va craquer en
face ou pas F3 tu r ton puis A3 B4 tu
reprends C en
C5 dur quand
même qui a joué cavalier 4 c'est la
ligne qu'on
avait il va l'enlever il va C à 8 il un
P pour la qualité la de fou ce qui donne
de vraies compensations au noir position
pas
claire mais euh S c'est plus lu qui va
jouer pour quelque
chose que d'entraîner SSE un jour ouais
Football Manager ais en vrai euh je
pense qu'il me manque quelques petites
compétences
quoi est-ce que tu penses voir de ton
vivant la SSE gagner la Ligue des
Champions non et championnat et la Ligue
1 je peux pas dire je pense mais déjà
pourquoi pas quoi
enfin la Ligue 1 tu
crois bah c'est même pas que j'y crois
mais en fait quand on jouait pas mal bon
il y a 10 ans enfin on finissait 4e 5e
par là et franchement il y aurait pas eu
le
PSG version Qatar qui toute façon TR
rest le titre et tu peux rien
faire tu peux quoi en fait donc s'il y a
un scénario qui se passe comme
ça qui sait mais tu vois ça fait
beaucoup deess donc en fait j'y crois
pas mais tu peux tu vois tu regardes
lance ils ont t pas été champions mais
je resté en Ligue 2 il y a pas si
longtemps ils ont bien travaillé ils
sont remonté ils ont fait second l'an
dernier donc c'est pas impossible quoi
voilà on va dire ça comme
ça Mo je préfère suivre la SS
hein et non mais là cette année benah
écoute c'est pas fait que ça monte
encore en Ligue 1 pour autant mais euh
évidemment bah là on est en course donc
ça change gravement de l'an dernier où
c'était ridicule
euh il y a un point for C année c'est
que l'équipe sait défendre donc euh ça
fait un point fort l' dernier il y avait
une attaque un but donc bon c'était
chiant là bon voilà c'est pas flamboyant
mais il y a un état d'esprit les joueurs
se battent ENF tu vois ça peut suffire
pour la Ligue 2 hein de jouer de cette
manière donc bah écoute hein on verra
bon Maxime qui va jouer F H5 tour D8 et
là je pense que ça va vraiment abandonné
côté enguyen HM
oui bah ça va regagner une pièce ouais
c'est quoi ça c'est ça c'est
carwana Mo qui doit tenir mais ça reste
depuis tout à l'heure un petit quelque
chose tout le temps
ouais cas ça va faire nul en fait
ouais bah ok mais prê de que il s'est
pas pris pour un autre et il
[Musique]
a les Reza ça va jouer longtemps pas mal
tour 3 j'aime bien dans le sens tu peux
les verg 3 tu peux aller faire des trucs
à droite à gauche gagne il carou
nul ça peut recoller
quoi est-ce que j'ai d'autres clubs que
j'aime bien non en fait je n'aime aucun
autre club Bordeaux ou
Lyon ou Greno grenable
ouaisen Lyon et Saint-Étienne non mais
il y a des clubs pour je pe un peu plus
de sympathie d'autres mais euh tu aimes
bien lance non non mais lance j'aime
bien mais en fait enfin je m'en fiche
aussi enfin je sais pas comment dire
après il y a lance qui joue jeisêtre
plutôt pour qu'il gagne mais s'il gagn
pasuss il perd tu vois ça va pas me
faire ni chaud ni froid quoi quelque
part euh il y a que Sainté que pour qui
je me bats et je vibre mais voilà donc
il y a des clubs je bien aimer à
l'étranger comme ça mais ça rien à voir
quoi mais est-ce que tu es pour les club
qui ont des maillots verts ou pas non je
sais que mes potes supporters du
locomotive du coup dès qu'il a un
maillot vert pour tous les clubs qui
avit des maillots verts parce qu'il
disait vert et le sang qui court dans
mes veines C dans mes veines donc dès
qu'il voit un club avec les maillots
verts bon bah ils sont pour eux non ben
ça je peux comprendre c'est mais bon non
enfin a des champion je supporte pas les
Françis bon non je supporte pas enfin à
Laur tu vois je vaisre pour lance mais
Paris j'aime vraiment pas trop he ENF
c'est donc non je ou mais après Paris ça
compte pas personne n'aime bah sauf ceux
qui aiment
mais les autres aim pas il y a aucun
autre qui aime Paris en fait
mais mais non mais lance là j'étais
content de leur parcours c'est bien
d'avoir battu Arsenal ou quoi donc
plutôt pour eux bien sûr ouais je pas
leur souiter de perdre quoi mais comme
je disais tu vois après bah ils perdent
ils perdent dommage pour eux
mais je vais pas chialer
quoi et Max ouais ouais il devrait
gagner
ouais les supporters de l' aiment bien
Paris non mais je crois qu'il y a aucun
aucun supporter de club qui aime Paris
en fait
is je sais pas s'ils ont des alliances
jeis pas peut-être les reen peut-être je
sais pas P reen ils aiment bien
dur à dire enfin faud c'est des gens qui
peuvent dire plus
que que moi
quoi non j'ai jamais vu C en Ligue des
champions alors déjà en fait quand on
était bon ça existait en fait euh
c'était pas sous le format Ligue des
Champions c'était la Coupe d'urope des
clubs
champions et euh mais bon j'étais pas né
en fait
ouais qu'est-ce que je pense du TFC
bah c un club qui faisait vraiment pas
rêver pendant longtemps qui était mal
géré qui qui méritait de descendre et
puis ils sont descendus et puis je sais
pas il y eu un renouveau et franchement
il y avait av un ventre fraîcheur ils
sont montés il jouent bien ils ont gagné
la coupe donc
écoute bon petit club quoi enfin c'est
bien donc là Toulouse bien quoi C
tempsci Marseille je crois que ils sont
moins détestés que Paris ouais ils sont
pas trop aimés non plus en fait mais
c'est clubs clivant mais ouais mais moi
moi je serai plus team om quoi si je
choisir dans les deux mais ça ça
n'engage que moi normal à Sainté ils
aiment pas du tout
Marseille normalement les ST Stephan
vont préférer Paris à Saint à à
Marseille
ouais sonêtement fou quoi non bah disons
Marseille c'était le rival historique
ouais par dans les années 70 c'était
parce que c'était des grands clubs
contrairement à Paris ouais donc en fait
tu bon on déteste Lyon parce que bah
c'est comme ça c'est géographique ouais
et Marseille parce que c'est c'est une
grande équipe
parce que c'était une grande équipe
c'est vrai que à ce niveau c'est normal
du coup Paris c'est un peu bah il exit
pas à l'épo mais vraiment pas en pour le
coup après Paris ouais mais voilà moi ça
c'est un choix perso
quoiou max on attend l'abandon pour
faire notre pause mais bon ça va gagner
enfin non mais oui çaon on attend mais
oui ENF on sait pas pourquoi on attend
mais on attend pour attendre il la
Monaco ouais ça va
enfin un club j'aime bien
enfin que je sens ouais non j'ai pas
envie qu'il arrive ce match de barage
Saint-
lion mais surtout je pense qu'on va le
perdre s'il a lieu quoi donc surtout
peur qu' des stades cassés ou je il y a
pas en Italie un club de je sais pas
quelle division les supporters ont brûlé
le stade ils ont vraiment mis feu tout
le stade a brûlé le club a disparu à
cause de ça je je suis pas mais une
petite ville mais c'était peut-être en
3e division 4e division et ils ont
vraiment enfin ils ont mis feu au stade
le le feu le stade en Lambo en fait ils
ont vraiment plus de terrain et ils
auront jamais l'argent pour reconstruire
quoi en fait ils
ont ils ont détruit le leur club en fait
leur ville quoi
c'est
con je sais pas si c'est en Italie ou
dans un autre pays mais mais il y a eu
ce truc
là
je same pas pourquoi il joue en fait non
mais là je sais pas non plus là il est
arrivé au 40e quoi donc normalement
c'est bon tu reprends tes esprits tu dis
oui bon pourquoi je joue
quoi bon il esppère bouffer des pions
les uns après les
autres mauber j'ai jamais fait le member
mais écoute pourquoi pas là je suis rasé
de très près
mais peut laisser pousser petit à
petit allez Movember ça
part on de faire la pause he parce que
c'est le 40e oui puis il a pas l' décidé
abandonner c'est pas passant de regarder
une position avec un fot plus à
convertir et comme ça on revient pour
pour le à 19h à tout de suite lesis alle
à
tout
[Musique]
he
he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
et oui on est de on est de de retour Fab
il y a peut-être eu une petite avancée
là à l'instant donc bon on a continué le
plan côté aliera avec la tour en G3 il a
bouffé le pion
G5 bon ça s'est activé en face et
çaenvoie du A4 mais on a plus quand même
HM donc
euh c'est déjà quelque chose et euh donc
il est plutôt mieux moi je me questionne
si avant il y avait pas autre chose à
faire pour les n plutôt que perdre ce
pion en G5 tu faire G4 he voilà pour les
changer ou quoi bon peut bon ce sera ça
on est de l'analyser ce soir pour la
vidéo mais en tout cas c'est une
décision euh qui pourrait être tour de
conséquences he pour Sarana ouais c'est
ok il s'active mais euh bon je sais pas
trop donc a priori l'ordi aime bien
prendre en des5 mais je sais pas si on
est obligé de le faire c'est sûr qu'on
est pas obligé on est obligé de rien
mais alors côté Baky on va on va faire
les choses dans l'ordre
je pense ça va faire nul hein ouais a de
bonne chance c'est pas un mauvais
résultat mais après au vu de la partie
on on a on était en droit d'espérer
mieux à un moment donné ouais maintenant
s'il reste quand même en course encore
oui oui oui non ben évidemment si on
parle que Maxime peut encore rêver avec
plus 1 et qui a plus 2 peut aussi hein
mais mais oui bon benah voilà victoire
bonne victoire de Maxime gariga ici
tiens on repasse voir c'est toujours
chaud c'est très chaud même très
compliqué très complexe
VO ça pourra mettre peut-être petite
pression mais c'est pas sûr alors qu'on
voit qu'era a joue un coup complètement
à côté marquant ça se passe très
bien
ouais ça devrait faire nul mais il
essaye un peu H4 l'ordi aime pas il aime
pas mais je sais pas enfin je sais pas à
quel point on do faire confiance je sais
pas que Ctait prend je sa pas pour si
content de ce tu voulais faire ça ça et
ça
ouais inité à prendre et jouer avec le
fou peêre B5 ou quoi quand même de pions
plus puis F6 tu peux pas tu MOS bien con
F6 mais non ouais ok donc H4 il
pas mais bon c'est loin d'être fait
parce qu'il veut quand même peut-être
jouer G4 H5 valoriser son pion de plus
là moi je prendrai les blancs bah oui on
prend tous les blancs va dire que
l'avantage à 022 il me paraît quand même
très léger par rapport à la
position plus net quand même he il veut
quoi alors il veut
A3 s qu' a D3
ouais
c'est pour ça que c'est5 tomber mais
alors c'est quoi ce
truc bon mais enfin je comprends pas ah
l'autre ouais l'autre pardon il va faire
tour des deux tour
ok que ça ce soit pas simple j'entends
mais
bon mais bon est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer
tour 2 de prendre 5 aussi ou non mais ok
il est mieux il est mieux
m il est mieux il est
mieux on va voir ça ça peut se décider P
ce
not par que là il reste quand Mme une
dizaine de cou à jouer et je pense que
en 10 coup il peut vraiment s'en passer
des choses ici il vaen passer il on 10
coup il fait déjà cétait pas trop ce que
disait mais c'est plus logique au dem
mais on voit que l'idée de l'ORD Leir un
contrejeu long terme SUR2
la turbinette encore une fois
je crois pas que pr que va imploser non
il il va défendre après sera pas une
mauvaise nouvelle s'los non non ça peut
mais on serait même pas mécontent non me
content de
rien son 31e coup
ici
je P que d à ce que fait en fait
ou5 moi j'arrêterai de regarder après CD
en fait ENF je veris ça ça ça ça et
ça en fait je veux dire que j'irais pas
plus loin en
fait ok mais il a des coups de ouais
enfin juste en faut aller plus loin é es
obligé de le faire d'ailleurs des qu et
mais bon après de bien juger ça ouisess
B ça passe parce que bon Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam enfin ou échec mais c'est autant prè
tuas un pion ouais pour moi il va la
gagner àa ou en tout cas il a les
chances tout cas il va tout faire pour
ouais pourquoi ça B je sais pas
justement al soit il a bien calculé des
trucs ù il sent qu'il a le contrejeu
pour arriver à annuler mais c'est
étonnant d' donner G5 aussi facil enfin
sans faire aucun effort de défendre ou
de mais bon il l'a fait il l'a fait il
l'a fait il l'a fait comme tu dis les
Baki cette partie n nous réserve
peut-être encore des surprises que je
pense que yuyangi va tout donner pour
essayer de la gagner hein pour lui c'est
une chance en or ici ouais alors
attention à la penduile pour il y a 15
coup à jouer il y a 2
minutes et autant pour l'instant ça va
mais je veux dire les pions peuvent
avancer et le jour où ils
avanceent pr je m'attends ce qu'il
prenne de la
dame
parce que ces pions passés on va dire
c'est des forces en finale c'est des
forces tout le temps mais en final ils
vontêtre d'autant plus dangereux et s'il
prend du pion en fait son problème c'est
qu'il aura plutôt un roi faible et B qui
pourra peut-être rentrer avec sa tour
après C6 attaquer le pion puis dame4
puis
s'infiltrer moi moi j'allais dire il
fait peut-être le calcul inverse c'est
qu'il est moins bien mais qu' veut
absolument gagner parce que lui il
estangi de son point de vue il est que à
4 sur 6 non mais je comprends qu'il veut
gagner il a besoin de gagner il prend
tous les risques fa pour moi faire pas
renoncer à l'espoir de gagner mais c'est
peut-être la chance de Baky que bah il
les ses adversaires il donneent vraiment
tout même avec les noirs pour le contré
et c'est pas enfin c'est jamais trop
bien quoi deire non non non mais là
peut-être qu'il exagère je sais pas voir
tour C6 je sais pas si si fort ou si je
fais tour 1 pour aller vers A7 mais le
roi noir peut être faible F la D E4 elle
sera bien placée tu as H4 H5 qui peut
aller ouvrir le roi tu as la 7èe rangée
enfin je sais pas je me sis beaucoup
plus confortable avec les noirs sans les
dames
que que que comme comme ça quoi je suis
100 % d'accord avec toi après les
joueurs pe peuvent péter des câbles hein
ouais parce qu'en fait nul ça le met
très mal yangi aussi bah très mal c'est
un grand mot mais oui enfin c'est dur de
se qualifier mais je gr c'est un winner
texitol ce tourno en winner une seconde
il a pas joué de gros
zo il a besoin de gagner enfin il a il a
une petite chance donc il risque tout
mais
évidemment ça a l'air complètement
débile en fait c'est Baki qui est de
nouveau gagnant B gagnant c'est un grand
mot mais qui un gagnant qui est qui joue
de nouveau le gain
jeis ouais mais c'est entre guillemets
tout le problème de faire des qualifiers
comme ça oui en fait tuincites les les
joueurs à jouer contre le le cours du
jeu parce que l'EN jeu dans le tournoi
est plus important que la partie en soit
ouais après tant mieux si ça fait nos
affaires ça avait pas du tout fait nos
affaires
Il a 2 ans avec qui avait forcé qui
avait forcé Maxime à prendre le
risque je crois qu'il a troué ça tombe
dans Lig dont on parut ça va faire nul
en fait du coup très bien jou la part de
Sarana Sarana si trouve tout ça là en
fait pour le coup il est en train de
trouveril va filer au 5 faire part jouer
le truc avec
des4 on dit problème ou intérêt du
tournoi au contraire toutes les parties
ouis mais truc merbleux c'est que enfin
tu fais un cyle de championnat du monde
tu fais des parties qui durent 7 he pour
être bien sûr que soit les meilleurs qui
soient qualifiés et cetera et ça va
complètement à l'encontre de c'est
complètement incohérent par rapport à
tout le reste c'est plus ça le truc
bizarre ouais et
puis dans les années 80 90 pour te
qualifier au candidat il y avait ce
qu'ils appelaient les interzonaux cétait
bien ouais mais en fait céit un gros
tournoi comme ça mais sauf que tu avais
pas deux places je sais pas si tu a h ou
quoi et euh et ok du coup c'étaitens de
dominer le tournoi tu vas pas prendre
des gros risques pour être absolument
premier ou deuxème et juste en jouant
alors après bah les mecs il devaient
absolument finir 8e à la fin bon ben il
faisit plus ou moins au Lig mais
mais mais du coup ça avit peut-être plus
de de sens comme c'était avant je sais
pas faudrait y réfléchir en tout cas je
là je peux pas te dire mais là c'est
vrai que ça incite vraiment des joueurs
à prendre des risques parfois
inconsidérés mais qu'ils ont raison de
prendre c'est comme quand tu es au
candidat un peu ce qu' avait fait
firouja la dernière fois c'est que bah
c'était trop en fait ce qu'il faisait
mais euh il jouait à un peu contre
nature par rapport à ce qu'il aurait pu
faire on espère que ça tourne pour nous
évidemmenta là qui a peut-être pas de
bol une nouvelle fois hein franchement
euh
ouais je sais pas s'il nous oblige mais
je pense qu'ils ont dû demander à ce
qu'elle y soit non la jauge
ouais comme ça ça fait tous les streams
un peu pareil dans toutes les langues
c'est tant mieux hein ça permet de voir
la jauge très bien
et donc la varante dont on parlait c'est
tour prend le5 tour prend tour prend fou
C6 défend D5 attaque
B3 B4 pour le défendre et D4 casse le
socle en
C3 pour venir bouffer B4 et attaquer le
cavalier sur la route et D4
et jouer cette finale un pion de moins
mais qui doit faire nul qui gagnant je
sais pas si c'est gagnant gagnant en
tout cas qui soit
mieux il va serouver bien en fait
mais
c'est prend5 D3 ça va sû être ça la
partie mais
ouais mais bon un moment tu vas mettre
ton content tu dois te le faire fermer
par
F4 après tu peux peut-être mettre ton
pion B2 ouais ouais non mais d'accord
mais enfin quoi qu'il en soit je veux
pas avoir les dames quoi avec les Noirs
moi c'est ouais non c'est fa un choix
bizarre mais après comme je dis c'est
plutôt un choix situationnel chose he
fait j'essaie de comprendre ce qu'il a
pu enfin j'arrive pas à capter ce que ce
qu'il a pu se dire en
fait tu sais il y a peu de temps pour
bcky c'est un peu l'irrationnel hein il
joue vite pour jouer le gain clairement
là il pousse à 10000 % yangi il a
surpoussé après c'était la strade de
Baky hein de se dire moi toute façon je
je joue pas le
gainoue pas mais je je laisse les mecs
c'est à eux de prendre les
responsabilités je pense qu'au début il
l' joué enfin il a joué ce qu'il avait à
jouer et puis bon ça a pas tourné pour
gagner il s dit ok ben nul pas si mal
normal pragmatique mais que
effectivement si l'adversaire veut
forcer non le truc c'est que je pense
que you a raison de forcer et ça fait
aussi enfin je crois que c'est un genre
de jeu qui arrange tout le monde je sais
pas comment
dire bah qui qui joue le contre
ouais non mais je sais pas c'est comme
ouais c'est comme un truc o si au foot
ou si a 0-0 les deux sont éliminés mais
toi tu es moins fort et tu joues à 10
derrière et tuespères mettre un contrre
à la fin quoi ouais tu vas-y hein vas-y
débrouille-toi enfin nous si on est
éliminé ça me va et c'est un peu enfin
c'est c'est bien de faire
ça ceinture noire
quoi c'est plutôt bien tu te mets en
contre et tu alors on on est auù
objectif on qui a jouer H5
ok
euh bah sûrement un meilleure tentative
que que l'autre vent qu' regarda puisque
était logique et et euh mais tomb vers
nul donc H5
jou 10h c'est stratégie des gens qui
gagnent des tour l'italien en 200 oui
mais tu peux pas comparer le Footit au
foot tu peux faire
nul juste là tu peux pas à quel jeu au
foot tu peux jouer tous derrière par que
0 bah tu peux c'est pas du tout pareil
là il se trouve que 0-0 les deux perdent
c'est ça l'avantage de Calif de
poule
tout à fait
pareil tu peux en faire une stratégie là
en fait si tu es plus fort tu l'autre il
va te faire nul enfin pas c'est pas une
stratégie ça tombe comme ça parce que le
format du tournoi est zarbi
quoi après vidit lui il joue en devant
jouer le gain puisquil est plus fort en
fait c'est je sais pas comment dire
c'est pas du tout la même
problématique tu dois battre des gens
moins forts et donc tu dois prendre les
responsabilité et prendre le jeu à ton
compte un peu comme you dans cette
partie
Ikar quoi juste par
curiosité il gag un pion quand Mme c'est
nul mais bon c'est iarou quoi non mais
du coup c'est moins simple
que quand il a pas de en plus quoi fou
H5 bien joué
bravo jou ça comme ça en fait c'est ça h
garde des pièces un
peu c'est
malinou il joue vraiment fort que
G8 t D1 ouais tu mets une petite
pression tu met une pression et puis en
plus tu seras pas encore au 40e si tu
arrives là tu
39e encore deux coups à jouer tu V
prendre tour des 4 ouais ça tour des 4
40e coup vas-y à
toi et tu as zéro risque avec les Blancs
c'est très bien joué de la part d'Ala
parce qu'a lui il a encore une autre
problématique c'est qu'il doit pas trop
risquer comme un abruti non plus parce
que il a les points et l' donc c'est
encore une autre problématique du
tournoi en fait il y a trop de joueurs
qui ont des problématiques différentes
je sais pas c'est c'est bizarre
mais bon tant mieux évidemment si on si
on en profite on essay-nous de vous
expliquer un peu les enjeux et les
raisons des coups bizarres qui sont pas
des coups qui seraient joués dans des
situations
normales il joue des TR
mal que en fonction des résultat de
Nakamura ben pas de manière directe mais
tu te dis en fait si carou se qualifie
il est pas mal parti pour le Loo ça va
être hyper important donc je vais pas je
vais pas me mettre à tenter le n'importe
quoi et me me mettre en difficulté pour
une qualification pour une autre type de
qualification enfin j'ai pas besoin
quoi pourquoi le dame 5 de pas bien
c'est pas tant pas bien c'est que l'ordi
préfère autre chose tour 1 tour ouais
tour pour aller rentrer là-bas et jouer
pour l'attaque du roi ou échanger la
tour en8 peut-être je sais
pas mais ce qu'il a fait c'est pas mal B
en fait il va être mieux un peu mieux et
et sans risque donc c'est normal quand
tu as de minutes à la pendule de faire
ça une nouvelle fois c'est pas lui qui a
la responsabilité de faire le fou
furieux non non puis bon un moment il va
essayer il va la jouer longtemps
maintenant parce que là il a plus trop
de
risquetien c'est euh en fait h il a
forcé pour rien faire de si bien tu te
fais bouffer des de bon tu essayer de
mettre ton P en B2 ou quoi mais
bon il va jamais aller en B ce pion de
toute façon donc non au pire on fera
tour des 7 on va te le donner contre le
fou par qu'en fait ça c'est pas pour moi
c'est que les blancs qui jouent le G ou
je suis d'accord c'est complètement
débile ce qu'il a fait
ou je pense B qui va la gagner en fait
ouais enfin il a bonne
chance parti tellement
bizarre et si tu fais ça ça ouais c'est
même mêmeami quoi tuas pas provoqu F4 je
pense tu as envie de le provoquer quand
même h je pense aussi
ouais alors chez F chez Maxime c'est
fini on peut fermer
d'ailleurs voir chez Baky ce que se
passe il a fait D2 F4
B3 les coup s'enchaînent assez
logiquement on approche du 40e
j'essaie de comprendre en fait comment
les Noirs veulent
défendre bah je pense en fait tu vas
mettre ton pion en B2 tu vas gêner un
peu la coordination des blancs et puis
c'est tout
quoi mais tuespères que ça tienne je
vois pas comment tu peux une garantie
que ça
tienne
j'ai l'impression que je vais
perdre avec les Noirs mais oui moi je
j'auris aucune confiance me bon
peut-être par miracle je vais tenir je
me bat
mais c'est hyper bizarre ce qu'il a fait
ben c'est ça en fait c'est que sous
prétexte tu joues pour le gain tu joues
la défaite en fait mais tu ne joues pas
du tout le gar en faisant ça en fait
c'est ça le
truc des fois la position peut être
compliqué et oui effectivement tu jouis
le gain et puis ça mal tourner où
l'autre a bien joué bon c'est la vie
mais là c'est c'est juste une très très
très mauvaise
décision à moin pas tu peux reminer dame
pr 6e pour
savoir je prens donc là bon je joue
clairement donc tu vas
prendre et en fait on va voir le même
genre de truc mais les gens fait pas mat
quoi
c'est pas la
même n tout de suite mais
okutre qu'il s dit ok ça c'est nul je
peux pas si je fais nul le tourno quo je
sais
[Musique]
pas
bizarre viteatention donc ouais écoute
c'est comme
ça en tout cas ettienne qui va avoir sa
chance là il a pris B3 bien jou il va
mettre le P B2
mais
ah ouais non bah qui qui veut faire nul
aussi ah domage
ça je pense bah à moins que concrètement
il y avait vraiment rien mais j'ai
semble que c'est dommage que Baky joue
pas du tout le gain quoi parce que là je
pense qu'il y avait une chance
mais après c'est aussi difficile quand
tu pars du principe tu joues vraiment
pour nul
puis tu as pas le temps à la pendu que
machin depuis un moment et c'est
difficile de se réadapter à rejouer le
gain
quoi c'est un peu dommage notre côté ça
se
comprend en marquant il va gagner ça
c'est pas le problème ikarou il va
peut-être gagner aussi benah il essaye
euh donc F6 jouer donc regardz une autre
variante s'il faisait fou C6 laiss
arriver le cavalier donc il a plutôt pas
mal réagi je trouve Sana encore une fois
il fait sa partie quandme Sarana mais
ouais fara qu'on essaie de bien on
reviendra ce soir sur ce sacrifice de
pion qui me semblait pas nécessaire mais
y a une gave de you B2
non mais c'est pas one ga enfin c'est
c'est le coup logique quoi après je sais
pas peut-être fallait jouer tour B8
d'abord ou je ne sais quoi mais d'abord
ouais mais bon ça c'est ah mais je
comprends moi j'aurais commencé par tour
B8 personnellement pour éviter tour B5
mais
mais B T5 tour à8 puis on va et
puis Bou avec les blanc
êre il veut faire tour Fd1 tour D8
etchanger aller en B8 après t Fd1 tu dis
faut F6
ouais t B5 t A8
T 2 ouais
bon ok les noir passe leur
tour on veut qui roi D2 ro de tour bien1
et après l'autre tour est libre un peu
de faire sa
[Musique]
vie ça peut hein aè on essae H4
H5
ça réussi à faire ça on va être gagnant
ça c'est ouais par il y a même des
réseaux
après non tour B8 ça aurait été mon coup
réflex mais pas pour les bonnes raisons
donc c'est
pas et bon on voir en tout casen bon
bien sûr il a une très bonne technique
donc s passe le 40e avec des
possibilités avir le temps de réfléchir
et on va voir il peut
peut-être la fatigue qui se fait un peu
ressentir aussi dans cette partie he
peut-être chez les deux joueurs par que
le tournoi est long c'est pas facile
mais bon hier ils ont la g de repos qui
justement est censé les aider t bien
joué ouais bon ça après c'était logique
c'est mais bon tour B5 il va l'avoir
aussi parce qu'il est logique aussi ben
là je crois que F F6 tu dois faire je
pense pas que c'estit une bonne idée
pour les noirs de laisser échanger la
tour si
facilement après bon fa regarder
concrètement évidemment
mais mais ça ça
offre ça se trouve c'est même pas si
simple Mme avec tour des pour les blancs
he
mais c'est tellement bizarre de pas
avoir fait tomber 8 en
premier donc F F6 ok logique donc tour
B55 ça va être
joué pense qu'il va faire tour B5 ça
parat normal mais tour B5 tour C8 et
tour C1 peut-être plus malin que tour A8
de toute façon ramène le RO non euh
ouais mais du coup j'ai tour C2 tour pr
H2
peut-être tu peux ne pas êre faire gaffe
on tour
D7 gen RE 2 tour
C2 3ais je sais
pas t D7 peut-être
ouais ça peut être très dangereux
ouais bah il y a des chances il y a des
chances t B5
jouer je pense qu'il peut vraiment la
gagner en
fait
B5 est-ce que il doit avoir le se là
quand même bah disons il a joué tout
pour gagner et là en fait tu ton seul
espir c'est de faire nul maintenant tu
tu prétends plus
rien moi je pense qu'il peut la
gagner parce que ça doit être tellement
relou là jouer avec les Noirs quand tu
quand tu
as surtout avec le scénario de la
partie où tu t'es mis dans la merde tout
seul quand même
ouais sera pas un problème parce que il
a une minute 5 mais c'est 30 secondes
par coup il y a plus que TR cou jouer
bon tu ramèes tonie on a vu plus
dur donc ça va en fait surtout que même
si faisis de H3 c'est pas sûr que soit
si grave tu peux attendre pu tu veras
bienp qui vaêtre joué al pourquoi est-ce
que l'ordi ve absolument roi F2 tour C1
je veux juste comprendre un truc si je
fais juste roi
E22 P C 3 ouaistir au pire mais oui ok
B7 tu faire8
ouais et genre ça il veut que soit un
statu jeurais tellement pas confiant
avec les Noirs non non non mais tu peux
y croireo enfin je comprends que tu tu
es pas sûr que tu vas perdre avec les
noir mais je pourrais pas te prétendre
que c'est nul comme ça
moi ouais c'est donc de jouer par Baki
mais bon je crois qu'il va faire tour C1
de toute façonès l'idée de faire tour C1
et de se dire que de toute façon tu as
jamais ro des de j'ai fou C3 et je
reviens ça tu le vois pu tu dis ça tu
vois et tu dis ouais de toute façon mais
après faut juste pas trop te flipper de
sur le 8e parceen fait le ramener en 8
c'est bien t'empêche les tours des7
t'empêche les
machins et tour B7 c'est pas trop
grave faut trouver cette idée ouais
c'est vraiment dur et
alira qui a joué
C4
euh
ok g de fous C 6
prendre attends je vais voir pourqui l'i
dit ça ça ça ça ça ouais mais ça ça
comment ça ah mais il ve nul ouais mais
on va pas faire ça quand même non non je
sais je juste VO ça oui bon ça c'est
juste nul donc C4 ou C6 il veut
quoi ah peut-être ah non est-ce que tu
qui TR k F4 céit
pas j'ai pensé sur pion prend tu F G V
bon tu nul quoi mais tu le fou ouais
mais oui ben je suis d'accord et je peux
pe pas vouloir ça
ça
ça h on prend on va dire
non j'ai pas le temps de toute façon je
vais essayer de faire un F4 mais non bon
a priori a priori on doit pas poser de
gros problèmes au noir dans cette
position
ma il veut rien ouais je suis d'accord
ça ça je crois qu'il veut rien aussi
ouis mais Bonon
ah ouais
terrible on y a cru pendant un moment
peut-être
pas pas bon j'ai envie de dire
enfin moi je trouve qu'il a quand même
bien
jouéa c'est une partie correct de parti
d'autre mais c'est quand il va gagner G5
je pensais qu'il allait peut-être poser
plus de problèm que là
quoi mais bravo Sarana bien bien jugé
quoi B qui pe vraiment vraiment gagner
hein il disent que viit va gagner je
vois ça depuis tout à l'heure mais je
vois pas ça va faire nul et gag ou c'est
tout lae Num 3 euh c'est quoi il a quoi
en plus il avir de pièces ouais puis en
plus ouais non non il va gagner là c'est
s c'était il s'est passé quoi avant
c'était une partie sûement compliquée le
4 5 c'était chaud mais donc une
italienne
ouais j'avis V se position ok
tendu il a bouffer un pion là-bas ahend
des TR ça a l'air joli en je sais pas ça
va vite là mais ouais c'est un truc en 4
qui traînait ok bah il l'a défoncé en
fait enin l'impression que j'ai eu il a
perdu la première depuis il a mis le
turbo al après il va avoir un départage
pourri il a perdu la première contre win
lami après il a BTU Gupta il a BTU
Colars il a BTU shirof nul ner ave Clen
noir il a BTU nan là si rebass sindarov
euh pas mal il va être à 5 et demi/ 7
ouais et enfin ça lui fera un 5 et demi
sur 6 en
d'affilé il avit déjà très bien joué la
Coupe du Monde visitein il avait éliminé
NPO notamment il av perdu contre Abass
était complètement injouable sur C TER
sur C TER il était injouable ouais euh
il a
ouais il faouit peut-être pas faire
grand-chose en
réalité autes juste comme ça pour un
tour d'horizon des trucs euh ici Pinko
c'est on a suivi un peu c'est chaud
ettienne il
essaye coroba l'air très mal vu la jauge
keer keer beau joueur je pense pas qu'il
va se qualifier enchaîner les victoires
mais on sait pas il peut il peut kzub de
la colère TF
il a une pièce de plus ouis OK et d
machin DCH essaye un peu bon
journé pour les pour les BC le jouur ka
qui se bat contre
CF quel
génie peut-être la tenir encore quoi oua
quel il fait il a un peu mal peut-être
mais5 qui jour
peut-être je sais pas trop il est pas il
est loin d'avoir perdu en tout cas qu'
tien encore quoi il arrête tout le monde
c'est un de gardien de but quoi mais il
est
incroyable pas du tout
274 24 non ça c'est sûr non mais en fait
c'est comme je dis j'étais surpris fait
que le gars soit sous-classé ça normal
mais tu vois il est que matre donc tu
peux te dire ok il a le niveau grand
maître et 2550 et Machin mais là en fait
c'est pas ça c'est genre niveau il fait
une parf 2008 quoi et puis il te la
tient tout le long du tournoi donc c'est
juste fou
quoi mais donc Alera s'il fait nul il
sera à 4 et dem et V serait déjà à 5 et
ouais mais bon il va prendre du kwana
maintenant il va prendre du Nakamura
il peut faire nul
hein il il
disent tour C2 est-ce qu'il va aller
chercher
H2 c'est ce qu'on tout à l'heure non il
a fait tour d'abord de tour C2 ok après
les gens disent qu'ilch moins bon coup
mais peut-être que
sur il va faire tour C1 tour D1 peut va
pét pour le 40 ah non mais il y a
ça ah il double là-bas al ça pour le
coup ça peut être gagnant
ouais alors l'ordi dit que non mais
attends non mais il est pas très fort
cet ordi si ça se peut que ce soit
gagnant
ça en plus c'est le
40e moi je pense que B qui va la gagner
hein
bah ouais c'est une chance
raisonnablec des fr candidat bah oui ben
est plutôt favori pour y aller avec tous
les classements
cumulés gagne celle-là il se met bien
alors il se met bien loin d'être
qualifié mais bon quand tu es+ 3 après c
TR quand même pas
mal tour c'est1 et ça on est 40e donc
bon ça va enseil veut tour B8 3 F7
plutôt tour D7 3 E6 tour B7 et roi F5 hm
hm plus logique comme manière de
défendre F3 tour F1 r G2 tour
repart moi j'aurais fait Tor C3 ok si tu
veux G2 échc ro H3 plus d'échec
ok je trouve la manière de défendre
assez logique pour les Noirs à vrai dire
t B4 H5 HM
h c'est une sorte de sorte de
forteresse il a fait tourner un B qui
retour non ok mais ça je peux comprendre
mais
euh il l' fait vite je trouve parce
qu'en fait là vu qu'il a passé le 40e il
pu réfléchir il a 50 minutes quoi donc
oui mais va la jouer bon ben peut-être
il y a rien à jouer en fait hein je veux
dire mais euh mais pourquoi pas ouais
ila qui joue ce que je t'avais dit tu a
3 F7 tu prend 8 euh donc on prend on
avait
dit peut-être que tout toutes les
prisons mais moi je voulais garder ma
tour en B8 pour attaquer B3 et mon fou
pour défendre le pion OK et ouais mais
peut-être pas F4 peut-être rien en fait
et tour 3 au lieu de C
prend D4 tour
ouais on a un de plus mais on est
tellement passif que on fait de la
merde qui arrive pas jouer au con faut
faire
nul4 le 3 tu fa échanger
ok probablement
nul
mais
pas encore qualifié pour autant mais il
est pas mal il est pas mal du
tout qui a pris F prend
ouais4 pe importe quoi tu proposes juste
en
fait il ve peut-être tout reprendre
prend le 5 dernier
piège mais encore oui mais au MOS tu
joues pour gagner quoi mais non mais
l'USS fait ro F7 ou je sais pas
quoi dernier piège
ah magnifique
ouais mais bon ça je vais quand même
jouer encore un petit peu ouais au moins
je te fais F3 si je peux r F23 enfin non
non mais je suis d'accord ouais je vais
pas te faire nul comme ça quoi je quand
Mme mon pion de plus c'est bon
h non non ok bon il a peut-être trouvé
le meilleur truc possible quoi en
réalité ouais ouais la seule en c'est
pas une chance mais c'est le seul truc
où où tu signes pas
direct B qui lui a refait t de échec
évidemment et là B qui va c'est sûrement
lever il va pouvoir
réfléchir s'il répète et ok bah c'est
comme ça ou bon moi j'essai quand même à
sa place parce que c'est les noirs qui
doent trouver quelques coups
probablement nul en
fait
pas trop dur
mais dernier n
reste partir en
PA qui va gagner complètement
[Musique]
gagnant
voil aller une W car pour
un tuas 4en c'est beau quoi ils peuvent
se faire l'ascenseur quoi tu peux vraent
si points un gars quoi moi j'aurais fait
hein
ouais il font pas mais ou mais ENF non
mais il font pas moi j'aurais
fait une fusée quoi C qui a le plus gros
zlo B tant mieux pour lui ou tu le un f
avant
tu le fais faire un temps à fermer sans
dire à personne avant celui qui gagne
entre le tournoi à 4 bah du coup tu lu
donnes 6 points quoi tu fais un G
Kama donne la force terrestre
quoi il serait beau
quen bah ça fait penser à la Russie des
années 60 hein h
oui mais surtout qu'ils ont aucun jouur
dans non mais ce qui est beau c'est
qu'ils ont aucun joueur dans le top 10
mondial
non non ils ont unand mais genre là dans
tous ceux qui peuvent se qualifier le
mieux il est mondial viit c'est 27e
c'est 28e et
GCH il en chute il3e d'ailleurs il fait
quoi aujourd'hui ser bon qu'il se fasse
encore défoncer
quoiah il a quand même gagner là contre
le Norvégien ouis contre le Norvégien
cétait quoi l'ouverture on s'en fout
mais je s
par bah si tu veux je te montre hein
ouais ENF c'est juste' fout aussi quoi
enfin Lopez
ok je ils font pas juste nul en fait
enfin c'est nul t'emmerd bah le mec avec
les Blancs il doit vouir jouer pour
progresser il se dit voilà c'est le
gamin là ouais ben c'est ça il joue pour
jouer il joue pour progresser alors que
B ne progresse pas quoi enfin reste nul
nul quoi voilà bravo quoi ah ok il y a
une partie non c'est bien pour gche qui
stoppe un peu l'hémorragie enfin il
saigne bien quand même
mais il gagne une partie au MO il part
pas tout ou je n'importe
quoi donc RET jouer sement qu' a des
deux
c'est la fin du Z not je propose qu'on
fasse une petite pause que là ça va ça
va plomber un pe ça a plombé une
demi-heure donc au moins qu'on souffle
un peu là et comme ça on revient avec
plein d'ENT trin et d'énergie surtout
que là ça va faire nul à mon avis
rapidos il prend E5 il peut pas là il f
pr te reprend ro ro D6 F auss donc il va
faire qu' a des2 ouais il va voilà mais
bon après tu es tu es bien bloqué mais
qui sait si tu va défendre ton B3 que tu
fais F3 que tu ramène le roi que non
mais bon
oui mais tu vas pas faire nul quand même
là non non non tu fais quand même pas
nul ah on sait enfin non non mais je
suis
d'accord il va faire quoi il te faire
tour à8 tu vas faire F3 il va te faire
tour à2
ça ferme
bien fais ça tu fais nul quoi
voilà on prend et T C T
4 tu pas
nul tu feras vite nul mais bon allez sur
ce petite pause et on revient pour voir
si se passe encore des choses allez à
toute
[Musique]
he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
alors les amis on va voir une une
première nulle là arrivriver dans la
partie d'Ali B vous avez vu les coups et
on verra après si Baki peut
gagner de toute façon c'est complètement
nul bah oui donc il a un pion de plus
mais ce pion C ne peut pas être valorisé
la T est très active en C2 der passé
toujours la position préférentielle et
en plus sur la seconde ranger ou bon
elle empêche le roi venir trop euh
s'activer parce que tu attaqu F2 donc
sans qu'ter qu'il a peut-être F5 tour H4
4 et qui va encaisser le
pion tour F6 R5 qui a l'air bien nul
ouais bon ça ça va faire nul et
Baki Baki qui qui clique alors Baky en
fait il fait un genre de tour C1 ça tour
C2 ça tour C2
retour3 ouais un retour ro D2 il veut
quoi il veut fou C3 ro E2 fou F6 et au
blanc de jouer c'est la même mais au
blanc et du coup peut-être faire un G4
c'est ça quiil veut et du coup tour C2
roi E3 tour C1 à ce moment-là peut-être
les deux échecs qu les deux échecs et
aller en B7 aller en B7 sauf que
maintenant il y aura plus de roi F5
ouais voilà ce qu'on regard tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est ce qu'il
veut
al les noir peuvent faire fou des4
ici mais tu fais tour B3 ouais tu évites
son truc C32 fou F6
ah mais du coup tu as plus
le bah tu tuas tu as pas joué G4 mais tu
peux le jouer maintenant
non on ve refire la même chose son et il
peut te faire ro F7 direct tour D7 tour
B7 mais on
verra bon ok enfin priori ça doit
pouvoir aller pour les Noirs mais c'est
eu de faire gaffe de pas se tromper et
c'est pas si facile après 4hur de partie
quand tu as moins de lucidité alors
attends est-ce qu'il va faire fou C CD4
tour
B4 3 pardon C3 bon tu peux pas prendre
donc2 et maintenant si tu veux jouer
comme ça jouer le RO F7
direct peut-être tu peux F5 comme ça
comme ça tu plus malin ça c'est
peut-être la bonne
ligne mais
bon comme ça G4 tu fais
Russ la tour D1 arrive pas à aller se
placer doublette avec
l'autre
un
coup de
T ok ah c'est pas bête aussi pas bête
mais bon c'est peut-être MOS com fac les
blanc pour se délier de tout ça est-ce
qu'on envoie le G4 maintenant Ilir une
idée justement sur ce
G4 iluttre justement à ce
momentl
mais écoutez ça va durer cette partie au
contraire de celle
d'IRA peut gagner
hein disons bon pour moi nul est le plus
probable bien sûr mais c'est pas d' draw
du tout et il puir des cas de fill ça se
passe bien donc peut-être peut-être 25 %
de chance de gain un truc comme ça non
non il y a des chances là
Mar qui est gagnant complètement gagnant
marquant faut finir mais ça per trop dur
Naka qui essaye en fait il a une sorte
de finale comme celle de d'alira mais
mieux ouais mais pas assez normalement
ala c'esta il TR il y aura plus qu'un
pion et bientôt plus de pion du
tout ça va ça va faire
nulidé tour F1 ah je sais pas j'aurais
pas fait tour
F j'aurais pas joué je sais pas trop ce
que c'est peutêre faire F5 dou après ou
je sais pas je pas trop quoi vous
dire com pour pour les candidats pas
terrible c'est pas terrible mais c'est
on au même point que ce matin quoi
allez prend C6 c'est beau t les pièges
de
con
dommage chiant à force prend C6 change
les tours avec tour H6 on veut plus rien
voir dommage
hein
niveau
classement on est dans les bas
fonds dans les haut
fond la surface même dans les haut
sphère mê Mo
disons toujours
mieux qui va pas réussir à la gagner
dommage pour lui hein c'est un beau ch
ils sont aussi à 4 et demi he c'est des
joueurs à 4 et demi on va voir ils vont
peut-être nous mettre le classement
audessus je crois qu'ils font genre
d'écran
défilant on est bien assez bas ça c'est
les mecs
complètement
bravo ouais pour moi a des des
des bonnes Chan il a des Chan il a des
chances de gain voilà n plus probable
mais pas fait du tout pe passer des
[Musique]
choses dites Maxime un demi de
fou g ou en
fait G4 le coup qu'on
attendait
plus que le tour F1 de
l'ordi sur H5 jouer H3 en fait
moi mais c'est peut-être pas bête pour
de le faire quoi qu'ever des pions mais
je sais pas trop je questionne toujours
avec ces structures de pion pere G6 un
peu faible B6 qui arver sais jamais dur
de
répondre je ne sais jamais
bon vidit devrait gagner je fais un
petit tour Mo des positions comme ça je
regarde
ici c'est compliqué il
s'accroche est mieux mais c'est pas
gagné
Ker il défonce quoi combien de points il
est à 4 ou 4 et dem
[Musique]
kerer je mettrai à 4
ah il était à 4
ouais kubof a battu
rtmf 4 c'est quoi en faitfin combien
avait fou avant C round qu ok mais il
est comme fou en fait ouais donc ça
c'est qure Ker donc il passerait devant
ouis
c'est
sur H5 pas pu on prend puis on prend et
T
reprend t
desè H5 tu prend t éche t je sais pas
quoi on
encaisse h 5 du coup quand tu vois ça tu
[Musique]
dis
du coup peut-être ça va mais je dire tu
peux voir ça rapport a battu Bartel donc
rapport reste il rient sur
firou a pas gagné terminus il continue
Perre des points c'est la cata
[Musique]
pour va gagner je
dirais qui reviendrait aussi Douda ah tu
mets le cou donc il a pris sa chance
bravo avec les noir dernière chance je
crois pas qu'il gagnera contre ner
si B qui gagne il passerait 2uxè attends
fais voir je vais regarder avec les
départage stop the
Count classement pour la ronde
non
possiblement pas quand même il serait
deuxème execo mais euh prête que à un
meilleur
départage et cinder il serait plus il a
perdu il va perdre
ouis et si fienko il avait un moins bon
départage il jouit contre un joueur qui
a moins d'élo il peut perdre en plus il
peut
perdre c'est le jalmanov quoi
mais en fait firou il est très mal he
pour la Calif via le grand Suisse là non
c'est terminé je pense il nul de trop en
plus avec les Blancs al terminer c'est
un grand mot évidemment vu qu'on dit
qu'il a encore des espoirs pour
Maxime qui a moins de points donc c'est
pas fini s'il finit en fanfare mais
disons s'il suit sur ce rythme là même
si on gagne qu'une ou deux ça devrait
pas suffire mais c'est déjà pas mal ri
s'il gagne il va être très bien a pas un
si mauvais départage quand même par
rapport à du Naka
machin non mais c'est chaud enfin c'est
très indécis et ben c'est c'est en ça
qu' est intéressant ce tournoi c'est bon
c'est la cadence qui nous dérange un peu
parce que il y a des coups de mou quoi
mais en soi il y a de l'enjeu c'est
chaud quoi yakubof il fait quoi tu
disais qui qui ça yakuboef euh je sais
plus contre qui joue parce que lui il
avait un gros
départage je vais aller
voir
mais en gros yangi je pensais qu'il
était pas très bien il all les noir
contre des Hatch
euh non il est pas
bien je sais
pas et c'est Korobov qui bat ou c'est
kzubof kzubof a battu artemief donc
artemief ciao
kzubof il va être à 5 aussi ouis
surprise quand même ça en fait fallit
faut vraiment être à 5 là ouais il y a
trop de monde en fait ouais il y a trop
de monde à 5 en fait même à 5 tu es pas
super bien en réalité enfin tu es bien
parce que tu es dans le bon
pleloton un Ploton ouais à 4 et demi tu
es un peu dans le Ploton débattu quand
même bah 4 et demi il faut que tu
finisses en très très très très bien 3
de en fait tu es dans groupe
rapportonion donc tu les as pas vu du
tournoi donc tu es mal en fait mal ou
mais mais bon de tels joueurs peuvent un
moment gagner trois parties de suite
après la faut pas qu' comme je disais
avec le truc du ho faut pas qu'il
s'amuse à faire nimp hein non non non
non pas du tout benah je crois je crois
qu'il a compris ça en fait ouais il a
l'air de gérer de pas s'envoyer en l'air
et du coup du coup voilà de pas finir
trop loin de
saut ce qui est faisable non mais il
faut que tu un caméra se qualifie en
fait
mais ça mais ça c'est loin d' fait aussi
en fait c'est faisable mais il est pas
très bien en fait Naka donc et peut-être
que Naka il s'en fout aussi en fait il
voit firou il dit bon
ais c'est vrai Naka doit pas risquer non
plus fait de la
merde Naka il a essayé de gagner
aujourd'hui il a juste pas très bien
joué pr bien trouvé le 5 là prend 45 bel
enchaînement il a ser le jeu et voilà et
là il
ESS il a pasot pour gagner il devrait
faire nul Naka mais mais Naka il va pas
y arriver je pense qu'il va pas se
qualifier est quand même dans un beau
groupe des 5
c'est pas non plus ridicule hein
j'ai peur qu'il y a aucun Français quoi
candidat là en réalité c'est pas quand
tu regardes le truc c'est pas bien parti
du
tout bah le
truc
il y a déjà une grosse Calif qui est
passé avec leoup la Coupe du Monde et
ben on pas les Grands Prix le machin F
Onura pas pas du tout une chance qui
part plus ça alors bon ça ici on risque
de pas se
[Musique]
qualifieril tu CIS pas comme j'exliqué
la chance elle est petite mais dire par
là que en gros quand on parle des
candidats j'ai expliqué hier pour avoir
un joueur qui a une chance de gagner les
candidats faudrait qu' avoir soit firou
soit Maxime en fait donc c'est les deux
qu'on regarde en priorité quoi qu'il en
soit après si Baky sur une grosse
surprise il va en candidat ce sera
génial mais je veux dire les chances
d'être champion du monde elles sont très
proche de 0 alors que fierouja s' va au
candidat tu auras peut-être 20 % de
chance qu'il les gagne 15 20 % et et
Maxime pareil mais sauf que Maxime bah
là c'est vraiment fini fini il rest 0,5
% de chance et firou en
réalité ça dépend de Naka en fait donc
si on considère que Naka a que 25 30 %
de chance de se qualifier via le grande
Suisse en fait tu es à 25 30 % de chance
d'avoir un français au candidat h et
alors qu'avant le début du tournoi je
pense que c'était un bon 50 % en fait
donc ouais c'est gen là le tournoi en
fait il se passe pas bien du
tout
n'est plus entre ses mains je pense pas
non je pense que firoualif n'est plus
entre ses mains
non a une tout maintenant bon qui sa et
pour
daym il y a une place à en fait Carl il
a gagné sa place via la Coupe du
monde ça comptera pas après juste à
priori il compte ne pas y aller mais on
sait jamais je veux dire changera la vie
changera pas
d'avis pas trop quoi te dire à ce
sujet donc bon
a priori il ira pas c'est ce serait
plutôt la tendance pour le moment
ouais ouais c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas l'idéal aujourd'hui après c'est quoi
la différence ho entre firou et Naka il
y a beaucoup là il y a 9 points c'est
énorme mais attends alors Naka a pas
encore perdu point qui va qui va perdre
quoi mais il perd quoi il perd un point
et demi il y a peut-être 7
points après Naka il faut peut-être
qu'il aille jouer un truc à la con aux
États-Unis à défoncer des mecs pour se
reprendre un peu de large bah je le
ferai à sa
place perdant pour by non mais by
il il est bien après ce que ça gagne ou
pas on sait
pasdon jamais de la vie
quoi là c'est Magnus il va pas le
problème c'est que
c'estass bon c'est catastrophique c'est
un charlot candidat
quoi mais bon c'est comme ça c'est puis
voilà mais ouais là en
gros bah c'est pas terrible pour nous
français
non mais Charlot enfin vous voyez ce que
je veux dire évidemment c'est un bon
joueur il est plus fort que moi mais
mais euh ok pour all les jouer les
candidats c'est peut-être je pense c'est
le jouur le plus faible à ne jamais
jouer les candidats quoi de l'histoire
donc donc bon je vais pas vous dire
c'est un grand génie quoi
il y aura tellement aucun rapport entre
les candidats et le top 8 ouais c'est
vrai mais bon après faut se qualifier
faut se qualifier hein enfin je veux
dire bravo à tous ceux qui aont pris
leur chance il seront arrivés hein non
mais même àen je pense qu'il est plus
fort que abasof déjà exenko a dépassé
les7 ououais ouais plus fort qu'abasof
évidemment donc il est un peu audessus
quand même largement
même mais gar l'élo moi je trouve que
c'est très peu hein mais après ouais
j'en a pris trois ou quatre en fait hein
bizarrement mais l'O c'est quand un truc
normal c'est en fait c'est le truc ouais
eto il il est pas qualifié non non non
il est pas qualifié je crois qu'il
cherche pas spécialement se qualifier
enfin déjà si tu viens pas ici c'est que
ça pas d'ê ta priorité dans la vie et
après il peut peut-être s'il fait un
énorme truc au ho ou qu' fait une belle
s of Cup et qui grille go à la race donc
so a pas dit sa dernière son dernier
mot beaucoup de et séché la coupeonde
mais en fait c'est pas si idiot de
l'avoir séché parce que quasiment tout
le monde a perdu des points ho et même
des gros points ouais et pas y aller
pour miser sur le hlo quand tu as un tel
hlo c'était pas enfin c'est pas idiot
c'est toujours pas idiot parce qu'en
fait ça veut dire que si toi tu te
qualifies au grand Suisse tu es qualifié
si Naka se qualifié au grand Suisse tu
es qualifié donc ça enfin tu as deux
chances en sachant que carwan a déjà
qualifié c'est les deux meilleurs
joueurs
en fait ouais le truc qui aurait été
dommage pourard fa un truc comme Maxime
tu perds un demi 05 contre un joueur
dangereux un SAR un mec comme ça ça te
coûte surtout tu as pu passer des tours
en faisant des nuls déjà
7 encore 7 15 Super 15 bah tu as 2750
comme so et compagnie et ou tu as 2760
mais du coup tu sues sfield donc après
je sais pas s'il a fait tous ses calculs
s'il a autre chose à faire dans sa vie
s'il a pas envie si je j'ai je connais
pas la raison j'aurais été à sa place
j'aurais essayé d'y participer mais ça
se trouve ça va être le calcul qui va le
qualifier de d'avoir fait ça donc peut
pas entièrement critiquer ce parce que
au début de enfin au début de ce tournoi
là quand même comme comme carwana est
déjà qualifié ouais du coup Naka et
firou c'est c'est quand même les deux
gros favoris c'est juste que comme c'est
une grosse loterie le grand le grand
Suisse même si tu as les deux meilleurs
chevaux et tu es pas sûr qu'il fin pas
sûr qu' fin dans les de premiers c'est
pas c'est pas un tournoi qui est
vraiment fait pour qualifier les plus
forts mais là on le voit ENF tuas tuas
VO sec tuas tuas vidit ou quoi tu tu
vois les moyens qu'ils ont joué mais bon
non mais tant mieux pour eux mais je
veux dire c'est là tu vois bien sur la
partie you contre Baky ça aurait été la
même position contre firou ça aurait été
nul signé depuis balurette en fait le
truc c'est ça c'est quand les joueurs
moins fort se jouent entre eux en fait
il risquent tout ils peuvent se battre
et donc forcément en fait c'est ben ouis
ça les avantages forcément en fait en
fait en ça les avantage pas
individuellement mais vu le nombre ben
forcément tu en as souvent qui pass as
souvent un qui passe voire deux non il
peut pas se REER la question que je me
posais tout à l'heure mais en fait non
il peut pas simplement pour tu dois
jouer un certain nombre de tournois dans
l'année pour prétendre la place à la
qualifo et pas des tournois de quartier
tu do faire des tournois et donc
[Musique]
voilà il a pas encore abandonné
d'ailleurs
non non non non il se bat il se B c'est
fou hein défend bien c'est perdant mais
en c'est les meilleures chances
pratiques là qui tente
ouais pour moi Naka là il va il va gérer
mais bon c'est aussi dangereux drugon
pour lui de jouer que la Califa lo même
si je pense que c'est le meilleur choix
pratique pour lui mais le risque c'est
que si al gagne une qui revient à de TR
points et l' il peut les gagner dans la
S Cup ouais mais ce que je disis je
pense ou doit ouais peut-être qu'il
peut-être qu' aussi il doit aller jouer
des tournois mais il doit faire il doit
faire ou comme des fous furieux ouais
doit faire des Open Batt des des mecs
comme moi et voilà bah ou payer non mais
ce serait moi ce serait viu he je te dis
moi ce serait direction l'Hongrie
direction Hongrie
ouais je vais te dire tu vas finir à
2850 en plus tu en prime la place de num
mondial
ouais ok juste tu vas acheter les
parties en fait enfin pourquoi pas quoi
B si ça se sa tu AAS un petit problème
quoi ouais pourquoi ça se serait quoi tu
prends les 204 en espèces et t'envoie
quoi et c'est quoi les car il que le P
en C5 mais c'est passé vite donc j'ai
pas mais il essa en tout cas il a pas
encore dit son dernier mot
complètement
si on fait re 5 il a une sorte d'idée
ouais pas tant que ça d'accord il faut
avoir confiance qui tu payes oui mais
c'est pour ça tu vas dans des pays où où
la confiance rne
règne tu vas dans des pay la confiance
règne c'est les plus
expérimentés et en Hongrie tu as
confiance
ah non pour le coup Ding je crois que ça
jouit vraiment he ses adversaires ouais
je crois qu'il jouit vraiment
ouais mais ça aurait pu que ce soit un
arrangement oui mais oui ça se peut que
les autres aent un plus le billet
cognitif ils sont quand même là pour
perdre machin
cout on ver bon en tout cas y qui suit
ou alors en France gen il y a bien des
Français là dans le chat qui sont prêts
à perdre quelques parties he sur des ton
à ferm pourquoi est si
loinanise un moi si' veut j'en per moi
j'en perds une je m'en fous non
mais ou
ouais tu non mais le truc en fait il a
pas besoin que je me couche quoi ouais
mais bon ok
par je fais pas trop ça quoi mais après
bon normalement il il assz grand pour
pour me battre tout seul quoi il s fait
de la pub pour les livres ah bon ouais
il pub pour les livres very good
[Musique]
book non en fait c'est beau quoi c'est
juste le chat qui va le sauver on va
faire plein à fer on va tous y aller on
va perdre comme des cons entre nous on
va faire nul sans jouer on s'en fout
quoi on fait on fait t du 1er au 31
décembre et ça dégage quoi et chat il a
fait
H6 après une longue
réflexion bon je sais pas quoi en
penser position est compliqué ça fait
bien peu les pions ça de se faire fixer
quand
même en fait gagner contre un Milo ça
lui rapporte 0,8 par tournoi c'est ça
mais plus trop maintenant mais
avant et là ils vont le rechanger mais
peut-être ça peut ouais tu fais que une
ronde ouais c'est ça une r fa les
tournoant en fait tu on joue qu'une
partie quoi tu repars et tu commences à
T le lendemain et claque et claque et
CLA et à coup 08 tu es bien c'est en
plus c'est complètement légal non oui
oui bah tout le monde comprend ce que tu
fais mais c'est pas interdit c'est pas
interdit
quoi ce que j'appelle l'optimisation
personnellement
h est-ce que j'ai déjà faitain non
jamais non parce que je suis pas assez
fort je suis pas sûr que j'aimerais
l'endroit pour le coup ah mais alis en
fait il se fait peut-être fermer par le
tournoi de chesscom là le champion ch ah
faut qu'il qu'il refuse les 100k quoi il
refuse les 100 K ouais tu sais ce que
c'est mais tant
pis c'est g c'est nul ça doit être nul
sur un jeu parfait mais je mais ça peut
être gagnant en pratique
H6 j'ai pas trop aimé le coup mais bon
après
ais visuellement j'aime pas tellement
mais je sais pas pourquoi pas alors
tiens il recommande mais en été OK ouis
je me dis que çare un crachin permanent
et j'aime pas ça moi en fait je m'en
fiche qu'il fasse froid mais bien froid
quoi tu vois ENF mais sec c'est pas
grave mais l'humidité ambiante ou quoi
je ça me plaît vraiment pas comme comme
temps donc on voit le classement
auudessus on l'a laissé pour que vous
voyez un peu les joueurs qui jouent ça
c'est
sympa
est-ce que H4 c'est
bien
bah pourquoi pas je sais pas si c'est
bien mais pourquoi
pas ça pas l'air absurde comme
coup en tout cas ça va durer
là il se c'est plus son je connais un
peu ouais je suis allé à plusieurs
reprises mais c'est beau quand même nous
truer tous les tournois il y aurait que
nous deux tous les tournois serait
truqué il y aura aucune partie qui se
jouerait en fait non
mais serè magnifique en fait pour
organiser tourno on joue pas aux
échecs des stages quoi en
fait que des nul à ranger VO obligé de
faire
nul mais par contre les à côté sera
sympa voilà voilà
exactement bien si B gagne il se donne
une vraie chance ouais on l' vu au
classement mais voilà vous êes Bonn idé
pingpong échec volleyball la
plage
ou le ski ou et cetera
quoi moi j'ai l'impression que je la
gagné quand même avec les Blancs jeais
bien un sondage savoir si vous êtes plus
raclette ou
fondu je sais pas s'il y a quelqu'un qui
peut te le faire il y a pas énormément
de modérateurs dommage B on le fera
d'ici la fin mais c'était juste je veux
pas influencer av donner mon
avis mais on voit quand même là avec la
réponse les réponse on
a plus de
raquette et qu'est-ce que quoi j'ai
pensé moi tout à l'heure j'ai pensé à la
fondue Bourguignon avec la fondue
euh Bour ouais tu tu la mets dans le
froid sais que c'est pas con hein ouais
j'ai vraiment envie de tester je sais
pas s'il y a des gens qui ont déjà tenté
l'expérience mais c'est une belle idée
d'américain ouais je sais pas mais c'est
il y a une idée quoi il a une idée mais
ouais les stages prévus prochainement
avec cornet ouais il y a les deux alors
en fait Seb et Mathieu ils vont faire
stage à Bordeaux en en décembre j'ai pas
la date exacte en tête mais tu pourras
trouver euh bah par sur le Twitter de de
Seb et euh j'en ferai un avec Seb euh
dernier weekend de janvier donc je crois
que c'est les 27 et 28 janvier à Paris
donc sur le weekend sera pas mal placé
pas loin de d'opéra et voilà donc si
jamais il nous reste des places c'est
déjà pas mal parti mais il en reste une
dizaine euh si tu veux euh t'envoie un
mail tuenvoie un Twitter t'envoie un ENF
tu nous contactes et euh est-ce qu'il
auras des pizzas voà est-ce qu'il y
auras des pizzas al je serais toujours
pas les faire à ce moment-là mais on va
peut-être faire la soirée pizza le
samedi soir ou je sais pas on n pas
encore décidé où on mangeit le samedi
soir mais normalement on se fait un
petit truc sympa c'est ça le planning en
fait tu tu poses tout le samedi le soir
tu te mets bien et tu refais le dimanche
mais tu as un beau samedi soir ça à côté
quoi est-ce que tu peux venir que pour
le samedi soir tu es obligé de faire le
stage tu peux venir que pour pour le
samedi soir mais euh il faut payer le
stage je sais pas comment on ferait mais
oui on pourrait faire une option venir
que pour pour le samedi soir parce que
moi j'en ai que enfin moi j'en a
absolument rien à quoi j'en ai
que le samedi soir
est fondu en mixte n dit doc av ça c'est
beau
ça ça c'est pour les prochains après il
y aura d'autres stages dans l'année
l'été peut-être nous on songera en
refaire un ou pas avec Kev on verra
c'est pas sûr tuas en parler tout à
l'heure à midi je sais pas tu as des
idées on a des idées mais on sait pas
enfin bon si ça se fait toute façon on
vous dira il reste des places pour la
backup mais que spectateur d's il en
restve pas beaucoup je sais pas plus que
20 et peut-être y en a qui sont partis
ouais la BUP bah très très bel event moi
je vous recommande si vous êtes dispo
alors du coup bah venez en spectateur
mais ah bah là en joueur ouais ça va
être compliqué
ouais
là je t'annonce que ça va être compliqué
je vais dire com il reste de
place il en reste pas énormément ça
c'est sûr place joueur c'est0 c'est
finito spectateur je pense qu'il en
reste encore 20 comme j'en ai pas
reparlé
depuis et ouais c'est bien ça il reste
20 20 places spectateurs ça pourrait
partir vite hein ça pourrait partir vite
ouais grosse ambiance en public avec les
tambours les trompettes les fumigèes
fumigè à mon avis tu vas être V bloqué
par la sécurité faut bien les
cacher il faut bien les cacher
effectivement mon
Fab qui mettre le feu àpot en fait j'ai
compris le projet du
Fab des bon droll oui des bon rô des
déguisements déguisement très bonne idée
je
pense
darda dans leuridani de points ça c'est
sûr il est dur le
[Musique]
tour tour est très
dur
est-ce que tu vas faire une petite pause
ouais parce que là en fait le prochain
sera important ce sera
dans pas loin d'une heure en fait non
mais un peu moins mais 20 20 25 minutes
peutêre de refaire une petite pause et
de revenir par qu'on était revenu un peu
plus tôt pour voir la fin de la partie
d'aliza et de revenir un peu plus tard
parce queour un peu trop à tout de suite
[Musique]
he he
he he he he
bon ben les amis en fait il y a pas il y
a pas eu de coup quoi du Tour B6 enfin
il y a eu oui il y a eu tour B6 il y a
eu un coup mais depuis un
moment on sait pas du tout quel quel
setup il veut mettre en place est-ce
qu'il va jouer avec fou G7 vous montez
drit pour laisser euh le pion prendre
mais ce serait une
chimère parce qu'on pourrait prendre en
D1 et faire B1
dame en fait il hésite un peu entre ça
est-ce qu'il fait fou G7 et il attend
comme ça ou il monte le loin contre le
roi et les deux vont peut-être hein
d'ailleurs mais
euh on va dire ouais tu est-ce que tu as
peur de
ça juste pour montrer hein la variante
et tu reprends
G7 ça un jour ça pourrait si le avait
monté êre gagnant pour les blancs faud
bien
défendre bon c'est de contre il a joué
G5 al je me questionnais làdusi est-ce
que tu peux vouloir ça pour ça pour
çaç F5 c'est évident c'est ça le
[Musique]
coup52 mais tu arrives pas à faire F F4
B2 peutre tu peux faire tour
C2
et tour C il y a de nouveau l'idée de
tout à
l'heure donc G5
F5 D4
ouais sur T C et on a pas tour B6 com
back on a pas
T3
on va voir la partie qui continue bon on
a qu'à signer nul juste
ok euh joli il pte quoi on peut on peut
aller voir parce que ça peut être sympa
juste ah c'est joli
ouais ah ouais on en était là il allait
bouffer le pion
H5 en fait il est tout bloqué il a fait
TF joli bon c'était loin d'être l'unique
manière de tenir mais il c'est un
résultat quand même important fais voir
du coup AUO où ça nous mène pour voir tu
sais avec le truc ou ouais
83 alors attends je c pas qu'elle soit
elle est pas encore compté non elle est
pas encore compté mais il a dû perdre
1,6 il a quel élo prè que par rapport à
lui il a 26 50 quelque
chose c'est écrit sur le chesscom ou pas
50 56 6 donc ça fait quoi la différence
par rapport à lui qui a 27 combien ça
fait 130 en gros 130 quasiment de hein
perd quasiment deux points bon c'est
toujours ça de prix hein enfin de prix
ou perdu
est-ce qu'il y a eu d'autres résultats
intéressant Fab en tête non alors
B ok c'est quand Mme un résultat
[Musique]
important alors ça donne quoi c'est
toujours ça se bat
toujours il domine cette partie mais pas
gagné dominer n'est pas gagné non
et VO
che ça joue encore
aussi c'est solide c'est solide il y a
pas d'entrée pour le roi blanc devrait
finir en N ça devrait tenir mais il il
tente il tente le tout pour le tout mais
Ramazan vraiment solide il va avoir le
meilleur départage du tournoi ça c'est
sûr vu qu'il
joue que des que à 27 tout le long en
fait c'est le seul qui peut peut-être un
moment donné s'il gagne B faud qu'il en
gagne beaucoup quand même il va être à
quoi 4 et non mais là il est largué là
c'est fini 7 il va être comme Al resa
ouais mais c'est oui mais gen que lui
s'il fait 3 sur 4 oui bon faut faire oui
bon oui il va pas faire 3 sur qu j'ai
compris Fab j'ai compris où tu voulais
en venir donc marquan il a gagné ça
c'est nul on va fermer les parties petit
à petit je laisse quand même la partie
d'aliireza en bas à droite parce que
j'imagine que c'est un résultat que les
gens demandent ça fait -,7 pour Caro
d'après ce que j'ai vu
bon c'est toujours ça
perdu et dans les parties qui on peut
regarder si tu envie qu'on se fasse un
tour des stad il y a Ker corobof attends
on va juste jeter un au passage vu que
je l'aiit bah toujours très bien mais ah
mais il défend javir donc on peut pas
prendre G7 à Cali
F5 et maintenant avec les blanc les
Noirs je dire il a c'est de P pass dame
qui va essayer de d'avancer mais bon
écoute il y a toujours ce pion h quand
même qui est pion passé qui peut être
gênant bah si s'en sort
bravo tellement foutu ouais mais regarde
le temps quand même qui peut jouer aussi
un visite qui a plus que 7 minutes 30
saon
jamais on a regardé probablement nul
cinder visite on a regardé la table
d'après c'est on a vu avantage blanc
mais bon c'est chaud euh Ker kobof donc
donc bel avantage pour keer mais alors à
quel point c'est gagnant céit ça
question qu'on pourra avoir att attends
faut que je récupère la page Evens en
fait tu nous disais tu nous amenais Fab
vers CER euh C audessus ouis à gauche
ouais bon ça l'air complètement gagnant
c'est
ça on va les récupérer pour pour les
gens donc il a une pièce de plus et il
TG de et bon bon ça a l'air fini alors
attends Ker il en était où il était à 4/
6 et c'était quoi il avait joué 26 30 26
30 26 30 26 60 ok mais départage un peu
pourri mais bon il se remet pas trop REM
et surtout il est
fort CER il se remet très bien d Hatch
qui bah il fait comme Ker en fait il a
gagné déjà kzubov qui a gagné et le
dernier c'était fait CF qui bah qui
suit contre la la révélation duour
contre la révélation du tournoi
ouais voilà après c'est joueurs ouison
après c'est joueurs plus loin qui qui
quelque part peu ESS qui espère un rush
final une REM pe sorti de nulle part bon
qui sait mais ouais qui sont un peu dans
la problématique de mvl quoi au final
exact et ben ou un peu moins pire pour
dou ou quoi qui a trou F5 ouais après F5
c'était ouais c'é obligé c'était
obligatoire c'était pas F5 c'est juste
qu'il vérifie mais c'était 100 % F5
mais écoute je sais pas si c'est bien le
stop mis en place par
par yyangi on va
voir je bien qu'il a gagné quand même
non mais il a vraiment ses
chances dans les appariments ça pourrait
nous donner quoi demain pour Alireza à 4
et dem si tu arrives
à je sais pas du tout tu as pas une
projection Fabes peut-être on peut
regarder nous de notre côté via chess
rel un a
euh parce qu' a 4 et
demi il du monde il va y avoir du monde
parce qu'en fait ceux qui sont à 3 et
demi ils ont tout donné quoi
aujourd'hui il y a pas beaucoup de mecs
à 4 et dem qui ont les n qui monte de
derrière ça peut être
séviant Sant ce serait pas terrible he
ça peut être mais j'ai pas de beaux
appariments à te
proposer il y a peu de mecs qui avaiit
desis
corb va perdre va perdre yangi va
peut-être perdre peut-être ça peut être
yangangi fait
nul et si P ils sontjà jou ou pas non
ouais peut-être pas je sais pas s perd
ou al c'est un mec blanc qui va doubler
il va peut-être jouer contre un mec qui
va doubler les blancs contre lui mais en
fait ah ou mais il y a que des mecs
quand même il est plutôt fort
mais
il va jouer un mec pas mal quand même
mais je pense que Yang a trop d' il va
être il va être maisu les couleur ou
quoi sinon c'est un gars qui
doublera cé qui rapport Douda pour le
moment tu vas pas jouer quand
même tu auras probablement fait CF ça
peut être fa
CF
pasement il sera 4 et
dem
param il fait
quoi pourquoi je le vois pas ça
parti il joue il joue param
et si par gagne il revient dans le
groupe en fait il revient aussi dans les
TR du coup il y a qui qui gagne bon il y
a rapporte Douda ça on l'a dit Levon lon
a gagné d'ailles ouais il va être non
c'est un gros groupe en fait c'est dur
demain tuas pas Grou 4 être plus fort
potentiellement que le groupe A5
quasiment pas tout à fait mais ouais bah
a 5 tu as quoi tu as kzubov quand même
tu vas avoir des Hatch ouais mais tu as
Kana Naka tuas quand mêmeou ouais mais
bon de l'autre côté tu vas avoir rapport
Douda
Levon firou non mais c'est dur c'est
c'tait pas moins fort à 4 et demi qu'à 5
hein ou c'est mais c'est souvent c'est
la problématique de ce tournoi tu as nan
qui revient à 4 et demi aussi j'ai vu
était gagnant oua chearinov contre tar
ça donne quoi
gagnarinov qui monteas que des gens qui
vont
aviran c'est pas par exemple c'est un
bon joueur très bon joueur dangereux
mais il joue vraiment il va pas ser la V
ouis mais il aura probablement pas asse
de pour Al parce qu'il va ê tout en bas
du
truc al il devrait jouer ch ça donn quoi
je toujours je
voir
en jou un ymaz quoi
ouais mais tu auras pasilmaz hein non
Chan il est où il a fait nul l'ami vitof
l'IS c'était plus bas plus haut plus
haut plus haut ils sont
[Musique]
mieux pas euh ça
joue ça joue euh je crois queof doit
être un poil mieux mais
bon peut-être qu'il est bien mieux
peut peut-être gagner alors attends il y
a une gaffe peut-être de l'adversaire de
Baky bon gaffe c'est vite dit ENF c'est
juste pas le coup de l'ordi quoi mais
c'est ro
F7 alors il y a eu quelques coups is
c'est vrai qu'il eu quoi tour B6 G5 F5
fou D4 t
B3 F7 bon il aime pas mais je peux pas
vous dire pourquoi il aime pas il
voulait jouer quoi
F7
faire fou ouais mais bon on peut pas
comprendre enfin je ça se trouve en plus
il dit de la merde l'ordi ouais ouais
c'est possible qu' dit de la merde aussi
donc je peux pas appeler ça une erreur
mais par contre peut-être que son setup
est juste mauvais dans son ensemble ça
c'est une autre histoire peut-être que
H6 G5 il veut quoi il veut tout je juste
voir ce qu'il veut l'ORD il veut ça ça
ça ça ça ça ça je just voir comment il
veut gagner en fait parce que gen
actuellement mais c'est quoi notre plan
après
ouais
ah il il va voloir faire tour B7 en fait
échanger les sacrifice sur B2
ouais ouais ça peut-être une bonne
gueule
ok B c'est pas ro F7 ou par F7 le
problème en tout cas ouais euh et donc
ça voilà pour vous vous compreniez en
fait si on échange les tours après on
peut jouer la finale de roi avec un P de
plus Eton
gagnera et donc c'est peut-être tout son
setup en fait qui va mais je trouve
qu'il a une gueule dégueulasse le c'est
je vouis pas trop dire pourquoi mais là
on vient de voir un
pourquoi c'est stopion F 5 passés
protégés
euh il est trop fort
quoi et enfin là si tu tiens c'est au
coup près on sait pas pourquoi en fait t
B6
ouais c'est obligé en fait mais
maintenant oigé de faire ça il y a
peut-être des réseaux de ma quoi tour
B7 F on peut-être les tours à 7 les
machins ça m infernal en pratique plus
le roi qui peut monterre tu fais roi des
TR pense que ça gagne pour je pense que
B qui va gagner tu vas tu tu feras F6 F5
ou quoi je pense que ça va gagner pour
moi ce truccl devrait gagner ouais
peutêtre l'ordi tiens mais doit tenir
par contre mais mais nous non
ouais tu dois pouvoir faire ro C4
là petit tour des3 ah il y a ah
oui ça c évite
on en tout cas s'il défend qu'il aura
sorti Mo ça va
gagnerur une connerie je pense
aussi al pourquoi gen H3 il aime pas il
fait tour C5 et ça change qu tu fa tour
mainant fait
fou5 oui bon non mais je comprends en
fait ce qu'il aime pas parce que tu dois
pouvoir amener ta tour qui rentre évite
à ce que la tour rentre ouais en ayant
en étant hyper précis tu dois pouvoir
éviter ce serait B à 5/ 7 bah 5/ 7 ce
serait quoi le groupe pour nous dire ce
que Baky peut avoir s'il gagne 5 7 c'est
Naka c'est carwana c'est les mecs comme
ça
non B attends je je vais regarder aussi
c'est c'est V carwana Naka prè de
que
Ker
d Kub ça serait pas dit qu'il joue un
mec si fort au final il pourrait éviter
je tu peux prendre un
semibon un d un CER c'est pas que
semibon c'est bon non mais gre tu peux
tu peux tu peux éviter nakaou Kana oua
qui sont les deux plus forts du tournoi
jusqu'à maintenant en tout cas
ouais tu peux lu
ouvrir
mais en gros je dirais Naka si tu as les
blancs on va attendre que qu'on puisse
on puisse écouter en
fait ouais j'allais dire à Fab Naka le
truc c'est comme il a le le le truc àéo
si tu as les blancs je pense qu'il va
prendre aucun risque Naka il a aucun
intérêt à aller s'envoy aller s'envoyer
en l'air
ouais et vidit il en est où vid
euh ben il devrait gagner en fait je l'
comptais pas dans le groupe je
considérra c victur comme acquise mais
bon il est
vraiment c'est un peu la question hein
ouais c'est une bonne tête quoi je serai
très surpris qu'il gagne pas mais il a
335 on peut peut-être rester un tout
petit peu sur la partie VI dans le sens
où la partie de Baky elle va avancer
doucement mais sûement mais doucement
mais sûrement et là c'est ça va être le
moment décisif parce que je pense que
jacovir sindarov en plus connaiss un peu
les joueurs bec qui doit savoir que sa
chance c'est de mettre la pression jouer
tempo jou tempo ouais bah en fait il
veut H6 pour enlever le pion G7 et
pousser son Pioner lui à Dame et créé un
pion passé enfin c'est maintenant ou
jamais donc en tout cas c'est la menace
euh donc
avite de voir alors ce que nous dit
lordordi c'est que B3 est bien mais B3
c'est peut-être le coup
le F6 moi j'aura h H7 et là faut trouver
B2 tour B8 et là B7 h ouais mais là ça
c'est pas évident à choisir enfin en
fait ok maintenant qu'on voit la
position je comprends on fait B1 et sur
dam 3 prend G6 il y a plus d'échec ouais
mais bon faut y croire bah faut tout
voir faut y croire d'avoir envie de
calculer jusqu'au bout ouis tuas envie
il fait B3 non non mais tu as envie et
puis tu es indien donc c'est calculé
c'est si je commence par T B8
B7
h66 ah j'ai
pas
ouais donc vidit vidit qui s'il a tout
ça va se mettre très
bien dit D5 est bon aussi mais bon vu
que nous on a la partie d'avant je
dis je transpose et je me casse pas la
tête F5 je suppose c'est pas ID parce va
H6 suppose plus on prend
G6 encore finir mais bon tu dois
gagner mais
bon plus clean ouais mais parce queon a
vu qu' pas d'échec à la fin et cetera
c'est c'est plus clean mais faut faut
pas faut pas trembler quoi non faut pas
trembler et il se placerait il se
placera à 5 et demi il prend la tête
peut-être execo mais alors execo avec
qui avec peut-être erig ici si si gagne
si si gagne ouais
faut Fighter ouais ça continue tu fais
B2 il y a ch dame tu fais B1 dame et en
fait bizarrement ton ro F6 il est pas si
mal parce que tu vas prendre en G6 il y
a pas d'échec après le K6 tient
énormément de cases mais c'est
ok ça paraît bizarre quoi mais c'est le
cas en fait c'est juste bon qu'est-ce
que je te
dise
ah mais ici vidit il joue demain tu
penses qu'il joue à fond ouais je pense
ouais il se mettent sur la gueule les
Indiens c'est bien c'est B l'esprit bah
surtout qu'il y en un qui gagne là il
est quasi qualifié
quoi si si et si personne gagne et ben
personne gagne bon ils sont quand même
très bien hein ils sont quand même voilà
ouais minute 20 bah Quiou ouais mais
c'est comment dire il va réavoir la même
occasion d'avoir cette finale après il
joue le il joue la finalevec qui les
trois pions avec F des 5 ouais
faire H6 je pense je vois pas quoi
d'autre tu lair cons F6 tu vas jamais
rien faire
quoi bi B ouais mais B là la partie elle
est c'est pas grave je TR ça change rien
on va voir la finale don on parlait
et juste l'ordi va peut-être empêcher la
tour des1 d'aller sur la 6e s'il fait
que des coups d'ordi
mais et sur E2 fou des fou il t refait
tour C1 en fait il r des deux il repart
ouais mais bon enfin ça va pas être peu
importe trop dur tu peux l'avoir par bol
mais c'est très improbable mais pe
importe tu vas quand même tourner et tu
vas finir pas y arriver quoi que est-ce
que ce setup là tu le laisses pas juste
comme ça ah tu vas faire tour 4 en fait
au
pire ah
sur tu peux l'avoir par pure bol mais ça
M donai personnellement
ouais bon on verra je sais pas qu dire
[Musique]
euh n ouais alors attends Eric g ici i
Penco il se dé
ici il pas encore
gagné tout à gauche
C euh
il a pas joué faire3 j'ai F6 de finir la
partie Mo
mais ouais bon
oui ça G5 je sais pas ça je vois pas
comment on a pas des sport pratiques en
fait moi j'aurais ça ça ça et ça enfin
ouioui je sais pas là c'est fini ouais
tu tiens toutes les cases là fin mais là
il va vraiment gagner VI il y a pas de
trucs bizarres dans cette vente là non
bah je pense qu'il en avait nulle part
en
fait h des trucs
bizarres euh ok non B qui B qui B qui
reste toujours autant favori qu'avant
moi je dirais il a ouais un 50 50 quoi
ouais je moins chance avant mais là
maintenant avec ce c'estuption F5 ça
augmente ouais 5
ouais n cas fait nul Sky
Bobby mais tour C5 en plus je pense tu
peux pas le jouer pour deux raisons par
qu'en plus tu tout à l'heure tu ÉIS cont
tour C7 en
plus il a tout fait pour rester tu dis
tu vas prendre tour B7 aussi ou F6 puis
tu Dris calculer tour
H7 qui donne pas super
envie c'est Torin j'imagine
HM alors l'idée sur reprend ce qui a fou
E3 qui fait très très
mal tist tu as plus tour B6 a mais ouais
bon en fait oui hein mais euh et du coup
t C5 tu peux juste te dire ouaon
pourquoi j'ai ça Dr
cette partie aurait été bizarre he
globalement ouais je des cousus des
euh des fautes ici ou là euh
jamais dramatique dramatique mais
imprécise
euh mais position pas facile est
compliqué très compliqué
ouais donc forcément bon avec l'aide de
l'ordi ou quoi ça aide
quoi euh donc attends céta la c'est
rigisi VO check je pense ça ouais je
pense c'est nul
ouais H6 puis on
prend
voilà j'aime bien le coup de l'ordi
c'est 5 end et en
B7 rest plus 20 secondes pour
vidit mais en fait c'est malin ce que
fait d'un point de vue pratique ce que
fait sinder c'est fait il joue des mais
qui sont
inattendus c'est pas idio en soi peu de
temps et Sophie qui est bien placé chez
les féminin 5è ouais belle victoire
aujourd'hui elle a battu Nino et comment
il
s'appelle je sais plus son nom mais bon
l'autre je Georgienne du coup beau
tournoi très beau tournoi bravo
vidite du coup tuas il avait commencé
avec une défaite contre l'ami en plus
qui fait un gros tournoi après et après
là bah tu goupes ta Colard shirof nul
naar au noir victoire nan victoire sind
c'est en plus il joue il joue des jeunes
il joue des jeunes costaud wou ouais tu
fa shirf au milieu qui est pas jeune
mais qui fait pas un mauvais tour du
tout ner qui est jamais simple à jouer
que c'est un bon joueur naar
donc B qui ça joue toujours pas en face
non ça su je penseil va faire de la la
de en fait
y je le sens je le sens comme ça moi il
est il est glissant là ça glisse ses
mains c'est c'est savonux
quoi et fou E5 c'est quoi le
oui pourquoi pas en fait il enlève le
roi et il veut si la tour s'en va faire
tour des7 t machin ou tour D5 t enin il
va y arriver à 3 chemins quoi h c'est ça
échec et T
B7 bon après en fait ça c'est une autre
question est-ce que ça ça gagne je je
pense que oui en pratique en fait et
peut-être oui tout court d'ailleurs
parce que le roi blanc va pouvoir monter
direction de 6 faire des réseaux de math
on peir des fois des sacrifices sur B2
pour jouer une finale de tour qui
pourrait gagner et cetera et cetera
donc donc je pense que
oui je pense que c'est même plus que 50
% de chance de gain je pense en fait
celle-là
ouais juste je mets 50 % parce que je un
petit chot à tour C5 par hasard
et pourquoi ah ouais et tour C5 et pas
tour C6 parce que tour C6 il y a
tour1 T8 et ça y est on est retouré dans
le même scénario
ouais non je donneraai plus de 50 %
aussi
mais c'est beau qucha il essaye vraiment
bah écoute pourquoi pas peut-être la
chance de sa vie entre guillemets quoi
enfin il est PL tout jeune je il a plus
ou moins mon âge pas le plus jeune je
crois mais
et très bon joueur mais en fait le plus
beau de sa carrière est derrière lui et
puis là il se retrouve là bien placé il
a les blancs une position qui il peut
essayer bah il essaye hein par c'est
vrai que s'il gagne il se il se met pas
mal quoi et en plus il prend pas des
risque démesurer en faisant ça c'està
dire qu'au cas où euh bah il va faire
nul quoi en fait et puis a priori il va
faire nul et puis et puis voilà
sindarof
ouais c'est
finito il va prendre B2 quand même par
principe mais bon F6 prend G6 ouais tu
fais plus rien et le pion va filer tout
seul les viit avec ce qu'il a fait à la
Coupe du Monde il mériterait d'y être en
fait queon il se fait sortir par abasov
c'est pas de bol je CIS que c'est
vraiment pas de bol pour lui le quart de
finale et là il est de nouveau dans les
leaders en faisant un gros tour donc en
soit Jea vidit parmi les joueurs entre
guillemets moins bien classés où je
disais c'est un peu la la lie des
joueurs entre la 50 et 20e place
mondiale je dirais que c'est un peu lui
qui mérite plus que les autres pour moi
mais d'ailleurs en fait c'est un peu
dommage que il soit pas enfin quand tu
vois ça tu dis soit pas invité à
d'autres tournois parce que la race
franchement je vois pourquoi il devrait
être derrière g quoi bah oui parce que
dans les trè les GR
tournois ilit car finale aussi donc
comme lui mais sauf que là
voilà
maxime a fait quoi il a gagné il a gagné
aujourd'hui donc écoute il fait ce qu'il
peut il se
REM bon il est très très loin de des
places pour se qualifier mais écoute
donc c'est le scén qu'on attendait il a
fait H5 et tour 1 ça retombe dans
l'autre truc qu'on avait vu donc nous on
pense que ça doit être gagnant pour Baky
enfin dans pratique mais c'est pas dit
que tu arrives gagnant en pratique je
pas ça va rien dire mais que en pratique
a de très bonnes chances de gain
ouais après euh il y a beaucoup d'heures
de jeu le tournoi est
fatiguant il peut se passer des choses
il peut se passer beaucoup de choses
hein bah perdre non mais euh mais nul
c'est possible hein bien sûr mais tu as
raison je mettrai plutôt 60 40 pour
bcky il reste 6 minutes ouais mais
encore le rajou au 60 et puis là c'est
une position ah bah oui encore 15
minutes au 60e quand même ok ok il a
fait GH
ouais mais c'est hyper logique aussi en
ouais je m'y attendais pas parce que
j'aais bien l'autre plan qu'on voit
depuis tout à l'heure mais il a pris bon
en tout cas ça te donne un pion passé en
H et d' j ton F après bon bien sûr la
structure est beaucoup plus disloquée
mais là lei il aime pas parce que il
donne roi G7 roi H6 et roi prend H5 mais
il a pas trouvé il fait un autre coup
pourquoi pas enfin ro G7 ro6
c'était c'était logique aussi hein non
mais tout est logique en fait mais ro F6
pourquoi pas comme ça
quoi mais après c'est vraiment dur quand
on a l'évaluation de l'ordi à côté de
réfléchir ouais là tu sais que6 c'est tu
dis oui en fait il va protéger le
pion tuas
H6 je sais pas comment dire en fait
avais pas les vales de l'ordi tu serais
pas du tout dit ça je sais pas si je
serais dit mais tu sais pas en fait
j'aurais pas mis une croix rouge comme
ça de but en blanc en tout
cas on est obligé d'avoir les croix
rouges et compagnie non mais j'aime bien
c'est joli
c'est joli mais ouais mais genre tuas
une CIX rouge tu es content non
ouais mais je peux l'enlever he si tu
veux j'ae bien non mais là en fait je
veux pas que tuèv mainant sera pour
demain ou quoi on verra ouais mais
regarde c'est quand même plus sympa avec
la
croix surtout que des fois ça veut rien
dire bah là ça veut peut-être pas oui
mais ce que dire c'est pour ça que je
laisse c'est ce que je dis aux gens moi
sur sur mon live j'enlève évidemment la
la jauge mais j'ai je laisse parce que
des fois ça des fois c'est vrai des fois
c'est un peu au hasard
quoi ça fait une animation quoi tuas
rouge ouais bon ok
ENF bon spring aime bien ils sont
nombreux aimer bon bah écoutez vous
aimez bien vous aimez bien non je juste
dire que en fait tu vois ça tu dis c'est
un coup de merde et puis ça ça te met le
cerveau surf en fait tu ches plus rien à
comprendre ouie façon tu as la jauge gen
en fait que tu l' tu l'ai pas oui mais
en fait non mais là en plus c'est beau
regarde
ouchaation Croix Rouge Croix Rouge Croix
Rouge Croix
Rouge la jauge en fait tu peux ne pas
trop la voir parce que tu as les yeux
focus sur les chiquers tuas un petit
truc là-bas et la moi ça m' arrivé que
c'est un stroboscope dans la tête quoi
moi ça m' arrivrivé que pour le seul
coup il m deux points d'exclamation ah
bah oui peut-êre laissé une pièce en
prise ou quoi et une fois je sais pas
pourquoi il a bug il a mis deux points
d'interrogation sur le meilleur coup pas
tou toujours sûr
quoi donc moi je dis ça fait très
plaisir
fa il rest m 11 coup àtienne en moins de
5 minutes là normalement tu peux jouer
des coups histoire de jouer tourner en
rond mais peut-être que faire de pas pas
laisser un échappatoire te faire bouffer
les pions ou je ne sais
quoi en fait c'est bizarre fait GH vite
mais bon peut-être avec de tempsutêtre
qu'il fatigue
aussiutre
Mach vra dire
logiquef point
d'exclamation il jamais tranquille
normal en
faitour se
coup je pense que ça peut gagner en
fait moi je moi Jeur serais parti pour
tour H7 personn ou je pense c'est tour
B4
non il y a roi D3 ou tour B4 en tout cas
je veux taper le fou pour les vers
B6 et ça c'est bon
quoi ça ça gagne c'est
sûr du coup euh ouais tch je me dit on
va taper le fou et on fait le truc et
tour A7 H6 tour à 2 W tour 1 on va dire
7 ou pas je sais rien je plutôt faire
roi2 personnellement
euh ah il é change et reprend F5 ok ça
j'avais je enfin j'avais l'idée en tête
je disais ça ça peut faire nul parce que
ça ouais
on attaque pas le fou et là il fait ro
G6 et là il fait fou
G7 je crois qu'il a rien vu non plus
hein là je crois que c'est vraiment du
hche là c'est vraiment du hasard il a un
quart d'heure pour trouver aller mettre
la tour 1 c'est pas c'est pas impossible
à trouver quand même ouais moi fou5 à
tour B6 c'est ça bah je pense tu as pas
envie hein de en fait il a fait ro F6
c'est pour venir s'attacher au pion F5
et attaqué moi j'ai l'impression qu'il a
jouer vraiment trop vite mais bon ça
ouais mais ça tu peux avoir envie quand
même parce que tu dis que tu menaces fou
F4 c'est sacrifi dessusre tu faire
tourser
ouais mais c'est complètement con parce
que tu vas repartir de l'autre
côté je pense qu'il a super mal joué en
fait 5 tu peux faire mais bon et tour à
7 alors ça fait vraiment genre nul ou
juste on a mal fait jouer blanc ave tin
con ça tenir ça H7 quand même direct
l'ordi plutôt que ce que nous fait 7
tour B7
su de
mais il a pas perdu
F5 beaucoup idot quoi
ok bon tour à de pourquoi pas enfin ça
sert pas grand chose mais je comprends
il te fait bouger le roi il va revenir
en
un enfin j'ai l'impression que tu vas te
prendre un jour un genre de roi F2 B j'
qu'on est pas loin d'être mat hein mais
euh moi je pense que ça gagne
ouais ils disent que Touras 7 c'est
gagnant peut-être qu'ils ont des grosses
turbines pour analiser donc c quoi
c'était roi G7 pour faire nul mais
est-ce que ça fa vraiment nul d'ailleurs
mais en fait si la mieux fait en fait je
sais pas comment dire F6 tu le fais pour
gagner F5 et si tu gagnes pas F5
évidemment c'est une connerie quoi mais
en fait j'ai l'impression que tu es tu
as les mêmes variantes mais avec un ou
de temp de plus bah siil H5 tu es moins
mal que sil en H7 et tu H8 et les réseau
de
mat h
donc mais tu vois à 5 tu vois tu as
prête que
kzubof kzubof c'est c'est le Bel
appareilement à 5 hein alors kzubof il a
un petit h faut pas pour un idiot il
était je pense qu' était 26 50 15 16 ans
aussi moi je pense que you il est
complètement à côté ouais il a l'air il
a l'air il a l'air d'être KO debout
quoi imagine B candidat bah c'est s'il
gagne aujourd'hui ça ça rentre dans le
domaine du possible en fait ce sera pas
probable encore pour le
moment mais ça rentre dans le dans le
domaine du possible
après ce qui est dur c'est que tuas
quand même des mecs à 5 et demi machin
qui restent
devant chaud quoi ah non tu commences à
être tu tu es dans tu es dans le bon
wagon quoi ah tu es là où tu dois être
pour y arriver ça veut pas dire que tu
vas le faire à coup sûr mais
tu Maxim a 4 tu vois il revient 20e là
a mais il son un peu plus loin il a qure
avant d'autres a marqué leurs points
quoi ils actualisent le classement en
marquant des points P d'autres sont à
zéro pendant qu'il joue mais il va être
30e allez
ouais bah qu'il aura un bon départage
pas le meilleur mais il aura dans il
sera dans les bon départages bah il joue
quand même une belle moyenne hein ouais
ouais il on dit gu c'est compliqué sa
game tout seul sans contrepartie ouais
mais c'est ce qu'on expliquit tout à
l'heure en fait le truc c'est que lui
doit être à 5 aussi il le sait très bien
qu' a qu enfin qu'il est short et il a
voulu prendre trop de risque après
ou où il a juste mal joué et on on sur
interprète c'est
o nous on donne un sens à ce qu'on voit
ce qu'on croit voir hein mais
bon mais tout nous laisse penser ça son
choix d'ouverture alors qu'en fait il
joue la Petrov quasi tout le temps
Petrov pour faire nul clairement
euh et certains moments de la partie où
il a donné la qualité ou quoi il était
pas obligé ça laisse penser que c'était
son son ambition
quoi
c'est pas sûr
mon qui Magnus marché sur le tournoi
regarde le dernier tournoi comme ça
qu'il a joué
suratar il a perdu il a perdu
contre contre je sais plus canadien là
quiant il a perdu contre le kazak il a
fini
loin pas du tout été en position de le
tournoi donc il aurais pu marcher sur le
tournoi évidemment tu peux pas mettre ça
de côté
mais
c'est le même pot mais il a changé de
nationalité il joue pour l'Espagne il
vient en Espagne maintenant je sais pas
sil vient Malaga je crois qu'il vient
Malaga je tour à 7
H6 que tour à 2 est
malin on fait tour maintenant H7 c'est
[Musique]
ça ça quandme une super bonne gueule
ça ça revient à la même position en
fait
on fait quoi là si il fait que répéter t
de T déjà
OK et
tin tour D1 tour a
2 tu F3 après bar et et et là le
problème c'est que tu as ça et ça et mat
ok je pense ça va gagner avec un truc
comme ça moi ouais
ça va tenir ça va tenir ça va tenir que
là en fait tu as plus F F6
ouais parce que tour des D7 et tour B8
moi je pense que ça va gagner avec un
truc comm ça avec un tel roi pourri
ouais
ouis et je pense qu'il va même pas faire
tour à 7 à cause de ça mais tu joues
qu bah je sais pas justement c'est pour
ça qu' réfléchit tu as pas de coup en
fait et tour C6 genre si tu te dis ça
c'est de nouveau H6 j'imagine tu te dis
que tu vas essayer de faire ça H7 ça et
ça tour B7 de toute façon tu te le
prends pareil ouais c'est la même
variante en
ais en peu différence mais ouai bon
scénario mais il a fait fou 5 F 5 donc
on y a pensé c'était pour aller vers F4
c'est ça ouais mais B6 ouais mais on
cétait dit que c'était complètement con
ouais tu coupes le roi puis H6 oui H6
très
bien je pense ça va gagner B je pense B
qui va faire tour B6 sans hésitation en
fait tu veux pas laisser fer une
couvercle avec F F4 ouais donc ça
c'est'est joué voà très vite d'ailleurs
normal ça je pense c'est
gagné je suppose
hein après on peut pas être sûr mais là
je pense que ça va je pense c'était ro
F6 la l'erreur
ouais au ver G7 et peut êre tout le
setup hein tuétait mieux avec ton P HC
jus au début que d'avoir fait ce machin
ou al il va pas encore
abandonner mais il doit pas être loin là
quand même d'abandonner à mon avis il su
quoi je
pense mais aussi faut dire he comme tu
disais quand tu joues vraiment le gain
psychologiquement c'est encore plus dur
de défendre bah tu es dégoûté tu es
dégoûté
ouais
là il est dégoûté je
pense h il va faire roi F7 tour F3
est-ce que est-ce qu'il peut essayer
qu'est-ce qu'il peut essayer encore pour
défendre pas grand-chose à mon
avis le pionche maintenant il part aussi
en fait
ouais il tu tire le roi là-bas
h al fou D4 il revient admettons genre
est-ce que tu vois il peut essayer de
revenir en F6 ah donc tu attaques la
tour ok tu peux pas aller en B4 il a F
C3 donc dis donc que tu reviens en B5 je
sais pas comme ça tu protèges un peu t
ti ton roi alors est-ce que je remets
mon roi
ou est-ce que j'en profite pour pour
partir là-bas
ouais peut-être qu'on le RO maintenant
on va versus
tuas les tour B7 aussi maintenant h
ouais je pense je pense que ça gagne
ça mais tellement bizarre ce qu'il fait
you il est complètement euh bah j'ai
l'imession qu'il joue au coup par coup
qu' a pas de Lian dans
ouais dans ses positions non ce qui non
mais B quiil là il va faire tour F3 tour
B3 c'est sûr bah ouais ou H6 hein c'est
pas con H6 ou H6
ouais et euh juste pour savoir erizi
erit est-ce que c'est
signé erigizi c'est je crois que c'est
une très belle partie en fait ouais ça
fight à fond très compliqué depuis un
moment et les deux se une grosse partie
vocheck euh mais ça joue en
fait ok
bon cétait
[Musique]
quoi qui prend la tête à l'heure
actuelle peut être seul en tête il peut
être en tête et donc monter un kwana ou
un
Naka il avait quelle couleur il av noir
et avoir les
blan tout le monde ENF ça va faire nul
c'est censé faire nul mais viit celui
monte son Go verage Naka il reste en
course s balancer des points et l' trop
il aura les blancs deux fois les blancs
sur trois pour finir donc c'est et puis
lui pour son départage c'est pas mal
aussi parce qu'il va jouer à 272 donc
ouais il est content ça arrange tout le
monde ouais c'est que B qui est-ce qu'il
y a un monde où il peut même jouer
faible demain bizarrement genre est-ce
qu'il peut tomber sur un cou s'il gagne
ah bah peut-être après tu vois parce
qu'en plus dans les appar peutêtre a des
mecs déjà joué d'autres qui peuvent pas
qui doivent ouais ouais mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'en plus ça m'étonne
ri mais bon ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en plus bcky il a pas un si petit hlo
final parce qu'on a vu qu'il y av pas
mal de
mecs bah par exemple un VO il a plus
d'élo que lui ou pas c'est pas
loin un point de moins ouais donc tu
vois il peut peut-être à ce jeul être
être être apparé
ouais en fait là où je suis confiance
c'est que je crois que maintenant à peu
près tout gagne pour les blancs
ouais il peut être le plus faible des
for Bak et du coup se prendre kzubov ce
qui serait vraiment bien et je pense que
c'est dans le domaine du
possible tour D1 alors pourquoi c'est
une faute ah parce qu'il y a de nouveau
le fou des4 ouais mais je pense pas que
il va pas le faire ah quoi que fou4 là
ça attaque la tour en
oui tu fais
choisir un peu semi bizarre TZ on va
dire H6 fout D4 du coup tu fais tour B3
disons tu fais pas tour B4 on a il
revient ah et tu peux ah voilà c'est ça
tu retourbes dans cette position là mais
en fait que l'autre a pas de base maisil
a compris que6 c'est trop
pourri kuzubov c'est un joueur en fait
je pense que si Baki joue contre kuzubov
avec les Noirs ce serait parfait parce
que kzubov avec les Blancs il va essayer
ENF il sait que il doit gagner à tout
prix pour aller au candidat et je pense
que c'est un mec qui il va pas te faire
le chantage à la nulle ou quoi il va
jouer à fond je pense ou il est plutôt
solide comme joueur mais oui mais je le
vois pas j'ai les blancs j'ai 60 points
l' de moins enfin ah non non mais il va
jouer pour gagner mais contre un AK par
ex je suis pas sûr qu'il va se en
l'air mais bon bon écoute on n pas là
déjà faut gagner celle-là faut jouer C
buff demain après il y a beaucoup
de moi je la vois tellement gagné
celle-là moi c'est plus tour C1 qui
m'inquiète mais il se trouve que ça
marche pas grâce à h6 mais fou des4
après une fois que tu l'as vu tu dis oui
ben je renlève la tour de la 6e et je
reviens avec le roi c'est hyper logique
mais ça pas l'air d'être son plan du
tout je crois qu'il est complètement à
côté et en plus fou des4 sur tour D6 tu
as peut-être tour C1 quand même mais
peut-être il va retomber dessus parce
que pas le choix enfin si tu mets à la
poubelle au ro ro F6 ouais mais il a
plus que 5 minutes à mon avis il voit
plus
rien dans le groupe à 4 points il y a
beaucoup de parties décisives ouais et
Riga ici ça je crois que c'est vraiment
une super belle partie ouais Penco il se
ouais bah même la position est belle il
partout ouais tu sens qu'ils sont ils se
sont envoyer de
partout mais semenko a l'air d'avoir
repris la forme ouais il rejoue bien
paril jouit mal pendant longtemps pas
mal mon tempsin pour pour ce qui avit
montré jusqu'à
alors demain il a intérêt à prendre la
nul avec ouais demain il faut faire nul
avec les Noir et après ça te laisse deux
fois les blancs quand même encore à
moins que tu doubles tu fais des
chantages tout le temps en fait tu fais
des chantages ouais en fait B qui il
faut toujours qu'il fasse des chantages
à la nul c'est qu'il va avoir les blancs
contre un mec à 27 etcal qui va jouer la
Calif au candidat bah tu met tu gardes
le bu tu dis ok tu veux gagne essaye
quoi essaye ouais gagner B perd en fait
ouais c'est ça donc by lui il peut faire
ça jusqu'à la fin du tournoi et sur un
malentendu il peut il peut gagner et
passer en fait c'est quoi l'idé de tour
D1 je sais pas trop mais bon fou4 il va
pas trouver j'ai l'impression en fait
qu'ils sont que la position est très
compliquée que nous on a les turbines du
coup on a compris ce qu'il fallait faire
donc ça nous paraît maintenant logique
mais je crois que
sinon tu comprends rien en fait tu
comprends rien
tu
et je pense que tu peux rajouter encore
une heure et il comprendrait quand même
rien parce qu'avec la fatigue qui
s'additionne la complexité de la
position bon il a fait fou des4 mais
j'ai envie de dire ça c'est un peu le
coup facile tour B3 tempo maintenant il
faut qu'il trouve G7 G7 ouais il fait
ref il repart dans son setup qui marche
pas en fait ouais il s'enfer dedans
h il C à côté ou il revient en fait ils
vont répéter B qui fera pas tour un une
deuxième fois bah qui va trouver en fait
peut-être que Nilan trouve mais que par
la force des choses ouais je pense qu'il
va gagner par la force des
choses est-ce quecart de niveau entre B
mvel est si grande que ça ouais quand
Maxime est en forme il est nettement
plus fort mais après faut-il encore être
en forme au bon
moment et cette année ça a pas été le
cas pour Maxime que ce soit la Coupe du
Monde ou
ou ici au grand Suisse il a jamais eu sa
meilleure forme il a eu
ça bonne forme sur d'autres tournois qui
étaient plus mineurs après le champon
celui où il a le plus de
caillas parce qu'en fait celui où il a
battu Carlsen il y a plus d'argent qu'en
gagnant le grand Suisse ouais donc en
gros c'est beaucoup moins prestigieux en
terme de prestige Maxime il est un peu
tombé à côté par contre en terme
financier il a il a fait les résultats
qu'il fallait au moment où il fallait on
va dire ça comme ça donc il refait tour
B6 3 F7 et bon là il va trouver ferapp à
tour ouais là il va il va trouver faire
F3 mais soit il va faire H6 ouais il va
trouver là je suis quand même étonné que
yuyangi il estit pas compris qu' pas
com7 après il est vraiment il com
peut-être qu'il comprend pas qu'il est
mal enfin il comprend qu'il est pas bien
mais que il sait pas à quel point c'est
la
merde peut-être qu'il y a un truc qu'on
voit pas très franchement et peut-être
que tour j'ai peut-être compris ce qu'
pas tour F1 fou F4 roi E2 tour C2
regarde roi D3 tour D2 il y a peut-être
une ligne comme ça
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont peur d'un
truc je sais ni quoi ni où mais
peut-être tu as l'impression de te
prendre des échecs et que tu perds le
contrôle de la première rangée j'en sais
rien je dis une connerie
mais bon il a joué H6 ok très bien c'est
le coup qu'on voulait en onou tour F3
mais H6 ça plus normal tour F3 plus
compliqué je
trouve biscoté t F3 parce que je sais
pas bon roi G8 ça va être joué non et
puis on va mettre le roi ko là-bas et
puis puis c'est tout quoiou ah alors je
pense qu'il veut défendre avec le rang
H7 fait fou
F4 ça
pourri il est complètement à côté
quoi alors attends peut-être qu'il veut
roi D3
pourquoi pas ro tour C2 tu ouais toute
façon je vais faire tour
C1 c'est ça qui
veut pour
défendre on a fini par
comprendre
alors t
B7 G8
H7 h truc qu'on voulait mettre en place
tout à l'heure qu'il est pas bon là mais
parce que 2 tour C2 il va revenir
ok peut-être pas H7 mais l'ordi il
faisait quoi
savoir qu'il fait j'ai compris comment
il fait en fait il fait ça il fait
ça je fais ça peut-être ça mais bon va
être F ouais je sais pas comment il fait
bon dire de vas-y on va jouer C coup
tour
C2 mais il fait ro d TR quand même tour
C1 il doit y avoir un truc où il faut
une plus grosse profondeur pour
comprendre attends tu peux pas faire ça
ça ça pr j'ai7 ça ça pr
non
ouais heureusement qu'il a les 15
minutes de rajout là pour
Baky parce qu'il va aller récup les 15
minutes j' pens final 15
minutes fait tu les aurais pas tuur
peut-être pas affiché autant
avant et tour H 2 sur3 donc ro3 tour C1
il y a un truc qui nous échappe qui doit
pas être si
dur mais
je
j'ai pas t B7 3 G8 32 il fait fou5 truc
non mais il faut qu'il fasse échaque
tout le temps avec
les qui gagne il a craqué notre ami
kazak
c'est une info de
chat je sais pas là je vois pas le gain
moi moi-même en fait
mais on essaie de
comprendre en fait je veux bien croire
qu'il y a un gain enfin ça se voit que
ça peut
gagner attends et si j'ai une idée
bizarre tour C1
F6 t prend F5
H7 ah T3 t H3 ouais mais si j'avais la
même avec le roi mieux placé si je peux
on va voir bah qui qui refait roi 2 tour
C2 mais là il va récupérer le temps
ouais donc il va réfléchir heureusement
qu'il y a le temps hein
moi je dis à toutes les les les étoiles
qui qui s'alignent pour que toutes les
planètes s'alignent pour que bil la
gagne chercher mon ordi pour poser la
question turbine for c'est mieux de non
mais juste parce pour qu'on sache quoi
bon moi je préfère vivre le truc en
direct et puis si on trouve tant mieux
enfin parce que sinon en fait on va
avoir le truc on va savoir
instant oui les étoiles s'alignent parce
que je pense que sans le temps en plus
il il trouverait pas en fait mais je
sais même pas si ça gagne moi en fait
alord dit donne plus 340 donc si
8 F6 pu
F7
H77
H7 on
prend juste
vérifier cette position une fois et de
fois
ouais donc là roi D3 tour C1 ro 2 tour
C2 roi D3 tour C1 tu peux pas faire ro
2 mais tu peux faire tomber ces déch tu
jouer un coup qui change un truc et
c'est pas trois fois la même position
ouais mais bon de toute façon tu vas
devoir trouver
là pourquoi il joue pas tour C ça
la partie elle me dépasse en fait je
sais qu'elle est très compliquée et que
et que et queon ferait pas mieux et si
tu fais tour C1 tour B7 roi F8 F6
d'abord ah ouais c'est de nouveau le
même truc et TU3 t H3 oui mais jeouess t
B8 pour avoir je disis tour B8 tu fais
ro F7 je fais H7 tu fais enfin bon ça
marchait pas du tout mais pourquoi il
fait pas tour c'est un tempore qu'il a
cru qu'il a le temps il est parti pisser
quoi la partie me dépasse en
fait
mais en fait du coup si ça c'est si fort
comme je vois pas de gain c'est bizarre
du coup de
fa parce que pas VO autre
chose
réfléchiour ce que je sais c'est que si
tu as pas les 30 minutes de plus tu
trouvve pas 15
minutes
Jes pas lesvion de l'ordi
quoi c'est juste qu'on trouve
pas ah il part par là-bas bonchec
et sur tour
C1 non sur C2
pardon
rang tu ramè en fait c'est ça en
fait làbas en fait mais du coup je fais
tour
[Musique]
C3 G3
mais ok c'est histoire déjà plus là nous
embê le plus ou mais ça reste pas
gagnant ça ouis alors est-ce que c'était
mieux avec une tour B7 ou je sais pas
quoi
avant
mais qu'il a
compris oui tu do faire
t les étoiles
salign que je veux dire que ça aurait
pas été le 60e pens tour tour C2 est
nul je pense que B qui va la gagner il y
a trop de trop d'élément trop d'éléments
positifs
combinés mais bon après combien m façon
tu rentres
làdedans parce que je dire là au moins
tu récupères quand même un pion qui est
pas si anecdotique que ça parce que tu
contrôles la colonne hmm et sur tour D1
euh je pas tu fais ce que tu peux quoi
tu pries pour pas être mat
ouais tu es loin d'être mat en
fait parce que il y a pas la case B8
contrôlé si tu décales la tour il y a
dame de l'autre côté et tu as le drit
qui va repartir sur la première rangée
tu pourras un échec en bre donc à
va dire tu es loin d'être mat aussi
enfin mais bon après ça ça peut perdre
enfin VO là il y a fou3 mais pourquoi il
a pas fou 3 le coup d'avant peu importe
mais oui en fait je en plus là tu mets
la tour sur une mauvaise
case donc quand tu fais t prends H3
enfin à vrai dire là ça c'est chaud hein
h tu peux même la gagner avec les Noirs
d'ailleurs enin ou il faut vraiment que
les Blancs exagèrre oui mais mais dans
la fatigue le
machin je comprends pas ce qu'il fout je
comprends rien à ce qu'ils font il a 2
minutes en tout cas mais je pense qu'ils
sont juste
épuisés je pense qu'ils sont juste au
bord de l'épuisement la partie elle dure
depuis tu es déjà à 6h de jeu il fait
tour les deux il a complètement changé
de
setup pourquoi il fait
ça mais pourquoi en
fait mais trouve que ça ça perd en
force roi C3 il veut tour H2 mais je
comprends ce qu'il veut en fait sur tour
1 il a fou D2 et sur tour D1 il veut
faire fou
E5 mais roi C4 non je sais pas moi je
comprends pas ce qu'il veut en fait
mais il veut ce qu'il veut
[Musique]
hein à vrai dire tu vasir la même
position avec le roi F2 qui était hyper
mal placé tu non mais en plus là tu peux
te reprendre les deux tors sur la
colonne B qui sont bien doublés qui te
prennent tout et le roi qui va venir
aider euh ben non mais il est plus
lucide he Yang je enfin je sais pas il
fait trop de décision très bizarre mais
alors après comme je te dis N a l'ORD
dit et je sais
pas bon tour C1 c'est enfin je sais pas
tu étais en train de faire ça à priori
tu as réfléchi 1000 an avant quand tu
avait ton H5 et compagnie enfin j joue
ton truc quoi c'est hallucinant et cela
dit ça devait peut-être quand même
perdre si avit tous les coups trouvé par
les blancs mais c'est même pas clair
clair ah même nous avec le petit turbine
franchement c'était compliqué comme
position dans mais tour C1 ça perdait je
vois pas la suite de la phrase
ouais ça avait l'air de perdre peut-être
mais mais moins que ça en
fait après on on verra mais ouais il
peut plus facilement mettre en place un
truc bien et en fait ettienne c'est la
tour F1 il va ouais tu la ramènes sur la
colonne D puis B
dou tour F3 ici paraît
logique je suis assez d'accord peut-être
qu' veut tour rche là ilend
ilend bon bon si on fait une dernière
petite pause pendant le quart d'heure
laisser réfléchir et on revient pour la
fin de la partie moi je pense ça va
jouer
vite moi je fais pause tu fais pause
mais vite fait hein vas-y le
fable c'est quoi t sur les 7 euh je
crois qu'on faisait du Roy G8 et
tout mais ro 2 tour C2 ouais non on a on
a regardé un truc de l'ordi mais ça nous
paraissait moins clair que ça en fait
nous ce qu'on avait comme ligne mais
après nous on a un tout petit ordi hein
donc il est pas très fort mais nous on
avait ça comme
ligne et où toi tu faisais tour
des1
tu fais tour B7 3 G8 d'abord ok si tu
veux nonous on av ça comme variante en
fait on a regardé ça pendant un moment
ah et là tu as tour D1
ok Mathieu il a montré pourquoi ça gagné
dans cet ordre là ça va
gagner et si sur tour B7 d'abord on
avait fait ouais bon j'en sais plus rien
et si on avit fait roi F6 du coup il y
avait H7 ok
ouais bon tu la montré je te remontre
pas j'ai la flemme non mais compris comm
je suis arrivé à la
fin c'est pour ça que N trouvit pas fait
pas7 c'est pour ça les planètes salin
pour by qu' aurait peut-être pas trouvé
non plus làf il avait pas du tout quoi
il cliqu les coup pe au hasard
ou mais ça il devrait gagner quand même
c'est une bonne
tête donc tour D1 c'est sûr que c'est le
coup il y a roi des4 aussi en
vrai ro4
ci c'est000 fois
logiqueon j'attends F6 du coup ah mais
F3 après oui c'est bien joué aussi
ouais ro F6 ro F6 tu peux faire tour F3
je suppose
pourprs il a
ok F
[Musique]
ça va arriver à gagner ouais c'est sûr
je sais pas si Carana en
train gagner c'est grand mot mais d'être
menaçante
pour il va gagner çati
oua c'est son son
rayon technique comme ça de trouver le
truc safe tuux juste cliquer
de
que je vois que ça bouge tu vois enfin
je sais pas trop quoi dire mais évolue
tout le temps
et on s'en fout enfin on reviendra mais
c'est pas fait
ici euh
[Musique]
ouis c'est de bien tenir ça quand
même sont
solides qui
gagne ça changera des
trucs ça changera des trucs bah il a pas
encore gagné hein non mais
bon F6 jouit normal et on se pose la
question de quoi tour F3 ouais tour F3
c'est pareil hyper
fort parce que j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait si tu fais ça ça et ça en fait H7
comment tu l'arrêtes le pion ah tu dois
faire tour D1 ouais mais ça TR 2 tour D8
ok bonne
tête mais bon tu doas calculer pour
savoir c'est oui c'est une très
bonnement
oua non je sais pas enfin l'ordi donne
un peu mieux au blanc mais moi quand je
regardais comme ça je savais pas trop
non plus hein je vois juste ça a bien
bougé par rapport une position qui l'air
assez stable assez égale et que ça peut
tourner un peu dans les deux sens
que H7 ça paraî plus fort que T
[Musique]
B3 quand
Mme qui
jou c'est
bien
donc ça 5 il l'
ramené pere 3 D3 c'est bien en
faitempêche la tour deevenir vers
[Musique]
D8 fa peut-être tour H1 H7 tour D1 va y
aller
mais
ou att TR c'est pas
mal il va gagner B qui c'est sûr ça rend
petit à petit
ouais en plus il joue taim
pas mais là cette fois se met pas mal
autant non mais là là le truc c'est
qu'en plus il y a tous les coups qui
gagnent donc je suis all je suis assez
confiant il a récupe du temps il chatte
ouais bah il a c'est ce que je disais il
a les étoiles qui s'alignent donc sur
les coups sur tout
quoi donc c'est
parfait faudra avoir le bon appariment
demain avec les Noirs il fait G4 ouais
j'étais en train d'y penser mais ça
c'est perdu c'est
sûr on peut pas juste prendre bah je
pense que si hein tour B6 on t'échange
les tours al ça il y a
Tourche H7 3 G5 W
ok c'est un de piège tu peux
tomber dedans mais peut-êtreétienne va
se méfier
du du coup H7 direct ro G5 F6 F6 ça ça
termine sur le
champ il va trouver non non bien sûr
mais c'est juste faut pas te précipiter
sur H Pranger
ça mal tu dis prends H6 bon je
fais tour B6 je t'échange c'est fini le
truc c'est un peu trop téléphoné c'est
pour ça que ça a pas marché mais il va
trouver là c'est
sûr comment dire le piège est vicieux
mais il est pas forcément attends j'ai
attends un truc ça
ça ça
ça éche F6 tu dois devoir faire T5 et tu
reprends F6 par échec ou sil r H4 toute
façon il bloque
ouais le piège il
est fou5 t prend5 bah on fera tour F on
fera ce qu'on veut quoi
même ok heureusement que qu'il a
eu le rajou he B que le rajout servait à
rien franchement là il a une utilité non
mais ça sert jamais à rien mais je dire
on pourrait s'en passer et tu jouerais
un peu plus vite avant et
et
euh non il va trouver ceorv c'est pas
trop dur après
peutêre t B6 échque avant peut-être
G5 t
G6 mais bon tu as pas envie avec le pion
B que tu do quand même aller contrôler
G4 H5
G1 mais ok c'est moins convainquant que
l'autre enfin peut-être tu fais tu
gagnes mais si fait ro H5 agg et tu
repars aussi non mais ça va il va
trouver non il y a beaucoup de choses
qui marchent bien
hein you qui se lève ouais mais y il
doit être dépité bah il se lève de toute
façon qu'est-ce tu veux faire d'autre
youu je pense qu'il est dégoûé parce
qu'il ben en fait il a pris tous les
risques
et ça a mal tourné dans ces cas-là tu es
souvent dégoûté moi les parties comme ça
j'étais
dégoûté parti que j'ai perdu comme ça ça
m'a toujours mis se levelos va
gagner en fait donc lui aussi il sera
dans le groupe de
points et toute la clic non mais en fait
il va faire soit tour B6 soit H7 les
deux gagnent il va faire l'un ou l'autre
là j'ai vraiment aucun doute
ouais qui quiélimine deux fois ouais non
mais dans parce qu'en fait tu dis bon
j'aurais juste joué pour nul j'aurais
fait nul
j'ai forcé toute la game mais c'est le
risque he enfin personne personne t'a
forcé à le faire je te dis pas le
contraire mais je dis-moi ça les
quelques Games où j'ai fait ça ça m'a
foutu il a fait H7
ça m'a toujours foutu plus le seum que
en perdant
perdant donc je qui se
lève F6 et tour B5 échec et ça ser B ce
sera fini ouais
ouais il va faire F F6 quand même et t
B5
échec tu as l'impression de perdre
contre toi ben en fait tu as
l'impression que tues Cho enfin tu t'es
mis dans ta dans la merde tout seul
enfin c'est toujours pareil hein après
quand tu gagnes tu es très fier de toi
tu oui j'ai très bien fait de prendre
des risques et puis quand tu perds mais
quand tu perds tu as un peu un peu plus
le se mais B c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a
ça prendre des risques si ça gagn à
chaque fois tu risquer c'est ça serait
plus des risques bah c'est pour ça que
la dernière fois contre Maxime en fait
quand il avait joué la dernière ronde du
Grand Suisse Siou il avait pris aucun
risque
h donc après après tuis un peu à ce à ce
à ce jeulà mais pour le faire en fait
d'après les conseils de Murtas il le
fait un peu tôt dans le tournoi duangi h
à vrai dire tu fa au dernier moment
quand tu as plus le choix benah en fait
tuas les blanc encore demain et puis
après tu as les Noirs si tu reprends les
noirs et si tu fais TR sur TR tu te
qualifies donc normalement d'après la
théorie de Murtas tu dois attendre le D'
mur
ouais surtout qu'en fait si tu gagnes au
blanc tu auras encore enfin là tuas pas
besoin de for tu pas besoin de forcer
donc d'après la théorie de Murtas tu
dois attendre le dernier moment c Thor
rouskov donc là B qui va faire tour B5
c'est sûr et ça va être
abandon
donc les amis on se retrouvera nous
après demain en espérant en espérant un
bon appariment B qui aura les Noirs donc
normalement je pense pas qu'il puiss dou
les blancs non il a eu les blancs une
fois de plus que les noirs ou parce que
là il a doublé les blancs donc il a 2 3
4 blanc donc il aura les noirsah faudra
faire nul demain et après espérer sur
les trois dernières faire un be un be
rush
après fa parti de la gestion de tour de
savoir aussi qu switch bah you je sais
pas pourquoi il s'est senti dans
l'urgence il s'est senti dans l'urgence
clairement et caroana et
caroana il peut se passer des choses il
peut la gagner ou la perdre en fait nul
reste plutôt envisageable
mais mais on verra je pas trop vous
dire lui fait les candidats je crois
qu'il les a fait une fois donc
normalement il devrait y avoir Baky et
non by by va être à 5 Paron je dire à 5
et demi moi je mettais déjà un demi-o
audessus donc by va rejoindre ce groupe
avec d fa CF prê que co mais tu vois il
peut même être apparié je pense pas
qu'il puisse être for mais enfin faut
vraiment je sais pas ce qu'il faut mais
ah non parce que CER DH fedos il a
combien d'élo 91
mais you il veut pas lâcher l'affaire
hein je va 5 on na pas vu de de problème
quoi non je bah on a dit on au pire tour
F1 quoi je dire t F1 c'est vraiment le
coup Finant de ouf
oui plus ve quoi en fait ça là vraiment
je fais tour F1 qui est le coup le plus
con possible moi je fais tour F c'est
sûr mais t B5 doit être un coup aussi
d'ailleurs promotion cavalier bon ça je
pense pas mais bon en fait il est joli
en fait le
professionali
tour F1
vraiment non pour moi yangil a un se
incroyable là c'est sûr non ouais pour
jouer jusque là c'est qu'il a le se bah
aussi peut-être parce qu'il a aussi il
s'est aussi fait éliminer de la enfin de
la même manière il s'est fait éliminer à
la Coupe du Monde de manière un peu
débile il était est gagnant et là il
refait le con je pense que ça lui fout
le seme puissance mais à chaque fois tu
t'en prends qu'à toi-même en fait c'est
ça le truc auss aux échec tu peux pas
genre ça te met le se
ouais pourra peut-être jouer le prochain
match de la su battle ah il doit avoir
le
SAM t B5 ouais très
bien ça devrait abandonner là quand
même
c'est une tour de moins
ou allez abandon de you on dit que c'est
signé sur la caméra les amis on va pas
faire de vieoso pour garder de l'énergie
pour pour demain et et du coup bah on se
retrouve demain à 15h30 attention pour
ceux qui seront pas là demain la ronde
de vendredi r vendredi commence
àh30 donc sur ce on se on se laisse et
on se retrouve comme ça demain avec de
l'énergie à 15h 45 d'ailleurs oui 15h30
le début de la ronde mais il y a du
délai donc 15h45 merci à tous passez une
excellente fin de soirée et ciao ciao